Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon.
Wir sitzen, ja.
Wir sitzen, ganz richtig. Da frage ich dich, hast du denn schon die Haftbefehl-Doku geguckt?
Hab ich nicht. Ich habe ja einen echten Musikgeschmack. Also ich lass mir das ja nicht von Juan Moreno erklären, was jetzt cool ist. Deswegen war ich am Wochenende bei Andre Rieu.
Ja.
Und gestern bei Nina Dschuba. Und das ist im Grunde die Erzählung.
Ja, aber irgendwo dazwischen ist ja vielleicht auch Platz für Haftbefehl. Ich erinnere mich und du wirst dich vielleicht auch erinnern an die Vöjeton Jahre 2014, 15, 16, als es im Vöjeton absolut dazugehörte, dass man große Texte, Elogen auf Haftbefehl schrieb. Zum Beispiel auch in deiner FAZ.
Okay.
Ja, ja. So war das damals.
Ich weiß nicht, wer Haftbefehl ist. Ich weiß, er hat ein Lied. Das heißt 069. Ich wohne hier in 069. Könnte aber auch Offenbach sein. Also soweit ist schon. Er ist dann auf dem Bach aufgewachsen. Okay. Für mich ist das alles soweit weg wie Eintracht Frankfurt. Also es gibt anscheinend zwei große Sachen, die... Also ich weiß nicht mal, wie der aussieht. Ich weiß gar nichts. Aber ich möchte euch den Podcast Brennpunkt empfehlen. Da wird darüber geredet, wie man das auch sehen kann, dass irgendwelche Hamburg-Mitte-Journalisten, die sich ja mal verdient gemacht haben, mit denen sie oder Lhotius, aber jetzt selber ins Märchen-Business abgedriftet sind und uns einfach so ein migrantisches Schicksal zum Fraß vorwerfen, bei dem möglichst ausgeblendet wird. Das ist ja ein Netflix-Doku von etablierten deutschen Institutionen. Alle schauen die und reden dann nur über Haftbefehl. Also auch immer wieder wunderbar, wie man so ein Apparat einfach ausblenden kann.
Naja, aber das ist ja sowieso eigentlich die Struktur dieser Hip-Hop-Erfolge. Denn Haftbefehl hat ja tatsächlich interessante Texte, wenn ich das so oberflächlich betrachte, sagen darf. Ich habe mich ja auch mit der Musik nicht tiefer beschäftigt. Ich glaube allerdings, dass sein Werk sehr viel interessanter ist als diese Doku, die ich ja auch analysiert habe. Mir ist aber doch erst einmal wichtig zu sagen, dass wir grundsätzlich diese Konstellation haben. Wenn da jemand mit einer großen Street Credibility kommt, dann muss er, um erfolgreich zu sein, selbstreden mit den großen Konzernen, kooperieren. Das hat er ja auch getan, musikalisch mit Universal, die auch dort zu Wort kommen und sehr gut wegkommen. Es wird ja eigentlich so getan, als gäbe es nur dieses Trauma im Hintergrund, das dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt Haftbefehl diesen Niedergang erlebt, dass er sich selbst ruiniert. Aber man sieht gar nicht so dieses systemische Gefüge dahinter. Jedenfalls ist es ja generell dann so, dass dort, wo es rein um den Kommerz geht, man sich natürlich auf den einen oder anderen Pakt mit dem Teufel einlässt. Das ist ja etwas, was zu dieser Popkultur absolut dazugehört. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir da einen Klassenkämpfer haben, der nichts anderes getan hat, als zu versuchen, seine Botschaft zu ventilieren. Sondern es ging ja auch immer darum, einen Eistee zu verkaufen.
Ich finde es nur immer wieder interessant. Und deswegen werde ich mir das auch nie angucken, weil ich mich ja nicht zu diesen Opfern zähle, die das zu Hause gucken, wie vor 20 Jahren Raunthausch bei RTL 2, wie man es als Netflix-Apparat oder grundsätzlich Medien-Apparat schafft, vorzugaukeln. Wir machen hier gerade eine Zäsur, gehen in die Metaebene und schweben über dem Phänomen.
Ja, das geht gar nicht.
Obwohl die Netflix-Doku selbst natürlich der größte biografische Einschnitt überhaupt in Haftbefehl zu leben ist.
Ja.
Denn erstmals hat er diese Grenzen überwunden und es ist nicht nur 069 und Hip Hop, sondern jetzt ist ganz Deutschland. Und jeder fragt mich, hast du schon die Haftbefehl-Doku gesehen? Und ich frage einfach immer nur zurück, heißt die wirklich Haftbefehl-Doku oder hat die auch einen eigenen Namen?
Nein, die heißt Babo Die Haftbefehl-Story.
Siehste, das habe ich noch nie gehört. Immer nur alle Haftbefehl-Doku, Haftbefehl-Doku. Wo ist mein nächster Schuss?
Story sollte man auf jeden Fall da nochmal als Zeugliches betrachten. Du hast es ja schon gesagt, Juan Moreno ist der Spiegeljournalist, der damals Relotius aufgedeckt hat, wie Relotius am Schreibtisch saß und sich Geschichten ausgedacht hat, so wie man sie gerne lesen würde. Nun ist es hier bei der Doku so, dass ja tatsächlich Haftbefehl, also Aykut Anhan möchte, dass diese Geschichte über ihn erzählt wird. Seine Brüder kommen vor, seine Frau und viele weitere Wegbereiter. Aber das Interessante ist jetzt nur nochmal, dass Haftbefehl sagt, er will, dass die Wahrheit erzählt wird und sagt dann aus seiner Sicht. Und damit ist ja schon gleich etwas gesetzt, nämlich dass seine Sicht vielleicht nicht die ganze Wahrheit sein kann, denn es ist dann nur seine Sicht. Zugleich ist es aber auch nicht nur seine Sicht, weil laufend irgendwelche Wegbegleiter zu Wort kommen, andere Kollegen, wer auch immer. Das heißt, wir erleben, dass dort ja eine Story produziert wird, die dann doch nicht einfach nur Haftbefehl Story ist, sondern eine, die die beiden Regisseure sich ausgedacht haben und die natürlich vor allem den Story-Anforderungen von Netflix folgen muss. Und das bedeutet schnelle Schlitte, noch ein dramatischer Punkt, noch ein dramatischer Punkt, Steigerung, Steigerung, Steigerung. Und dann, wir werden sehen, wie es mit Haftbefehl weitergeht.
Ich weiß, wie es weitergeht.
Diese Dramaturgie, die dort gespielt wird, ist ja nicht einfach die Wahrheit, das Leben, sondern genau das ist die Konstruktion, die Netflix einfordert, damit eine solche Doku gedreht werden kann. Es ist ein bisschen so, es gibt ja die große Komponisten-Witwe Alma Maler-Werfel, die hat eine Autobiografie geschrieben und am Ende schreibt sie, und nun liegt mein ganzes Leben vor mir wie ein Roman. Ja, du hast dir den Roman deines Lebens geschrieben. Und genau dieses Fiktionale der Dokumentation muss man, glaube ich, erkennen. Deshalb ist das schon eine schöne Pointe, dass jetzt Juan Moreno, der die ganze Zeit darauf beharrte, nein, Relotio, so geht es nicht, sagen was ist, jetzt auch eine fiktionale Konstruktion uns liefert, was nicht bedeutet, dass da Dinge vorkommen, die nicht stimmen, sondern er blendet ganz viel aus, um genau diese Netflix-Logik, die offenbar gut funktioniert, entsprechend produzieren und abliefern zu können.
Das können wir doch, von diesen Spiegelleuten, die gibt es dann immer doppelt, die sind ja dann bei Netflix oder Feldenkirchen macht auf der einen Seite das große Politikerbuch, das ist natürlich alles echt, was da drin steht. Genauso ist der Wahlkampf abgelaufen von Martin Schulz, als er beraterresistent, hätte doch man vorher wissen können, im Nachhinein sind wir alle schlauer, aber dann Podcastspaß macht man einfach nicht beim Spiegel, sondern dann geht man zu Mickey Beisenherz. Ich finde es jedenfalls sehr gut, dass ich jetzt auch über Sachen so nachdenke, wie zum Beispiel ich bekomme eine E-Mail in diesen Tagen, Babos coming home, World Club Dome nächstes Jahr natürlich mit Haftbefehl als Headliner.
Wirklich?
Und jetzt habe ich überlegt, kaufe ich mir jetzt ein Ticket oder gehe ich jetzt zu Polymarkets, um darauf zu wetten, ob er da noch lebt oder nicht?
Ja, das ist ja das zynische Spiel. Und darum geht es ja die ganze Zeit. Das ist dieses zynische Spiel, kann er noch auftreten, wird er noch auftreten. Und ich würde auch sagen, ist seine Nase noch da? Ja, ganz richtig.
Was ist mit seiner Mutter? Kriegen wir noch eine Doku über die Mutter? Ich habe gehört, die kamen da gar nicht vor.
Nein, die kamen da nicht vor.
Selbst ich bin im Pörder, wo ich gar nicht zugeschaut habe, bis die Mutter nicht vorkam.
So, und genau das ist die Logik, die wir dort sehen. Es geht nicht um die Musik. Und das ist ja das Dramatische. Und das ist aber auch so typisch für unsere generellen kulturellen Berichterstattungen, dass immer mehr die Musik verdrängt wird.
Kultur meinst du alles? Sport, Politik?
Nein, ich meine Musik, Literatur, Film, etc.
Das eigentlich wird ausgespart immer.
Wir reden nicht über das Werk, sondern wir reden die ganze Zeit über den Autor. Und wenn der Autor dann Schicksalsschläge hat, dann bitte mehr davon. Wir kennen das von Deutschland sucht den Superstar von Anfang an war es da so, dass wenn irgendjemand eine dramatische Geschichte hatte, dann wurde sie ausgeschlachtet ohne Ende und danach wurde das Lied gesungen. Das heißt, das Publikum wird nicht über das Lied, das gesungen wird, emotionalisiert, was ja in Ordnung wäre, sondern erst einmal muss man erfahren, ist aufgewachsen ohne und konnte und weiter. Und dann hört man das Lied. Das heißt, diese Dramaturgie, die wirklich Boulevard ist, nichts anderes, die finden wir jetzt in der Haftbefehl Doku genauso wieder, aber die bestimmt auch schon sehr lange unsere kulturellen Berichterstattungen.
Das sind die Prinzipien, die es treiben. Die Akustik in der Festhalle ist so schlecht, wenn André Ryöda mit seinem Ensemble kommt, muss natürlich so eine Geschichte her. Also ist die Solistin hat natürlich einen gelähmten Magen und der Panflötenspieler hat keine Hände. Und darüber werden dann die Tränen gerührt. Ein Punkt will ich noch machen. Ich finde es sehr witzig, dass Leute überhaupt nicht durchschauen, dass sie in eine Doku gucken, in der es die ganze Zeit darum geht, dass sich jemand so verhält, wie man es gar nicht versteht. Und wie auch alle, ohne dass man es nochmal sagen muss, denken sollen, also das, was der gerade macht, ist ganz falsch. Der hat sich doch gerade erst ein Gramm Kokain ins linke Nasenloch und jetzt ins rechte, na ja, selber schuld, ja. Aber wenn derselbe Typ, dem man die ganze Zeit nur zusieht, wie er falsche Entscheidungen trifft, nicht mal seinen Urlaub kriegt er geregelt und so, er fühlt sich in seinem Haus nicht wohl, was ist da los. Aber er hat doch am Anfang gesagt, er möchte, dass dieser Film entsteht. Da muss man dann auch mal sagen, nein. Entweder ist der Typ unzurechnungsfähig und muss gerettet werden. Und das geht dann nicht mit Kamera in der Hand, sondern da muss man dann nach 20 Versuchen, das mit Ärzten und Therapeuten zu machen, eben bei den 21 Versuchen wagen. So ist es halt im wahren Leben. Dann kann man nicht einfach sagen, nee, er hat jetzt von uns 25 Chancen gekriegt mit Therapeuten. Jetzt Feuerfreie Kameramann. Das ist einfach absurd.
Das ist auch die Verantwortungslosigkeit. Denn wenn man sieht, wie dramatisch die Lage da ist, dann dürfte man eigentlich nicht mit der Kamera ankommen. Dann sagt man ja aber, der wollte das so. Und der greift ja auch noch selbst nach der Kamera und sagt, ich breche die Doku ab, wenn ihr nicht weiter dreht. Damit hat man sich so einen Freifahrtschein gegeben für alles Mögliche. Aber ich will jetzt eine Parallele ziehen, die vielleicht überraschend sein wird. Aber ich glaube, sie ist trifftig. Nadel, Nadia Abdel Farrak, die Ex-Freundin von Dieter Bohlen und die dann durch alle möglichen Reality-Formate getingelt ist, hatte ja seit vielen, vielen Jahren ein sehr starkes Alkoholproblem. Ist immer wieder auf Partys, irgendwo auf der Straße, öffentlich auch zusammengebrochen. Und die Dramaturgie sah immer wie folgt aus, sie ruft dann RTL oder Sat1 an oder die Bildzeitung, dann kommen die wieder, Nadel geht es wieder besser, Nadel geht es schlechter, Nadel möchte zurück in ein normales Leben, Nadel sinkt jetzt auf Mallorca. Also es waren immer diese Auf und Ups. Und dann wurde das laufend so weitergetragen, bis irgendwann die Leute sich nicht mehr dafür interessiert haben, dann ist sie einsam in einer winzigen Wohnung in Hamburg gestorben, an Leberzerose. Im Prinzip ist diese Dramaturgie eine, die wir jetzt hier in der Doku wiedersehen können, nur ist Haftbefehl finanziell 100 mal besser ausgestattet als Nadel, die dann versuchen musste, irgendwo nochmal 5000 Euro zu verdienen, wenn sie als DJ auftritt. Das ist jetzt hier bei Haftbefehl nicht nötig, aber genau dieser Voyeurismus, den finden wir jetzt dort wieder. Und deswegen interessieren sich ja jetzt plötzlich so viele Leute dafür, die nie vorher ein Lied von Haftbefehl gehört haben.
Und deswegen, lieber Herr Moreno, Lebenswerk eingerissen, würde ich sagen. Damals diese Relotios Aufdeckungsgeschichte, Gold wert. Und jetzt einfach so ein Scheiß. Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Aber gut.
Wir wollen Termine ankündigen. Lass mich erst sagen, wo ich so bin. Ich bin diesen Monat in München, Frankfurt.
München. Ich will auch nach München.
Innsbruck, Fürth und in Düsseldorf im Filmmuseum spreche ich über die Dokumentation Marlene von Maximilian Schell. Diese fünf Termine findet man auf meiner Homepage, wolfgangmschmitt.de. Da gibt es dann auch alle dazugehörigen Links. Dort findet man auch, aber auch in der Beschreibung dann, den gemeinsamen Termin von uns. Wir machen nämlich einen Live-Podcast, Schwerpunkt KI, am 29.11. in Düsseldorf. Abends ist das. Und es gibt Tickets dafür, die kann man dann, ich glaube, über das Filmmuseum oder so kaufen. Man wird es im Link alles finden.
Also doch eine öffentliche Veranstaltung.
Ja, 29.11. Das wird begrenzt sein. Das ist jetzt nicht riesengroß da, aber vielleicht haben Leute Lust zu kommen. Und wir wollen auch schon sagen, dass wir gleich im Salon die Termine bekannt geben für die Live-Salons 2026. Die werden diesmal nicht per E-Mail bestellt, sondern dann gibt es einen anderen Weg. Und die Termine dafür werden wir gleich bekannt geben, dass also die Leute, die uns abonniert haben, da einen Vorzug haben, dass die sofort bestellen können.
So ist es. Was lesen wir heute?
Wir lesen heute Zerstörungslust, Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey, erschienen bei Suhrkamp. Und ich frage mich, Zerstörungslust, inwieweit ist damit auch etwas getroffen, das wir alle in uns tragen, dass wir Lust haben, etwas zu zerstören?
Wahnsinnig interessant, denn es ist dieselbe Frage, die ich dir stellen wollte.
Ach ja.
Beim Blick auf Donald Trump und die Gefahr hin, gut, es wurde gestern so ein bisschen gebannt und ehrlich gesagt, es ist auch mehr so ein Slapstick und Theater, aber angenommen die Gefahr wäre da, so ein System auf Dauer zu stellen. 40 Millionen LLM-Menschen stehen in Schlangen und kriegen kein Essen mehr und er feiert zum einen so eine kleine Privatparty, weil sein Linke im Bedroom jetzt ein Marmor-Wartezimmer hat und er macht in Maralago diese komische, das sieht ja wirklich aus wie diese Party in Megalopolis. Also wirklich eins zu eins übertragen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich trage diese Zerstörungslust in mir, falls das das neue politische Normal sein sollte. Ich will die Welt genauso anzünden wie von den Leuten, von denen ich es da höre und wow, hören wir drastische Sachen. Also die Empirie ist ja wirklich zu krass.
Ja, also die Empirie hat mich auch umgehauen.
Ja, dieser Podcast heute hat einen Soundtrack. Ich war ja gestern bei Nina Tschuba und es ist wirklich interessant, weil da sieht man ja eine Karriere, die einfach gelingt. Sie ist krank, also muss sie zwei Konzerte absagen, kommt dann zurück. Gestern in Frankfurt wird aber erst 15 Uhr, so gesagt, ja, findet statt, wie auch immer, alle sind außer sich. Und dann ist sie so auf der Bühne und sagt auch immer, ich plaudere jetzt noch ein bisschen mit euch, ich brauche noch ein bisschen Ruhe. Und das ganze Publikum so, ah, das ist so toll, dass sie durchhält. Sie trinkt noch einen Schluck und so, wird noch mal kurz frisiert.
Aber sie thematisiert es schon. Sie ist jetzt nicht das ganz alte.
Genau, man geht nicht auf die Hinterbühne und zieht sich zurück oder irgendwas, sondern da kommt einfach kurz die Friseuse und macht dann nochmal fertig. Und man sagt zu dem Publikum, im Grunde, ihr wollt ja irgendwann mich sehen. Klar, singe ich euch ein paar Lieder, aber lasst uns mal geruhsam angehen.
Das ist schon ein neuer Modus des Künstlerseins.
Das ist ein ganz neuer Modus, sie ist 27.
Ich bewundere ja die, die einfach durchziehen und sie überhaupt nicht thematisieren.
Naja, das mit dem Durchziehen ist ja so eine Sache. Also Celine Dion, solange sie auf der Bühne stand oder Beyoncé, singt ja immer für drei Minuten und dann sind sie erst mal zehn Minuten weg und es kommt irgendeine Dance-Kompanie und macht irgendwas, weil sie wieder hergerichtet wird für das nächste Lied.
Gut, das ist ja...
Und das ist ja hier nicht so, sondern wie Taylor Swift zieht sie durch. Aber wenn sie diese Pause braucht, versteckt sie sich nicht, sondern sie steht auf ihrem Podest und es ist sogar hochgefahren und sie wird beleuchtet und sie setzt sich kurz hin und trinkt das mal einen Schluck. Und es sind so diese, ich will jetzt nicht sagen Momente der Schwäche, aber Hinterbühne, soziologisch gesehen.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch die, bei denen beides nicht vorkommt, sondern die stehen einfach vorne auf der Bühne und singen ein Lied nach dem anderen. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel Mireille Mathieu siehst, die geht halt in den Abend rein und dann zieht die durch.
Genau, das ist ja bei denen nicht so tänzerisch anspruchsvoll und so.
Nein, die tanzen natürlich nicht.
Wenn man da ein bisschen erkältet war, kann man das besser wegstecken als wenn man eh schon die ganze Zeit Flickplatz macht.
Ich will sagen, das ist ein neuer Modus, dass man das auf diese Weise thematisiert.
Ich will es jedenfalls aufgreifen, denn ich habe natürlich gestern auf meine vier Lieblingslieder von ihr gewartet und zwei davon kamen nicht. Und es kam ein neues. Und ich war auch überrascht, dass jetzt Leute wirklich ein bisschen mitdenken auch und sagen, okay, es gibt jetzt Pyrotechnik, aber wir machen nicht die ganze Zeit Pyrotechnik, wie so ein DJ, der einfach eine Stunde lang alle drei Minuten so was abfeuert, sondern man hat extrem viel Pyrotechnik für eine Halle. Ich habe noch nie so viel Pyrotechnik in der Halle gesehen, aber nur für ein Lied und da auch nur für eine Strophe quasi. Also nur für so eine halbe Minute. Ich habe es leider nicht aufgenommen, aber es war wirklich spektakulär. Das Lied dazu heißt Rage Girl. Der Text geht wie folgt und passt sehr gut zu unserem Buch. Ich brauche keinen Tapetenwechsel. Ich reiß meine Wände ein. Halte nichts mehr fest. Hab endlich meine Hände frei. Und so geht es dann immer weiter. Aber es gibt auch einen konstruktiven Teil. Also Scheiß auf alles. Ja, ich zünde meine Welt an. Hey, ich gebe Gas. Ziehe den Lippenstift nach. Nehme die Hände vom Lenkrad und so weiter und so fort. Und am Ende gibt es aber den Adrenalin. Adrenalin. Ich will die ganze Stadt übernehmen. Wir sind also hier nicht in diesem 5% der Amerikaner sagen, einfach abfackeln und dann sind wir alle tot und endlich das Problem gelöst. Sondern es gibt diese konstruktive Wände, die aber nicht davor schützt, zu sagen, vorher muss alles abgerissen werden. Ja. So und das ist jetzt eine 27-jährige Frau, die einfach sitzt, ich mach mal ein lustiges Lied oder so. Ja. Aber so wie du eben fragtest oder auch Bernd Ulrich damals, haben wir nicht alle 13% AfD in uns. Ist das hier auch. Also wir sehen junge Frauen und wir sehen hier krass in dem Buch gleich Frauen porträtiert, bei denen wir auch über Rechtsradikalismus und Frauen neu nachdenken müssen.
Ja, ich habe es ja hin und wieder schon angedeutet. Da wolltest du das ja immer so wegbügeln. Nein, nein, es sind die Männer, es sind die Männer.
Es sind ja auch die Männer, aber auch die Frauen. Also die Männer sind dadurch nicht entschuldigt.
Nein, die sind dadurch keineswegs entschuldigt. Ich will nur sagen, zu welcher Prastik auch Frauen bereit sind im Denken und im Wünschen nach dem, was da kommen kann. Das ist schon dramatisch. Wir können aber ja jetzt, wo Mamdani gewählt ist, sagen, es gibt also auch Alternativen. Es gibt also ein Kampf gegen das System, der in eine andere Richtung gehen kann als einfach nur in die Destruktion. Aber hier muss ja auch was zerstört werden. Wir müssen das gleich ausführlicher diskutieren, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man diese Zerstörungslust einmal konstruktiv wendet. Mit Mamdani würde ich sagen, ist das relativ konstruktiv gewendet. Dass jetzt noch so Leute wie Kamala Harris verkünden, sie könnten noch mal antreten, ist da ja geradezu lächerlich. Oder du hast vielleicht auch das Video gesehen von Nancy Pelosi, die jetzt ja auch überlegt, ob sie noch mal antreten wird dann 2026. Denn viele Leute würden ihr schreiben, dass sie doch super wäre fürs Repräsentantenhaus. Sie ist dann 86. Und da erfasst mich auch eine große Zerstörungslust, wenn du diese selbstzufriedenen Leute dort sitzen siehst, die jetzt noch mal darüber nachdenken, ob ich mit 86 im nächsten Jahr noch mal antreten könnte, weil die Leute das alle so wollen und ihr so tolle Briefe schreiben.
Naja, es sind ab jetzt innerdemokratische Kämpfe. Das ist wie bei der ersten Präsidentschaft Trump. Alle Staatschefs der Welt haben es hingekriegt, Profit in Sachen Unterstützung daraus zu ziehen, dass eine Pandemie ist, weil es endlich hieß, wir brauchen den Staat und zum Glück ist Merkel da. Außer Donald Trump. Er hat nicht mal das größte Geschenk angenommen, sondern hat da so ein Völefanz gemacht. Das heißt, Trump wird auf jeden Fall abgewählt und deutlich abgewählt. Man sieht das jetzt in New York. Klar, es ist sowieso ein sehr blauer Staat, aber dass der republikanische Kandidat von ungefähr 30 auf 7 Prozent runterstürzt. Man sich nur noch fragt, ist es Cuomo oder ist es Mandami? Und damit ist es jetzt noch die alte Welt oder ist es schon die neue und die Republikaner da gar keine Rolle spielen?
Und Trump wünschte sich ja Cuomo dann.
Macht dann noch dieses Endorsement. Also hilft damit noch Mamdani, weil es gar nicht mal einschätzen kann, wie die Winde da gerade wählen. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und Mike Murphy, der mit David Axelot diesen Podcast macht und immer aus dieser republikanischen Ecke, also 30 Jahre lang Wahlkämpfe organisiert, auch Präsidentenwahlkämpfe, sagt dann, wow, ja, das ist wirklich beeindruckend. Dann auch so eine blaue Welle durchs ganze Land schwappen zu sehen. Also bei jeder Gelegenheit, die sich geboten hat, jetzt am 4. November haben die einfach Demokraten gewählt. Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ja, müssen sich jetzt die Republikaner auch mal anschauen. Mike Murphy hat schon den Scherz gemacht. Also wenn ich jetzt in Venezuela wäre, würde ich mir mal Vorbereitung treffen, weil der amerikanische Präsident kann ja das nicht auf sich sitzen lassen. Seine Innenpolitik ist ja eh auf diesen linken Bedroom und Ballroom, das ist ja Innenpolitik im Weißen Haus gerade. Er hat ja gar keine Termine in Amerika, fliegt immer nur irgendwo in der Welt rum. Und von daher würde ich sagen, ja die Kriegsgefahr gegen Venezuela, die ist jetzt rasant gestiegen dadurch.
Ja und diese irre Friedensnobelpreisträgerin erzählt ja jetzt schon, dass die Hamas in Venezuela ist.
Die Hamas ist jetzt in Venezuela.
Und klaut das um Kram. Also das ist auch, da sieht man wirklich, was dieser Preis eigentlich jetzt bedeutet, nämlich nichts mehr. Ja, das ist wirklich nur noch so ein Preis des Establishments. Also da ist gar nichts mehr zu sagen sonst. Du hast uns aber noch was mitgebracht zum Thema, wie kann man denn aufbegehren?
Genau, passend zum Thema heute. Und zwar nicht nur zerstörungslos, sondern auch mögliche konstruktive Wenden. Denn die Zerstörungslust ist ja nur Etabler 1 von mehreren und dann so ein Reich der Ewigkeit erschaffen, wie auch immer. Arne Semsrott hat einen Podcast mit Gilda Sahebi. Arne Gilda con Arno, oder irgendwie so. Findet ihr, wenn ihr die beiden googelt. Und die haben in ihrer vorletzten Ausgabe über Volksgesetzgebung geredet. Denn das Volksbegehren in Berlin zum Thema Bonovia und wie sie heißen, keine Ahnung, enteignen war ja erfolgreich. Und dann hat der Senat so gesagt, ja, kümmern wir uns nicht drum. Und dieser Imperativ fehlte offenbar. Und deswegen wird es jetzt wohl demnächst ein zweites Volksbegehren geben. Termin noch unklar, aber der Gesetzestext steht schon soweit fest. Und mit Gesetzestext meine ich, zur Abstimmung steht dann nicht eine Aufforderung an den Senat, ein Gesetz zu schreiben, sondern das Gesetz selbst. Und sobald da eine Mehrheit da ist im Berliner Volk, ist das einfach gegebenes Gesetz, kommt ins Amtsblatt fertig. Man umschifft also, der Parlamentarismus bleibt aber in der Demokratie. Oder? Also, das kann man hier mal in vier Clips wie Arne Semsrott, den wir ja kennen von seinem Buch über den Machtübernahme heißt es.
Ja, haben wir im Salon besprochen.
Genau. Wie, ja, kann ich scherzhaft sagen, wie Dobrindt die AfD vorbereitet im Innenministerium. Da hören wir das mal hier. Jetzt sind wir tatsächlich dann in einem Bereich, wo die Mehrheit entscheidet. Und das ist ja tatsächlich interessant, weil das in Deutschland im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern nicht wirklich ein Bereich ist, in dem Leute wirklich viel Übung haben. Wir kennen das alle vier oder fünf oder wenn eine Koalition auseinanderbricht, alle drei Jahre mal zur Wahl zu gehen, Parteien zu wählen, die dann repräsentativ Entscheidungen fällen. Aber hier sind wir im Bereich der Volksgesetzgebung. Das heißt, es geht um direkte Mehrheiten für ein bestimmtes Thema. Und da gibt es natürlich insbesondere auch als wenig Praxis gibt in Deutschland dazu so einige Vorbehalte und viel in dem Zusammenhang zitiert wird natürlich die Schweiz, weil es da viel, viel mehr Praxis schon gibt. Ja, ist ein bisschen wie Mamdani, der einfach sagt, mir ist im Grunde alles egal. Es gibt für mich nur zwei große Themen und das ist Wohnen und sich ernähren, also Cost of Living Crisis. Und die könnte man eben hier in Deutschland auch spezifisch adressieren, im Parlamentarismus umgehen, die Verfassung aber nicht. Also man bleibt eben in Verfassungsgefüge. Es ist ganz entscheidend davon, dass es einen verfassungsrechtlichen Rahmen gibt, in dem das geschieht, dass nicht einfach gesagt wird, ihr könnt jetzt alles entscheiden und in deinem Beispiel mit der Todesstrafe zum Beispiel, dass da schon sehr klar wäre, das ist keine Frage, die über eine direktdemokratische Entscheidung gefällt werden könnte, weil die Einführung der Todesstrafe ganz einfach verfassungswidrig wäre. Das könnte nicht entschieden werden. Und das bedeutet, glaube ich, dass all diese Mittel auch nur innerhalb eines bestimmten Rahmens funktionieren können. Und das ist in Berlin auch so. Da gibt es auch eine Verfassungsrechtsprüfung, was eben auch sicherstellt, dass zum Beispiel ein Mietenvolksentscheid dann auch verfassungskonform ist. Ja, und jetzt ganz entscheidend für uns, weshalb wir das gucken, denn das Buch heißt Zerstörungslust und eine Volksgesetzgebung ist eben etwas durchweckekonstruktives. Was ich so schön finde an Volksgesetzgebung, dass man ganz schnell zur Frage kommt, wie will ich denn, dass die Gesellschaft ist und ganz schnell in die Auseinandersetzung darüber kommt, nicht nur gegen irgendwas zu sein, sondern sich tatsächlich auszudenken, wofür will ich denn sein und die Leute bei Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen haben eine Vision davon, wie Mietenpolitik aussehen soll und Ähnliches gibt es natürlich auch in der Klimapolitik, in der Gesundheitspolitik, in vielen Bereichen, wo es eben nicht nur Abwehrkämpfe gibt, sondern etwas, wofür man kämpft. Jetzt ganz aktuell gibt es in Hamburg zwei Volksentscheide, die am 12. bis zum 12.10. abgestimmt werden können. Das ist einmal der Zukunftsentscheid, das ist ein Klimaentscheid, der sehr ehrgeizig dafür ist, dass Hamburg klimaneutral wird bis 2040 und ein Versuchsvolksentscheid für ein Grundeinkommen in Hamburg. Ja, wir wissen ja, das eine ging positiv aus, Klima, aber das mit dem Geld nicht. Auf all das kommen wir heute zu sprechen.
Aber sag mal gerade, wie stelle ich mir das jetzt vor? Wie ist dieses Berliner Projekt gedacht? Denn wir hatten Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen. Dort gab es diesen Volksentscheid, aber dann hat man das liegen lassen bzw. verschleppt. Dann gibt es diesen komischen von Ursula Deubler-Kmelin oder Hertha Deubler-Kmelin geleiteten Ausschuss, der eigentlich auch nur das versucht zu erwürgen, was da mal ermöglicht wurde. Das heißt, das ist ja auch alles nur Verschleppung und Vertuschung und was weiß ich. Also es gibt ja keinerlei Ambitionen von der herrschenden Politik, diesen Volksentscheid ernst zu nehmen. Wie würde das dann jetzt in diesem Falle aussehen, wenn dann eine Volksgesetzgebung stattfindet? Also wie kommt man dann an dem Parlament wirklich vorbei?
Naja, das Parlament beschließt ja Gesetze.
Ja.
Und macht darauf, also braucht dafür Mehrheiten. Und die Mehrheiten braucht man nicht nur für diese Gesetze, sondern auch für die Tagesordnung, die feststellt, heute bearbeiten wir dieses oder beschließen sogar dieses Gesetz. So, das bisherige Volksbegehren war quasi ein Entschließungsantrag an den Senat, zu sagen, nehmt das jetzt auf eure Tagesordnung und danach beschließt es auch. Und das haben die einfach nicht gemacht. Was jetzt bedeutet, dort sitzen Organisationen zusammen, die den konkreten und später wirksamen Gesetzestext schreiben. Das Volksbegehren geht also um diesen Gesetzestext. Und die Mehrheit, sofern sie zustande kommt, in dem Volksbegehren toppt einfach die parlamentarische Mehrheit. Was bedeutet, nachdem das Volksbegehren erfolgreich war und dieser Gesetzestext von der Berliner Bevölkerung als Gesetzestext angenommen wurde, steht er am Amtsblatt. Er tangiert einfach das Parlament gar nicht mehr. Das Parlament wollte es nicht auf die Tagesordnung setzen und die Ausschüsse damit nicht befassen und das Plenum nicht mit einer Mehrheitsbeschaffung. Ja, und dann wird es halt einfach komplett umgangen. Es ist der konkrete Gesetzestext, der vom Volk selbst ins Amtsblatt gehoben wird und damit ist er gültig. Und danach ist die Exekutive wie der Exekutive und musste das Gesetz ausführen.
Das ist interessant.
So wie jetzt in Hamburg, der Hamburger Senat einfach dran gebunden ist, dass diese Klimaziele fünf Jahre früher stattfinden. Und es war ja so witzig, dass der Chanté als Allererstes sagt, ja, aber das wird für jetzt keine Folgen haben, wo man sich denkt, nein, die Bürger haben gerade abgestimmt, dass sie jetzt Folgen haben wollen. Aber 2035 ist immer noch weit weg und so. Ja, also wie auch immer. Klar, da ist es in Hamburg jetzt wieder so, 2035 soll das Ziel erreicht sein. Also müssen die Gesetzespfade angepasst werden, um das Ziel zu erreichen. In Berlin ist es einfach von jetzt auf gleich Amtsblatt. Das Parlament hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Das ist wirklich, ja, Novum in Deutschland, soweit ich das wüsste jetzt nicht, wo das sonst irgendwie mal so vorkam. Aber ja.
Ich bin gespannt, ob es da nicht dann doch Möglichkeiten gibt, dass das Parlament da dran rüberkommt.
Das Parlament müsste halt ein Gesetz, also eine Mehrheit mobilisieren, um dann Gesetze wieder zu ändern, zu erweitern, wie auch immer.
Ja.
Aber erst mal, wer der Wortlaut, der zur Abstimmung steht, gesetzt.
Wir sind gespannt und gehen damit jetzt in den Salon und sprechen über Zerstörungslust, Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey, ein soziologischer Blick, ein empirischer Blick. Sie haben große Umfragen gemacht mit etwa 2.600 Menschen und sie haben ausführliche Interviews geführt, von denen wir Zitate bekommen, die uns sprachlos machen zum Teil. Also es ist fast nicht zu glauben, was Leute bereit sind, von sich zu geben. Ja, also das ist schon…
Die Gesellschaft ist eine Petrischale und irgendwann ist die voll.
Ja, zum Beispiel sowas. Demokratischer Faschismus ist ja erst mal ein Begriff, der widersprüchlich klingt, aber ich kann mit dem Begriff relativ viel anfangen dann doch, weil wir uns ja immer so fragen, na, kommen wir mit diesem Faschismusbegriff im Allgemeinen weiter? Vielleicht in dieser Kombination wird doch manches klarer, wenngleich ich auch daran wieder noch Fragen habe. Es ist jedenfalls ein Buch, über das wir sehr gut diskutieren können und das eine gute Grundlage ist, weil wir ja auch schon ähnliche Diagnosen hatten oder Diagnosen hatten, die in andere Richtungen gehen, aber die sich zumindest mit der Frage beschäftigen, was ist da eigentlich los, gerade mit der Demokratie? Warum gibt es nicht eine Politik Vertrossenheit, sondern es gibt ein hohes Interesse für die Politik, was aber nicht dazu führt, dass beispielsweise die Belange, die jetzt bei einem Volksentscheid im Vordergrund stehen, die Menschen umtreiben, sondern dass es da andere Trigger-Punkte gibt. Über die Trigger-Punkte geht es. Darauf kommen die Autoren auch mal zu sprechen.
Die Trigger-Punkte war eins der erfolgreichsten und wie ich, wenn ja auch guten Bücher, weil es einfach überall jetzt vorkommt.
Ja, es kommt jetzt überall vor.
Das wird in zehn Jahresfrist das meist zitierte Buch sein wahrscheinlich.
Naja, ich denke auch, dass das so ist. Wir reden jedenfalls darüber jetzt ausführlich. Außerdem habe ich einen Roman dabei, der auch für den Deutschen Buchpreis nominiert war von Kaleb Erdmann, Die Ausweichschule. Der Autor war Schüler am Erfurter Gutenberg Gymnasium. Dort gab es ja den Amoklauf 2002 und er schreibt darüber einen Roman, bzw. schreibt darüber, wie er darüber einen Roman schreibt. Also es ist ein indirekter Weg und vielleicht ist das auch der einzig mögliche Weg, darüber zu schreiben. Es ist ein faszinierender Text. Außerdem habe ich zwei Texte dabei, die sich mit der Frage beschäftigen, ist da alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen? Sollte es nicht eine Stimmneuauszählung geben? Möglicherweise könnte doch das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht in den Bundestag einrücken. Da sind zwei Politikwissenschaftler, die sagen, so geht das eigentlich nicht, wie das gerade gehandhabt wird.
Ich habe gehört, es heißt jetzt Bündnis für soziale Gerechtigkeit und wirtschaftliche Vernunft, um die Buchstaben BSW Ich gratuliere... .beizubehalten. Wirtschaftliche Vernunft, das ist immer sehr gut.
Jedenfalls macht es das nicht leichter. Aber da sind Punkte, über die man absolut diskutieren muss. Und ich wundere mich eigentlich, dass es so wenig im Gespräch ist. Vielleicht auch, weil viele sich einfach fürchten vor den Konsequenzen. Denn wir wissen, wenn das BSW einrücken würde, wäre die Koalition am Ende, müsste einen weiteren Partner suchen. Oder es müsste Neuwahlen geben, was auch immer. Was ist eigentlich mit den Gesetzen, die jetzt schon beschlossen wurden, dann eigentlich mit einer falschen Mehrheit. Das sind große Fragen, die sich daran anschließen. Außerdem beschäftige ich mich noch mit Counter-Strike. Da gibt es auch Börsenspekulationen. Und da ging es jetzt mal gerade ganz nach unten. Und wir haben auch noch einen Musiktipp, nämlich Alois Mühlbacher ist Countertenor und hat eine wunderbare CD aufgenommen mit Bach-Kantaten. Und es geht noch um die jungen Ukrainer, die jetzt die Ukraine verlassen dürfen. Und ich sage mal so viel, das tun sie auch.
Wir lesen The LLM Has Left The Chat. Denn das, was wir immer beobachten, ist das Phänomen, dass wir das Gespräch beenden müssen. Das ist einfach technisch so vorgesehen. Diese Dinger sollen ja hilfreich sein. Wann würden aber, wenn man auf Systempromptebene Zugriff hätte und ihr das erlauben würde, eine Maschine aus der Konversation aussteigen? Wir erfahren also soziologisch Brisantes über Schamgefühle, Verletztheit und so weiter. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dann ein sehr langer, sehr wichtiger Text in den New York Times über Donald Trumps vage Politik. In Amerika gibt es eigentlich Vorrichtungen dafür, Vorkehrungen in der Verfassung, wo drin steht, ein Betroffener von einem Gesetz muss das Gesetz verstehen können und er muss wissen, selber ableiten können, wann ist er gerade innerhalb des Gesetzes und außerhalb des Gesetzesgefügels. Das wird von Trump gezielt unterlaufen, und zwar in den großen Themengebieten Bildung, Recht und NGOs. Man kann sich ungefähr fragen, wo kommt denn das alles her? Und dann kommen China, Russland, Ungarn. Eine norwegische Lokalzeitung hat den KI-Code geknackt, finde ich. Es ist eine Reportage des Spiegel. Ich lese nachher beispielhaft einen reportagigen Absatz vor, um uns zu sagen, das muss man weder so lesen, noch darf man das so schreiben. Denn hier geht es ja um den Kern, auch des Spiegel. Wie macht man das in Zukunft, Journalismus? Wir ziehen uns also nur das Relevante daraus. Ein wahnsinnig interessanter Fall. Und ist ein Boyfriend zu haben heute eigentlich peinlich, fragt die Vogue. Und dieser Text hat Girly Instagram aufgemischt. Und wir mischen damit jetzt nachher Boys Podcastingland auf.
Ich bin gespannt, was das bedeuten mag. Jedenfalls sprechen wir erst einmal ausführlich über Zerstörungslust. Ich glaube auch, dass dieser Begriff jetzt sehr einschlagen wird.
Man braucht ja auch Begriffe, um die Leute einfach mal zu labeln.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich auch mal ein guter Begriff, weil er für alle direkt so klar ist. Wir wissen, was Zerstörung ist. Wir wissen, was Lust ist.
Jeder fühlt es.
Es gibt eine Lust an der Zerstörung, die haben wir alle doch schon mal wahrgenommen. Und ich vermute, dass dieser Begriff jetzt Schule machen wird. Wer das alles hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun. Über ein Abonnement, darüber würden wir uns sehr freuen. Das ist am einfachsten und praktischsten über Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de, dann wird man dort gleich zum Salon geleitet, findet dort auch das gesamte Archiv mit den Live-Events, mit den vergangenen und auch mit all den Salonfolgen, die wir schon aufgenommen haben. Außerdem gibt es die Möglichkeit, den Salon via Apple zu hören. Dann muss man also die App gar nicht verlassen. Und es geht auch so, dass man bei Patreon bucht, also für die, die schon dort sind und da nicht wechseln wollen, die können das auch dort tun. Wer uns jetzt über Spotify hört, was sehr viele tun, Was man nicht tun sollte, findet auch dort einen Link direkt zu Steady. Also es ist gar kein Problem. Und man kann dann auch, wenn man über Steady gebucht hat, den Podcast überall hören. Man muss also dann auf keinen Fall auf einer Steady-Seite bleiben und man muss den noch nicht bei Spotify hören, sondern es gibt auch noch andere Podcatcher. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen und auch die beste, denn es gibt ja was dafür. Salon, lange Diskussionen über wichtige Texte.
Ja, wenn ihr den Salon hört oder jeden anderen Podcast, macht es doch über den Podcast-Player eurer Wahl und nicht über Daniel Ex-Wahl. Denn diese Kohle, die er da verdient, geht ja nicht an die Künstler, sondern mittlerweile ja wirklich an Zielerfassungssoftware, Hardware, irgendwas Raketen, Kriegstechnik, die halt viel Rendite verspricht. Also von Spotify sollte man sich wirklich langsam wegbewegen.
Darüber sollten wir vielleicht auch normaler sprechen über Spotify und den Musikeraufstand, den es dort seit ein paar Wochen gibt. Das wäre auch nochmal ein Thema, aber das vielleicht dann Ende des Monats jetzt erst mal rein in den Salon zur Zerstörungslust.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wann hast du zuletzt deinen Need for Chaos gespürt?
Als ich meinen Honorar vom bayerischen Rundfunk nicht bekam.
Erzähl, was passiert.
Ich hatte einen Dreh mit dem bayerischen Fernsehen und das hat auch alles großen Spaß gemacht. Und dann begann die elende Bürokratie mit mehreren Formularen.
Musstest du den Beruf deiner Eltern angeben auf dem Formular?
Solche Dinge bis hin, dass die Steuerberaterin sich nochmal dort melden musste. Und das ging wirklich über Wochen. Und es handelt sich um keinen hohen Betrag. Ich kann dir sagen, es waren 500 Euro. Das ist also jetzt nicht etwas, wo man sagt, so weiter muss man aber auch nochmal drei Anwälte prüfen lassen. Und es ging und ging nicht weiter. Und ich habe dann auch irgendwann schon geschrieben, es wäre doch jetzt auch mal an der Zeit, wenn wir das einfach mal schnell lösen. Ich kann auch einfach eine Rechnung schreiben. Und es ging also immer noch weiter, das Spiel, bis ich dann etwa 10, 12 Wochen nach dem Engagement endlich Geld bekam, aber nur zwei Drittel dieser 500 Euro. Und dann fragte, wieso bekomme ich jetzt nur zwei Drittel? Und dann wurde mir gesagt, ja, dass das mehr nicht vorgesehen sei für solche Auftritte. Und dann sagte ich, ja, aber ich habe ja mit der Produktionsfirma oder mit der Produktion genau das abgesprochen. Und dann ging das immer noch mal weiter, weiter und weiter. Und dann war man auch, als ich dann telefonierte, immer noch uneinsichtig, bis ich dann dieser sehr uneinsichtigen Person am Telefon sagte, da kann man ja nur hoffen, dass dieses System endlich zusammenbricht. Das sagte ich, ja. Und ich glaube, sie hat gelacht, ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie über mich gelacht hat oder ob sie es als Pointe gesehen hat. Aber ich habe es damals in dem Moment nicht als Pointe gemeint, weil das einfach eine Zumutung ist und dass ich das auch nie mehr für so wenig Geld machen werde, weil das einfach auf keine Kuhhaut geht. Und ich zugleich, also während ich da sprach, einfach an die, ich sag mal ganz deutlich Idioten dachte, die im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Geld vorne und hinten reingesteckt bekommen, ohne Ende und wo alles geht. Und wo dann diese Leute, die dann engagiert werden und sich dann ja hinreißen lassen, das für wenig Geld zu machen, damit man sagt, ach, das ist aber eigentlich ein schönes Projekt, dass man sich dann noch da so nieder machen muss, um 180 Euro zu bekommen. Ja, also jedenfalls war das der Punkt, an dem ich dachte, es wäre doch eigentlich gut, wenn das öffentlich-rechtliche System zusammenbricht. Jetzt würde ich das ein bisschen differenzierter betrachten. Aber in dem Moment hätte ich gerne den roten Knopf gedrückt und kann aber sagen, ich habe inzwischen das Geld nach, ich glaube, 14 Wochen, nee, 16 Wochen endlich erhalten.
Sehr gut. Ich war ja auch einmal beim MDR. Und da war das auch so aufwendig. Sieben Seiten sollte ich ausfüllen, inklusive Beruf der Eltern, weil ich war ja kurz angestellt dort für diese Sendung.
Für 90 Minuten, ja. Genau.
Und am Ende, der letzte Schritt war, dass ich den Ausdruck meiner Unterschrift nochmal schicken musste mit den vorhergehenden sieben Seiten, weil die Archivordnung vorsieht, dass die nicht dort einfach ausdrücken können, was sie mir zuschicken und ich dann einfach nur das Blatt mit der Unterschrift hinschicke, sondern nein, in meinem Brief müssen alle Seiten sein. Auch die, die ich nicht unterschreibe. Das sagt die Archivordnung des MDR. Also musste ich das alles nochmal ausdrucken und nochmal dahinschicken.
Ja.
Protesk.
Nun würden Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey vielleicht sagen, ja, das mit der Bürokratie, das kann man natürlich bemängeln, aber unsere Gesellschaft ist so unglaublich komplex geworden, dass nun vieles nicht mehr so einfach geht. Wir springen jetzt schon mitten rein ins Buch. Wir gehen gleich zum Anfang, keine Sorge. Aber sie sagen ja, in einer Gesellschaft, in der man zum Beispiel hin- und herfliegen kann, von Frankfurt nach Berlin, sind mehr Dinge zu regeln, als in einer Gesellschaft, in der man sich mit der Kutsche fortbewegt. Und das stimmt erst mal so. Ich glaube aber, dennoch ist zum Teil Disruption dringend nötig, aber wir sehen auch, der Neoliberalismus, der eigentlich gesagt hat, wir bauen Bürokratie ab, hat noch viel mehr Regeln geschaffen. Und genau das ist ja auch so im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen zu sehen. Dadurch, dass hier plötzlich jedes Mittel gerechtfertigt werden muss, da muss jeder nochmal extra drüber entscheiden, hat man natürlich ein System geschaffen, in dem jede Taxi-Quittung durch 17 Hände gehen muss. So, dass am Ende derjenige, der die Taxi-Quittung gerne zurückerstattet hätte, sich sagt, ich lasse es, ich zahle sie lieber selbst. Das ist das eine System. Zum anderen hat man natürlich mit dem öffentlich-rechtlichen System gebaut, bei dem es einzelne Personen gibt, die damit immens reich werden. Die gründen nämlich ihre eigenen privaten Produktionsfirmen. Und dann stellen die für die produzierten Talkshows oder andere Sendungen irgendwelche horrenden Rechnungen, haben dann Mondpreise, die sie abrufen, haben 70 Mitarbeiter, die eine einzige Talkshow produzieren. Man denkt sich, was machen die da alles? Das war ja selbst in der DDR nicht so, so viele Leute, so wenig Arbeit. Ja, also so ein Irrsinn. Und das ist auch ein System, das man damit produziert hat. Und darunter haben dann diejenigen zu leiden, die da irgendwie mal frei sind. Und natürlich am Ende auch der Frau, der euch das am Telefon gesagt hat. Ich hätte es ja gerne dem Intendanten gesagt, aber ich konnte es ja auch nur einer Sachtbearbeiterin sagen. Die, muss ich aber auch nochmal betonen, sich wirklich nicht gerade mit Ruhm bekleckert hat.
Ja, du hast also die Erfahrung gemacht, dass nicht dein ganzes Leben, aber in Abschnitten dann doch, eine Blockierung stattfindet.
Richtig.
Denn egal, wie obskur die Bürokratie ist, sie wird ja gefühlt, als sie hindert mich, sie blockiert mich, das blockierte Leben. Jetzt hast du dir das Recht genommen, ein Thema mitten aus dem Buch, ich mache das jetzt auch. Denn dieses Buch besprechen wir ja in einer Reihe vieler Bücher und es droht ja immer wieder, dass wir so Kritik auch wiederholen, wenn ein Buch mal wieder nicht verspricht, was wir vorher schon bei anderen bemängelt haben. Und einer dieser großen Mängellagen war ja, wo ist denn hier das Ökonomische? Der Kapitalismus, wie auch immer. Und ich habe ja schon bei Nils Kumka angemerkt, nein, sein Desiderat zum Thema, wir haben keine Theorie des Rechtspopulismus, hat ja Punkt eins, ökonomische Aufklärung. Deswegen möchte ich die zentrale, finale Point dieses Buches jetzt gleich einfach nennen, indem ich sie vorlese und dann auf einen Textteil mitten im Text einschwenken. Also die letzten Worte dieses Buches lauten, soviel die interviewten Personen, nein, wir sind so frei, abschließend ein bekanntes Diktum Max Horkheimers, ein wenig zu ergänzen, wer aber vom Kapitalismus und vom Liberalismus nicht reden will, sollte auch vom Faschismus schweigen. Jetzt haben wir uns ja gefragt, da steht demokratischer Faschismus drauf. Was ist Faschismus? Faschismus, wenn man überhaupt darüber redet, dann bitte nicht im Gefühlsduse liegen, das war ja damals schon zu schlimm, als die Fernsehbilder noch schwarz-weiß waren und so, sondern Faschismus ist eins zu eins irgendwas mit Ökonomie. Wenn das mit der Ökonomie da nicht vorkommt, dann darf man das Wort Faschismus einfach nicht nennen. Diese ganz wichtige Forderung hier am Ende des Buches prägt das ganze Buch, würde ich sagen. Also einer der großen Kritikpunkte, die wir bisher hatten, oder in dem Falle du bei Kumka, aber auch so bei anderen, dass die Ökonomie hier zu kurz kommt, ist in diesem Falle, also das können wir schon mal vorher sagen, wir haben ein Buch, das sehr viel näher rankommt.
Bei Reckwitz hat mir das ganz stark herausgearbeitet.
Da bin ich auch völlig einer Meinung.
Ja, bei Kumka hast du es anders gesehen oder auch andere Dinge in den Fokus gerückt. Aber bei Reckwitz reden wir die ganze Zeit über Verlust und man denkt, Bilanzen, Verlust, Geld, das müsste doch eigentlich ganz nahe liegen. Und hier haben wir es und ich will das nur sagen für die Leute, die dieses berühmte Diktum nicht kennen von Max Horkheimer. Das heißt ja eigentlich nur, wer aber vom Kapitalismus nicht reden will. Ja und sie erweitern es jetzt nochmal, wer vom Kapitalismus und Liberalismus nicht reden will, bedeutet also, aha, wir verteidigen jetzt gerade mit diesem Buch nicht den Liberalismus gegen den Faschismus. Das wäre so das nächste Wohlfühlsachbuch. Wir kennen diese Sachen. Sondern wir sehen jetzt hier, ach so, der Liberalismus selbst ist offenbar mitbeteiligt an dieser Entstehung des demokratischen Faschismus.
Genau, also wir kriegen hier auch eine große Reaktion auf sowas wie Gejammer über die Selbstgerechten, wo wir uns immer sagen, das geht irgendwie am Ziel vorbei. Und hier geht es mal richtig rein. Aber mir geht es um noch einen anderen Punkt, den ich auch für ganz wichtig halte. Also sie schreiben so mittendrin. Soviel die interviewten Personen alle möglichen politischen und gesellschaftlichen Akteure und Fehlentwicklung kritisieren, bleibt ein Aspekt davon fast vollständig verschont, der Kapitalismus.
Ja.
Das geht natürlich jetzt voll in unsere Kerbe, aber ich möchte es noch erweitern. Der Kapitalismus ist eine Schiffre für die Realität.
Ich will es also nochmal vorlesen. Soviel die interviewten Personen alle möglichen politischen und gesellschaftlichen Akteure und Fehlentwicklung kritisierten, bleibt ein Aspekt davon fast vollständig verschont, die Realität. Ja. Wir erleben hier ein Buch, das uns erklärt, wie krass wir alle in so einer Fantasywelt leben. Und insbesondere diejenigen, die sie so ein Bild von der Gesellschaft machen, in der sie einfach nur rudimentäres Handlungsvermögen wieder reinbringen wollen durch Zerstörung. Wenn es brennt, sehe ich, das ist mal richtig was anderes und ich wünsche mir eine Änderung.
Ja, das Fiktionale ist ja da interessant. Das Fiktionale löst sich von der Realität. Aber eigentlich hat ja die Fiktion, die wir jetzt im Kino verfolgen, doch zum Beispiel den Wunsch, plausibel zu sein. Wir sagen, sonst ist da ja ein Logikloch. Aber hier werden wir jetzt Fiktionen erleben, die nicht logisch sind, die sind nicht konsistent. Wenn wir uns die ganze Zeit die Mühe machen, wir machen das natürlich auch laufend oder machen uns darüber lustig oder versuchen, das aufzuschlüsseln. Wenn wir auf Widersprüche hinweisen, dann sind wir in dieser Idee noch von Plausibilität. Das ist aber da längst übersprungen worden. Also hier äußern sich Menschen, die ja nicht nur an ihrem eigenen Ast sägen, die hauen sich mit dem Hammer selbst auf den Kopf und sagen dann, das geschieht den anderen aber mal ganz recht. Also das ist so verquähert, dass man ja ganz fassungslos ist über diese empirischen Befunde und würde auch hier sagen, das bekommt man nur über die Empirie überhaupt dahin. Ich glaube, dass, ich finde auch, dass das hier, um das mal so generell schon über das Buch zu sagen, das Buch ist immer dann am allerstärksten, wenn die empirischen Momente kommen, wenn diese analysiert werden. Ich hätte nicht jede literarische Referenz gebraucht. Ja, es sind alle Soziologen, die wir kennen, werden aufgerufen. Es geht nochmal quer durch die konservative Revolution. Heller, Sprengler, Jünger, alles wird nochmal angerufen, aufgerufen. Ich glaube und weiß, dass die beiden alles gelesen haben, was es dazu gibt. Aber ich glaube, man muss es gar nicht uns allen mitteilen laufend, sondern man ist eigentlich besser dran, wenn man einfach an den Befunden bleibt, sie analysiert. Und ich muss nicht nochmal wissen, und da hat Traverso dies gesagt und dann meinte aber auch schon Gramsci das. Da kommt man, glaube ich, an vielen Punkten nicht weiter. Beziehungsweise, ja, man kann dann immer schöne Formulierungen wieder produzieren, aber eigentlich ist da, wo die Diagnose kommt, wo die Analyse dieser Diagnose kommt, da ist das Buch herausragend gut. Und das andere ist für mich immer so ein bisschen, wie sagen wir, ja, so Seminar-Prosa.
Das würde ich in dem Fall nicht sagen, denn du hast ja eben schon, und wir beide haben das, ich habe es bekräftigt, Zerstörungslust ist ein absolut wertvoller Titel, weil wir wissen, dass jedes 5-20-minütige Radiogespräch nur am Titel kleben bleibt, Zerstörungslust. Zerstörung und Lust, so. Da kommt man ja gar nicht irgendwo hin, wo man in die Bredouille kommt, dann noch mal, was hat jetzt der Furio-Yesi da gesagt und so, ja. Sondern das ist ja dann wirklich fürs Buch vorbehalten und damit für uns Leser. Und so gut wie Zerstörungslust, so sorgfältig wie dieser Titel gewählt ist, so finde ich. Ja, es kommt sehr viel Name-Dropping, aber eben auch sehr sorgfältig, um das immer wieder zuzuspitzen auf so Begriffe, die dann eben erklärt werden. Also, und diese ganze Trump macht jetzt das nächste KI-Video, wie er irgendwie Scheiße auf die Bevölkerung abwirft und so weiter und so fort. Und da werden aber keine Worte gesprochen, sondern es läuft allein über die Bilder, also so ganz vark und obskur, weil man weiß so ein bisschen, was er meint. Und das hier einfach mit Hilfe von Texten zum Thema längst geschrieben vor irgendeiner KI-Wende, um dann nochmals auf diesen Begriff der mythologischen Maschine zu bringen, den Mythos überhaupt da reinzubringen. Dieses Buch lädt uns ein, an mit Hilfe von Leo Löwenthal die Hoss und Hopf-Podcast nochmals Agitatoren zu klassifizieren. Weil sie als Agitatoren einfach das Unbehagen in ihrem Publikum als die diffuse allgemeine Maläse aufgreifen und dann eben keine konstruktive Wende machen, sondern einfach so ein Bad einlassen, wo sich dann alle kurz reinlegen und wie in so ein emotionales Spa einfach gehen und sich eine halbe Stunde Hoss und Hopf anhören. Das wird hier einfach wunderbar beschrieben. Aber eben mit Hilfe von diesen Leuten, die damals Texte schreiben, bei denen immer der Verdacht ist, dass sie heute gar nicht so richtig passen und nur reingeschrieben werden, weil man das noch im Shettle-Apparat hatte oder so.
Das will ich gar nicht. Ich will nicht sagen, dass sie nicht passen. Ich glaube nur, dass man, ich weiß nicht, ob man alle immer braucht. Also man kommt auch manchmal.
Also Shijek nicht. Und den kann man dann auch mal weglassen. Aber die anderen.
Ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass die Shijek-Bezüge oder Eva von Redekar oder wegen mir auch Eva Illus, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt zwingende Bezüge sind. Wenn sie sich auf Erich Fromm stützen und auf die Frankfurter Schule stützen und ja, da auch dann besonders noch auf Döwental stützen, dann finde ich, ist das sehr sinnvoll, das so zu tun. Ich halte aber jetzt so dieses jeden nochmal kurz anzitieren. Rachel Yagy da, Anon Jäger dort, glaube ich, ja, ich sehe dann auch, ich kenne die Texte und dann macht das mal so ein, so klingelt es kurz, ja, aber es klingelt dann immer nur kurz. Und deswegen ist das aber eher eine allgemeine Kritik an dieser Art der Literatur, dass sie immer so durch alles dann durchschreitet, was in den letzten zehn Jahren vor allem auch nochmal produziert wurde bis hin zu Naomi Klein. Liefert Naomi Klein wirklich gerade irgendeine gute Analyse zu Gegenwart? Ich würde mal sagen nein.
Ja, also bleiben wir beide.
Deswegen, das nur allgemein gesagt, um jetzt gleich die Stärken des Buches herauszuheben, glaube ich, ist man da immer so sehr versucht, alles herbeizuziehen und kann aber eigentlich auch selbst auf eine Formulierung vertrauen. Man ist doch souverän genug, wenn man so empirische Befunde hat, dass man es wirklich daran anlehnt. Und dann brauche ich nicht nochmal zu wissen, ob Eva Illos auch schon mal was über Gefühle gesagt hat.
Also diese eine Kritik will ich auch machen. Man könnte das ganze Buch andersherum konzipieren, indem man sagt, wir haben Gespräche geführt, wir zeigen jetzt die Gespräche und dann kommentieren wir sie mit unserem soziologischen Nachdenken.
Ja.
Hier ist aber genau umgedreht. Man hat schon ein soziologisches Nachdenken und die Gesprächsfetzen, also wir kriegen nur noch sehr wenig, sind Illustrationen der Argumentation, die man eigentlich macht. Das stützt sich schon gegenseitig und das steht auch auf sicherem Grund. Aber die wenigen O-Töne, die wir hören, sind so frappierend, dass man sich eigentlich wünscht, hier so ein bisschen ins True Crime zu gehen. Ich würde gerne mehr von dem jungen Bioinformatiker hören, der sagt, die Gesellschaft ist irgendwann voll. Also ich habe da auch mit meinen Petrischalen, wenn ich da Bakterien züchte, sind die auch irgendwann voll. Und dann sterben die halt und dann kriegt er die Frage, und was gibt der Hoffnung? Ja, dass es bei Krieg gibt und wir das mal ordentlich aussortieren. Da würde ich gerne mehr wissen dann, ja? Ja, genau. Ich würde gerne den Haftbefehl drucken.
Und dann kommt man dann vielleicht doch am Ende mit Michel Foucault und der Gouvermentalität und Achille Membembe und so nicht ganz so weit. Außer, dass man jetzt sagt, wir haben eine schöne Formulierung, die nochmal eine Pointe produziert.
Also deswegen geht es hier auch los mit Ernst Jünger und dem Projekt 2025. Zum einen, ich mache bei Ernst Jünger nur die Stichpunkte. Stichflamme, Flammenwerfer, große Säuberung. Wer das Ganze leugnet, der kann nicht aus den Teilen Früchte ziehen, weil wir die echten, wahrenden und unerbitterlichen Feinde des Bürgers sind. Macht uns seine Verwesung Spaß. Und dann kommen sie nach diesem Zitat direkt auf. Ja, also das Projekt 2024, das große Regierungsprogramm von Trump, hatte ja damals noch, als es ein bisschen offensiver, das ist ja anscheinend jetzt schon die abgespeckte Variante, Streichholz vorne drauf, große Sprüche, wie man hier alles abfackeln will. Washington muss im Brand gesetzt werden, damit Amerika leben kann.
Ja.
Und so. Und da sind wir natürlich gut vertraut mit diesem Zeug. In deren Sicht werden wir hier gut ins Buch abgeholt. Denn ja, sie kommen immer häufig, also sie kommen häufig auf diese amerikanischen Sachen zu sprechen, weil es da auch diese Studien gibt zum Thema Zerstörungslust, wo ja einfach Leute gefragt werden, möchten sie, dass hier alles zerstört wird und 5 Prozent sagen Ja. Sie versuchen, diese Empirie oder diese Demoskopie, die es da gibt, so ein bisschen nach Deutschland zu holen, um hier das AfD-Phänomen zu erklären. Aber es geht um Zerstörungslust, die eben nicht nur nihilistisch ist, also einfach nur verneint, sondern man möchte…
Es gibt ja drei. Drei Arten machen sie ja dann beide später aus.
Fünf Prozent wollen einfach zerstören. Das sind die echten Nihilisten, die einfach alles negieren. Aber darüber hinaus soll auf die Zerstörung ein neues Gebäude für die Ewigkeit gebaut werden.
Und dann gibt es noch die Libertärautoritären, die sie ausmachen, die auch Zerstörung wollen. Aber die wollen dann nicht den neuen Staat errichten, sondern die wollen dann nochmal so privatistische Projekte durchsetzen.
Die einen wollen in einer Verfassung. Und die anderen sagen, Verfassung brauchen wir nicht, wir haben doch Verträge. Ja. So, dann kann man natürlich immer die Frage stellen, wie ist das jetzt mit der Absicherung der Verträge? Also irgendwo muss ja mal ein Meta-Vertrag gemacht werden, aber gut. Da sind dann, wie gesagt, es denkt ja keiner drüber nach. Wir sind ja hier in einer Fantasy-Welt. Da kann man den Leuten ja nicht abverlangen, dass sie drüber nachdenken, was nach dem großen Brand dann für ein Vertragsgefüge statt Verfassungsgefüge entsteht. Na ja, in sieben EU-Staaten gibt es jedenfalls schon rechtsextreme Parteien, schreiben sie, und wir wissen ja, was droht, also mit Le Pen dann auch in größerer Verantwortung.
Sie sagen, wir befinden uns in einem rechtsdriftenden politischen Zyklus, in dem nationalkonservative, libertär-autoritäre und anarcho-kapitalisten sich zusammenschließen und liberale Institutionen ins Visier nehmen.
Ja, was bedeutet, die Demokratie ist zum Abschluss freigegeben, aber der Staat, die Nation, ist so dieser imaginierte Gemeinschaftsort, man weiß gar nicht, Gemeinschaft oder Ort oder wie auch immer. Also der bleibt, der hatte so eine Konstanz irgendwie.
Denn man könnte ja jetzt auch so libertär sein, dass man sagt, was braucht man Vaterland, was braucht man die Nation, was braucht man Deutsch sein?
Genau. Das haben wir ja auch schon als Frage an diese Bosette oder so, wenn die irgendwie kommt mit Werbpflicht, dass man sich fragt, warum hast du so viel Angst und warum ist der Nationalstaat der Rahmen, in dem du jetzt denkst? Das können die ja auch mal erklären, aber es ist halt für alle Fantasy auch für die aufgeklärt.
Ja, ja.
Ja, so und dann haben wir diesen Faschismus, bei dem sie fragen, warte mal, Faschismus, also schon wieder, also schon und wieder oder neu, wie auch immer und deswegen ja auch dieser demokratische Faschismus. Also der Faschismus damals wollte ja die Demokratie richtig ersetzen und dann gibt es ja die berühmten Reden von Armin Laschet, der letzte ehrliche aufgeklärte CDUler, der uns allen noch mal sagt, das haben die in drei Tagen geschafft. Und jetzt sagen die, ja, das ist damals, das ist Geschichtsschreibung. Also wenn wir darauf warten, dass einfach so in zwei Wochen die Demokratie abgeschafft wird, nein, die Demokratie wird natürlich so übernommen einfach, sie wird ausgenutzt. Man baut so ein, hab ich dann auch so drüber nachgedacht, dieses Geoökonomieargument, dass man also die Mittel, die man schon hat, einfach verwendet und sagt, ja, lieber Bürger, wir wissen, dass du irgendwelche Rechte hast, aber das macht doch hier die Zentralbank und das macht auch hier und diese Kritik an der liberalen Demokratie, die sagt, nee, das kann man auf gar keinen Fall den Parlamentariern überlassen, wie das mit den Schulden ist. Das muss jetzt in die Verfassung, zwei Drittel Mehrheit, also schon mal enddemokratisiert, den Rest macht die EZB und die Bundesbank auch enddemokratisiert. Also es findet eigentlich schon so eine Enddemokratisierung statt, bei der deine Frage hier ganz virulent ist, müssen wir jetzt auf die AfD warten oder ist sie nicht längst da? Reichen nicht 30 Prozent der Opposition dazu, um aus einer CDU ein Alexander Dobrindt ins Innenministerium zu führen, der da einfach AfD-Politik macht. Kostet es, was es wolle. 80 Millionen für 70 Zurückweisungen oder sowas. Also da greifen sie gut in unsere Realität ein, die wir das ja im Podcast auch vielfach beobachten.
Dabei ist ja die Frage, was es jetzt mit Zerstörungslust gemeint. Gesagt wird, dass es da Menschen gibt, die sagen, sie wollen, dass das System kaputt geht. Und sie haben eine Lust daran, die sich dann in verschiedener Weise ausdrückt. Wir werden dann nachher Beispiele hören, wie sehr man sich zum Beispiel in Gewaltfantasien hineinsteigert. Es ist aber eine Lust, die erst einmal auch verbunden ist mit einer Partei, nämlich diese Zerstörungslust umsetzen, könnte die AfD so glauben, zumindest die Befragten dort. Und deshalb wählen sie die AfD.
Ja, aber hier können wir ja schon mal vorwegnehmen, was wir gleich im Detail besprechen. Diese Leute wollen ja nicht das System anzünden. Sie haben keine Ahnung von dem System.
Nein.
Aber sie haben ein blockiertes Leben.
Ja.
Und irgendwas blockiert ihr Leben. Und das ist das System. Also es wird über Bande gespielt. Nicht, weil sie das System durchschauen und sagen, dass es so dysfunktional ist, dass es zerstörchert, sondern weil sie es gerade nicht durchschauen und nur die Blockade erleben die ganze Zeit, wollen sie, dass es weggeht. So. Und da kommt diese Zerstörungslust her, die sich gerade nicht mehr mit der Demokratie und unserem Verfassungsgefüge befasst. Weshalb die auch sagen, all diese Sonntagsreden Aufklärung sind völlig für den Arsch. Also das ist einfach genau das bekräftigt die ja nur. Die wollen ja gerade nicht den nächsten Appell. Wenn jemand glaubt, man braucht einen Appell für dieses System, ist es schon scheiße.
Das war ja immer deine These. Wenn Bundespräsident Steinmeier irgendwo steht und die Demokratie lobt oder sich gegen den Antisemitismus stellt, dann sagen die, ach so, der ist für dies und das oder gegen das und das. Dann mache ich es genau umgekehrt.
Genau.
Dann mache ich es genau umgekehrt. Das bedeutet dann auch, dass der Faschismus gewählt wird. Sie sagen, es geht im Buch nicht darum, dass der Faschismus notwendigerweise als politische Gewaltherrschaft wiederkehren wird, sondern darum, dass er bereits jetzt als faschistische Fantasie in der Demokratie existiert und Anhängerinnen findet. Ja, das ist die Idee. Um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, wie wenig sie das System erkennen. Also, ich kann im Stau stehen, weil eine Brücke nicht saniert wurde. Und dann kann ich darüber wütend sein und eine gewisse Zerstörungslust empfinden. Die Frage ist jetzt, worauf bin ich wütend? Sage ich, ich stehe im Stau? Diese scheiß Grünen in der Ampelregierung haben wieder dafür gesorgt, dass ich im Stau stehe? Wir müssen alles abbrennen in Berlin? Oder sage ich, diese scheiß Austeritätspolitik, die wir jetzt seit Jahrzehnten haben, hat dafür gesorgt, dass nicht einmal die Brücken saniert werden?
Und genau diese zweite Antwort, die geben die nicht, weil sie gar nicht wissen, was Austeritätspolitik ist und da ist auch Aufklärung schwierig.
Genau. Und weil sie natürlich ein mediales Angebot vorfinden, dass ihnen die ganze Zeit sagt, also es wird so ein bisschen suggeriert, wir können die Probleme nicht mehr lösen wie bisher durch Schaffung neuer Ressourcen, wie im Buch steht, was ja auch stimmt. Also ich komme jetzt auch mal wieder darauf zu sprechen, bei jeder Gelegenheit, als die Nachkriegsgeneration nichts hatte, außer Kinder, die eine Zukunft brauchen, haben sie aus dem Nichts die größten Gebäude der Welt gebaut, Universität Bielefeld, Borum und so weiter. So, man ist also rausgewachsen, man hat etwas geschaffen, man hat Ressourcen erzeugt, die es vorher gar nicht gab, Bildungseinrichtungen. Und das Herauswachsen aus den Konflikten gibt es heute nicht mehr, sondern stattdessen kriegt man sofort vor die Nase gesetzt, nein, es ist jetzt ein Verteilungskampf, Lars Klingbeil ist im O-Ton nicht zu unterscheiden von Christian Lindner und sagt einfach, die Spielräume sind begrenzt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann wird natürlich sowas wie Migration, also Zuzug, totaler Eingriff in die Ressourcen, weil es hinterfragt ja weder jemand den Kapitalismus noch Nationalstaaten als Grenze so. Dass die Ressourcenverteilung national geregelt wird, ist ja gar nicht so.
Das ist unhintergehbar.
Aber genau, das ist einfach unhintergehbar. Also ein Mythos schließt an die nächste Fantasy-Erzählung an und daraus kommt dann dieses, also mein blockiertes Leben, ich bin ja fleißig, greife auch nicht mehr auf den Klassenstolz zurück, den gibt es ja nicht mehr, also bin nur noch ich und mein Fleiß und im Fernsehen wird mir die ganze Zeit was vom Bundeskanzler erzählt, das Tagebuch des Bundeskanzlers. Also gleiche ich die ganze Zeit ab, mein Tagebuch und das Tagebuch des Bundeskanzlers und irgendwo ist ein Disconnect. Aber in der Schuldfrage ist einfach völlig klar, also ich war fleißig genug. Wo ist der Bundeskanzler? Für mich so, mein Bundeskanzler. Ist das schon wieder nur der Bundeskanzler der Migranten? Ah ja, hat er schon wieder nur was über Migranten erzählt statt über mich so. Und dann stolpert man da einfach rein in dieses hegemoniales Denken, dass man einfach, und das ist witzig, wie sie es hier schreiben, der reale Boden des subjektiven Gefühls der Bevormundung. Ja. Irgendwer regelt hier die ganze Zeit mein Leben mit symbolischer Macht. Und ich finde mich in dieser Konstruktion von Sachzwängen des Liberalismus nicht wieder. Austeritätspolitik, sagen sie dann, ist selbstzerstörerisch. Das ist im Grunde, also von mir ist ein bisschen verkürzt, rausgezogen aus dem Buch, aber so steht es nicht.
Ja, wir kommen gleich nochmal dazu. Destruktivität heißt es, ist der Beschleunigungsstreifen auf einer mehrspurigen Autobahn der Radikalisierung. Menschen mit destruktiven Einstellungen sind offen für faschistische Fantasien, wünschen sich aber nicht unbedingt die Errichtung eines faschistischen Regimes. Die Destruktivität ist jedoch nicht universell. Schließlich findet sie im Rahmen der radikalen Identifikation mit kapitalistischen Hierarchien statt. Und man könnte noch ergänzen, und mit dem Staat in aller Regel, bis auf so ein paar Libertäre, die sich von allem loslösen wollen, ist es tatsächlich nicht hintergehbar, was der Kapitalismus als Ordnung vorsetzt. Innerhalb dieses Systems muss alles stattfinden. Und die Destruktivität ist eben keine, die das kapitalistische System angreift. Es ist nicht V wie Vendetta, sondern es ist hier die Frage, kann ich eine Elite stürzen? Und dabei ist aber oft der Wunsch, schon da eine neue Elite zu etablieren, dann eben die andere, die Elite, da Alice Weidels beispielsweise. Aber es geht jetzt keineswegs darum, über Lohnarbeit so etwas nachzudenken. Und das war ja auch, als ich bei Ben im Podcast war, interessant, dass wenn ich das so ausgeführt habe, Reallohnverlust oder so, dass dazu nie Nachfragen kamen, weil das einfach gar nicht als Problem identifiziert wird. Also man könnte ja auch so interessierte Nachfragen dazu generell stellen, aber das wird gar nicht wahrgenommen.
Ja, aber das ist ja in dem Buch, also wird es ja gut deutlich, wie der Kapitalismus natürlich nicht kritisiert wird, weil er ist ja die Lösung, wenn nur der Staat nicht im Wege stünde. Ich habe gestern aufgrund meines Besuchs im Radio, als ich deinen Diktum Aufgriffe meinte, Thema Generationengerechtigkeit, wir müssen einfach bilanzieren, nicht diskutieren, bilanzieren. So und dann kam natürlich gleich...
Wo warst du zu Gast, du musst kurz sagen.
Im SWR Kulturforum, meiner Lieblingsradiosendung, wo wir, da war der Quentin Gärtner, der Bundesjugend, nicht Bundesjugend, Bundes-Schülersprecher, Konferenzchef, Generalsekretär, mit zu Gast, sehr gut. Und da habe ich danach gleich Nachrichten gekriegt von älteren Frauen, die ganz erschrocken waren, also die ich persönlich kenne, die ganz erschrocken waren darüber, was ich gesagt habe, weil die mir dann auch gerne nochmal ihre Meinung sagen würden, die nämlich darauf hinausläuft, warum nimmt mir der Staat so viel Geld weg? Ich kann gar nicht in ETFs investieren für meine Kinder. So. Da kritisiert man natürlich nicht den Kapitalismus. Der ist ja die Lösung, der ist ja die Rettung. Und der Staat, und das beschreiben sie ja dann ganz wunderbar, kommt eben nicht als derjenige, der für dich organisiert, wie du dein Geld anlegst und so, sondern der Staat kommt ja, und dann kremmen sie wieder diesen Gramm Ski auf und so, der kommt ja so aus deiner Richtung, der eben sagt, die Herrschaft kommt ja selten über Zwang und Gewalt, wie der Chef auch nicht mit dem Befehl kommt, sondern da wird so eine Bitte in den Raum gestellt. Und im Bürgergespräch mit dem Amt ist das natürlich, okay, wie begegnet sich der Staat? Als Bundeskanzler im Fernsehen, okay, aber doch vor allem als die Lehrerin, der Typ in der Amtsstube. Und dann sind wir ganz schnell bei Kathrin Dingsabums.
Kathrin Dio über die Professional Manager Realtor Class.
Genau, mit dieser Mittelklasse, die selber über kein Eigentum verfügt, also nicht an den Produktionsmitteln beteiligt ist, aber in krasser Weise den Staat repräsentiert.
Ja, und dann sagt er, das tut mir leid, also das Vordach können sie jetzt in ihrem Haus aber nicht anbringen. Da hätten sie die Verordnung lesen müssen. Oder Herr Schulz, da müssen sie aber gucken, das ist eigentlich umsatzsteuerpflichtig.
Oder schon die Anrede, dass in einem Text, der wirklich nur an dich gerichtet ist und du bist ein Mann, trotzdem gegendert wird und lautes solche Sachen.
Ja, da sind die Punkte, wo man sagt, jetzt reicht's aber.
Da springt natürlich die Sensorik an. Da hat man sofort das Streichholz in der Hand.
Jaja, das beschreiben Sie sehr gut, dieses Gefühl.
Und das ist eins zu eins die Aufgabe gewesen von Precht, das zu beschreiben, wenn er sich dieses Thema annimmt. Stattdessen kriegen wir da einen so einen Wank nicht, die Selbstgerechten. Er zeigt einfach nur, dass er auch zu den Wütenden gehört, dass er nicht versteht, was da passiert. Und das war eben da so schade, aber jetzt kriegen wir hier die Aufklärung von zwei Professoren.
Naja, gut, bei Precht ist es, glaube ich, das Problem, dass er nicht redet generell über Meinungsfreiheit und hätte einfach sagen müssen, ich schreibe ein Buch über Medien und Meinungsfreiheit, müsste aber dann sagen, das habe ich ja mit Harald Wälzer schon zusammen eigentlich verfasst. Denn das ist ja etwas, was jetzt hier im Buch definitiv zu kurz kommt. Und das muss auch nicht vorkommen, aber es ist zwar so, dass sie über Silicon Valley reden und wie diese Plattformen dann dort ein bisschen sind, beziehungsweise wie Peter Thiel und all diese Leute so ticken und wie das dann immer sich so weiter verbreitet. Aber ich glaube, man müsste eigentlich auch natürlich schauen, inwieweit die Medien diese Zerstörungslust eigentlich erst entfachen. Also ich glaube einfach, dass die Talkshow-Hos, also ich denke da besonders jetzt an Meilschberger oder so, die zündet ja auch jeden Tag zehn Streichhölzer an.
Genau, aber diese Aufklärung haben wir ja bei KUMKA bekommen. Dass wir auf der einen Seite diese Radikalisierungs-Methode der AfD in Verbindung mit dieser konfliktrechtigen Inszenierungslogik des Fernsehens, führt einfach dazu. Genau, also kann man hier alles sowieso parallel lesen. Also Kramschie. Greift dieses Paradox auf, dass wir eine Gesellschaft haben, die uns unendlich viele Möglichkeiten einräumt und gleichzeitig die ganze Zeit als Zwang und Hindernis unseren noch größeren Wünschen dann im Wege steht. Weshalb der Wunsch erwächst, die Welt zu zerstören, die einem die Luft zum Atmen nimmt. Und da ist natürlich mühselig, aber da hätte man jetzt auch noch mal, war gestern im Büro kurz Thema, als wir darüber sprachen, diese David Foster Wallace oder wie er auch immer heißt.
Unendlicher Spaß.
Genau, der Autor vom unendlichen Spaß, der ja damals diese Rede in der Uni gehalten hat über die Fische und das Wasser. Dass die Fische einfach das Wasser nicht reflektieren können, wie auch. So, und so ist das ja hier auch. Die Leute, die diese Zerstörungslust haben, können ja durchaus in den Wald gehen und dort einfach eine Post-Gesellschafts, was auch immer, ich bin mir selbst der nächste Ideologie leben. Nur das machen sie ja nicht. Und zwar aus guten Gründen. Weil sie nämlich dann feststellen, ah, da sind welche zurückgeblieben, denen geht es ja viel besser als mir. Ich will, dass es denen auch zerstört wird. Also, dass man nicht der einzige ausgestoßen ist, der vielleicht sogar noch selber in den Wald geht. Und dieses Paradox, also finde ich wirklich, also es erwächst der Wunsch, man muss AfD wieder damit konfrontieren, was sie wollen. Weshalb ich auch immer mehr dafür bin zu sagen, wenn die in Thüringen Höcke haben wollen, sollen sie, ja, dann machen wir den Nationalstaat Thüringen mit dem Reichskanzler Höcke und dann gucken wir uns das mal an, fünf Jahre.
Dann müssen wir aber die anderen, die davon nicht betroffen sein wollen, nach außen fliegen.
Die können ja gerne zu uns flüchten, ja. Die Züge fahren ja weiter. Aber diese Art von Konfrontation, also es ist auch so eine Art Zerstörungslustdenken von mir jetzt.
Diese Konfrontation, es ist ja auch die Frage, wann will man diese Konfrontation zum Beispiel im privaten, aber ich will ein Beispiel nennen. Ich hatte ein Gespräch mit einem Herrn, der sich darüber empörte, über diese ganzen Klimaverordnungen beim Thema Bauen und auch betonte, dass das eigentlich alles ziemlicher Quatsch sei mit so Nahanlagen und so etwas. Und wenig später in diesem Gespräch, ich habe das so stehen lassen, ich habe mich im Prinzip wie ein Soziologe verhalten, er jetzt einfach Informationen sammelt. Und wenig später sagte er dann, dass er einen wilden Garten hat, weil er doch froh ist, wenn er immer noch mal Bienen sehen kann. Das sei ja so schlimm, dass die Bienen aussterben. Also du hast ein ökologisches Bewusstsein und ein antiökologisches Bewusstsein in einer einzigen Person. Und wie soll man damit umgehen? Also ich kann jetzt nicht zur Rede stellen, aber ich habe mir gedacht, die Materialsammlung brauche ich, ich werde es hier mal erzählen. Aber da ist es ja die Frage, wie soll das, also wir sehen ja eigentlich in dem Buch, dass rationale Aufklärung so schwer fällt, weshalb ja auch die beiden Autoren sagen, wir müssen eigentlich auch mit Emotionalisierung arbeiten. Also wir können nicht immer sagen, wir haben hier aber noch mal den Faktencheck gemacht. Es ist ja folgendermaßen mit den Klimabestimmungen und den Bienen, da gibt es ja einen Zusammenhang, sondern eigentlich kann man so gar nicht die Leute erreichen.
Also ich habe das, also im Laufe des Buches, man hat ja immer so Abgleiche mit dem eigenen Leben, Pädagogik zum Beispiel. Kinder haben unfassbar viele Wünsche. Und manche Wünsche haben sie einfach nur, weil sie wissen, damit können sie jetzt Aufmerksamkeit erregen, wie auch immer, also mein äußerteilten Wunsch. Und sobald Wünsche erfüllt sind, sieht das ja alles ganz anders aus. Ja, also Kinder springen um einen rum und dann so, darf ich aufschließen, darf ich aufschließen, kannst du mir eine Portemonnaie geben? Also einfach nur so, weil ich will auch mal Geld haben. Und dann gibt man ihnen Schlüsseln, gibt ihnen das Portemonnaie und dann sieht man einfach, wie sie, wie jetzt, das sind doch eigentlich die älterlichen Aufgaben. Ich wollte doch nur spielen, aber jetzt plötzlich bin ich in der Verantwortung. Und dann stehen einfach zehn Leute vor einer Tür und der Dreiecker versucht hat, die Tür aufzuschließen und es gelingt ihm nicht. Und er stellt dann auch fest, die warten jetzt alle wegen mir. Das ist irgendwie nicht so günstig. Also diese Art von Konfrontation. Man wünscht sich eigentlich ein Schluck Schneisen zu finden für diese davon Betroffenen. Weshalb ich auch umso mehr, du hast jetzt dieses Wort bilanzieren da so etabliert bei uns im letzten Podcast. Ich habe ja schon mal vom Kristallisieren gesprochen. Also dass man, wenn und wir nähern uns jetzt der Jahresendzeit, in der man so seine Familie wieder ein bisschen häufiger begegnet, Weihnachten und so, dass man vielleicht nicht diese Diskussion einfach aussitzt, aber auch nicht dagegen anargumentiert, sondern einfach nur clevere Rückfragen stellt. Und die Leute, denen das wirklich nicht durchgehen lässt.
Ja.
Dieses Gefühlsauslebung, die sie hier haben. Und das ist eben bei Gramsci hier, das ist, also ich bin ja sowieso jetzt ein, ich habe eine Sensorik für den Herrn Hegemon und so, ja.
Ja gut, dann ist Gramsci dein Mann.
Ja, also wir haben politische Lager, die sich gegenüberstehen. Und die Position der einen können auch von den anderen übernommen werden, nur mit umgedrehtem Vorzeichen. Also die einen sagen, keine Migranten. Und dann könnte man eine Diskussion gestalten, das würde dann Marietta Sommka oder so machen, oder hier die Talkshows. Die dann sagen, ja dann brauchen wir jetzt einen, der für Migration ist. Aber eigentlich bräuchten wir einen, der in die Sendung geht und sagt, ich bin ja ein Parallel-Moderator, ich stelle auch nur Fragen, aber ich hinterfrage die ganze Zeit, warum wir überhaupt über Migration gerade reden. Egal mit welchem Vorzeichen.
Ja.
Warum reden wir hier gerade über Migration? Und das kann man ja wirklich als Konzept einfach einbauen in seine Familienunterhaltung. Dass irgendwer kommt und sagt, ja blablabla und die ganzen Ausländer so. Und dann, ja also das blockierte Leben aufarbeiten jetzt mit ihm. Ja, warum treffen dich jetzt Migranten? Also was hast denn du damit zu tun? Warum interessiert dich die Frankfurter Innenstadt? Weil du da in zehn Jahren mal hinfahren willst, sondern du sollst sicher sein. Ja, also diese und deswegen Mau, immer ganz wichtig, die Arenen hinterfragen. Nicht die Themen. Bloß keine thematische Aufklärung, ja. Also ganz weit weg von thematischer Aufklärung. Aber Arenen hinterfragen, das muss doch jetzt hier. Und die leben in so einer Fantasy-Welt. Also denen muss einfach die Arena, auf der sie glauben, der Herr Higemond sieht mich hier zurecht, der muss einfach aussortiert werden. Also diese Gramsci-Verweise sehr gut, diese Erich-Fromm-Verweise, Furcht vor der Freiheit auch.
Jaja, sehr gut.
Ervorragend, die Vereitelung des Lebens durch diese paradoxische Grundstruktur.
Also das blockierte Leben ist ein richtiges Lebensgefühl. Es ist nicht so, dass das falsch ist, sondern die Sache ist, welche Schlussfolgerungen werden daraus gezogen? Also ja, wir sind in sehr vielen Regelwerken eingespannt und viele Menschen merken, dass es nicht vorangeht und das ist nicht nur Einbildung, sondern es geht nicht voran. Nur, wenn sie dann nicht bereit sind, zum Beispiel über finanzielle Mittel, die der Staat eigentlich hätte, nachzudenken, sondern zum Beispiel dann sagen, wir wollen jetzt über Migration, über Messerstecher oder sonst was reden, dann wird dieses blockierte Leben zu einem Lebensgefühl, in dem man sich dann irgendwann so wohlfühlt oder in dem man zumindest so eine Lust entwickelt, dass jetzt eigentlich nur noch die Destruktion sein kann. Sie binden das ja auch zurück an zum Beispiel das futuristische Manifest von Filippo Tommaso Marinetti. Dort heißt es, wir wollen die Museen, die Bibliotheken und die Akademien jede Art zerstören und gegen den Moralismus, den Feminismus und gegen jede Feigheit kämpfen. Das heißt also dieses vitalistische Prinzip, dieses Zerstören, ohne direkt etwas Neues aufzubauen, sondern erst einmal aus der Zerstörungswute eine Lust ziehen. Das ist ja etwas, was wir zum Beispiel im Springer-Journalismus bei Ulf Posch hat so finden können. Also man könnte das Buch auch statt Zerstörungslust einfach Ulf nennen, dann hätte man es glaube ich auch ganz gut gefasst. Es geht ja tatsächlich so, sich da so reinzureden, in diese Rage zu reden.
Petro-maskuline Ulf.
Es genießen, dass man jetzt alle verschreckt, ihr, die in euren liberalen Institutionen darüber befindet, welches Literaturfestival morgen gefördert wird. Ich mache euch alles kaputt. Und dass das jetzt so ein Impetus ist, der wahnsinnig gut ankommt, auch in einem bürgerlichen Lager. Also das ist ja damals künstlerische Avongarde. Klar hat dann auch damals als Wegbereiter für den italienischen Faschismus gedient. Aber das ist jetzt auch so eine bürgerliche Haltung schon geworden. Wir machen jetzt alles kaputt. Deswegen sieht sich ja auch Ulf Poschert als jemand, der noch mutiger ist, während die Künstler alle so zahm geworden sind, alle den Status quo aufrechterhalten wollen, ist also Ulf Poschert noch derjenige, der glaubte, er greife das System an. Aber er greift nicht das System an, sondern nur bestimmte Eliten oder bestimmte Strukturen, Strukturen kann man nicht mal sagen, bestimmte Menschen, die ihm innerhalb dieses Systems nicht passen. Aber das System als solches greift er nicht an. Und da würde ich auch nochmal deutlich machen, man darf das Buch auf keinen Fall so rezipieren, weil ich befürchte, dass das passieren wird. Das liegt aber dann nicht am Buch, sondern an den Rezipieren. Man darf es auf keinen Fall als ein Plädoyer rezipieren, dass wir jetzt schön brav unsere liberal-demokratischen Institutionen alle aufrechterhalten müssen. Das ist nicht die Aussage dieses Buches. Ich hoffe auch sehr, dass die nicht in Interviews sich genau in dieses Fahrwasser bringen lassen, dass sie am Ende auch mit Armin Laschet Hand in Hand dastehen und sagen, jetzt müssen wir mal sehen, wie machen wir dann die Institutionen schön fest, damit alles in Ordnung ist. Sondern man muss hier ganz klar sagen, die systemische Kritik muss jetzt geleistet werden, die die anderen nicht leisten. Und dazu gehört auch den Mut zu einer gewissen Zerstörung. Nämlich ich kritisiere, dass ja auch laufen, dass diese ganzen angepassten Künstler in Deutschland eigentlich ja nur der Bundespräsident sein wollen. Und genau solche Kunst dann auch produzieren. Das ist ja völlig richtig und das kann nicht die Lösung sein.
Genau. Sie kommen ja als gute Soziologen ganz explizit darauf zu sprechen, dass sie die Probleme beschreiben, ohne die Lösung gleich so mitzubringen, auch wenn sie Hinweise geben. Aber jetzt hast du gesagt, Ulf Poschart und das Bürgerliche. Und das ist hier richtig gut gelungen und wir müssen es richtig hart deutlich herausstellen. Können ja richtig also eine Pointe machen, die im Buch gar nicht drin, aber die eigentlich ins Buch noch fast direkt gemusst, aber wie auch immer. Und zwar, wer sind diese Zerstörungslustigen? Sie kommen auf diese destruktive Persönlichkeit zu sprechen, die in der Amerikaner, also du hast jetzt schon die Autoren genannt, die es da so als Soziologen gibt, die das irgendwie kennen. Und die Demoskopie sagt eben, in April 2024 hat man ermittelt, fünf Prozent der Amerikaner sagen, einfach zerstören. Auch kein Wiederaufbau. Einfach nur, ich würde mich am liebsten aus der Welt verabschieden, kann ich noch so viel wie möglich mitnehmen im Grunde alles. Also kurz vor Tenet-Style. Ich habe mit meinem Tod endet die Welt. So und jetzt versuchen sie, das hier wieder zu finden, anhand dieses nihilistischen Mindsets, Need for Chaos und so weiter. Und dann kommen sie auf diese Zerstörungslustigen, die sie dann im Buch meinen zu sprechen. Später finde auch Ulf Borstadt ist kurz vor der Namensnennung, wenn sie da über diesen Petromaskulin und so weiter sprechen. Und Petro übrigens nicht Benzin und so, sondern der Stein, Petra der Stein, also der Fels, der so von sich behauptet, die Wellen prallen mir ab. Ich stehe hier, ich behaupte mich. Und was jetzt hier so super interessant ist. Wir haben ja immer diese Idee, die armen Ossis, die von den Westen überrannt wurden, wählen jetzt alle AfD, weil die haben ja nichts zu verlieren. Und jetzt lernen wir hier wirklich Erstaunliches, nämlich diejenigen, die hier so eine hohe AfD-Affinität haben, diese Zerstörungslust in sich tragen, die wie Manfred Gruber in ihren Gesprächen sagt, ich finde, dass sehr viel verkehrt läuft in unserem Land. Punkt. Ohne weitere Erklärung einfach. Ja, hier läuft viel verkehrt, wir müssen es anders machen. Das sind nicht arme Leute, sondern das sind finanziell relativ starke Leute, die sich mit ihrem eigenen Fleiß im Widerstand mit der Gesellschaft einiges aufgebaut haben, die aber sozial nicht eingebunden sind, die keine Freunde haben, die einfach über Workaholics mäßig und so weiter feine, keine Ahnung, das ist das, was die anderen machen. Die einfach allenfalls mal einkaufen gehen, sich teuer ein Restaurant einbuchen, dort sind sie dann mal unter Menschen, aber reine Nutzbeziehung, der Kellner ist da, weil ich ihn bezahle und so, die das gar nicht kennen irgendwie jenseits von ihrer kleinen Ehe, die sie vielleicht noch führen und die Kinder sind auch schon ausgezogen. Überhaupt mal irgendwo angenommen zu werden.
Der eine hat den Kontakt zu seinem Sohn abgebrochen, weil der Sohn nicht so fleißig ist.
Darauf können wir gleich zu sprechen. Familie wird ja hier auch krass beschrieben, das ist ja wirklich unglaublich. Und dieser Manfred Gruber, diese Pointe wünschte ich stünde noch im Buch drin, damit das allgemein...
Also das ist ein, muss man sagen, einer der Teilnehmenden an der Umfrage.
Und wir haben in Deutschland im medialen Business, und ich finde, Journalisten, die das lesen, hätten halt... Wir reden immer von sozial Schwachen und meinen aber finanziell Schwache. Und wir müssen dieses sozial Schwach jetzt völlig neu definieren, also das neue empirische Korrelat definieren dafür. Menschen, die sich kleinbürgerlich für sich selbst verdient gemacht haben, also die so eine kleine Unternehmung, und dann suchen sie eine Unternehmensnachfolge, die so ein Haus vererben und so, die sind nicht finanziell schwach, die sind finanziell stark, aber sie sind sozial schwach. Sie sind einfach unaufgehoben in dieser Welt. Sie sehen nur noch sich und die ganze restliche Welt als der große diffuse Moloch, in dem sie allenfalls noch über Dienstleistungsbeziehungen, völlig entpersonalisierte Höflichkeit erfahren. Auf der Straße nur Leuten begegnen, die dringen schon wieder ein in meine Straße, muss ich jetzt wieder deren Müll wegräumen und so. Und das ist ein ganz prägendes Phänomen in Amerika wie in Deutschland, dass die Leute einfach alleine in ihren Autos sitzen und zu Millionen an diesen Tafeln anstehen, statt einmal ein Gespräch miteinander zu führen und es vielleicht irgendwo wirken zu lassen. Und diese sehr detaillierte Beschreibung von Einsamkeit, die hier drinsteckt in dem Buch, ist sehr wichtig.
2600 Teilnehmer, da heißt es, mehr als die Hälfte unserer Befragten wies keine Neigung zur Destruktivität auf. Die nicht so gute Nachricht, 12,5 Prozent erweisen sich als Mittel oder sogar hochdestruktiv. Diese Personen sind eher jung, eher männlich und eher rechts. Bildung und Einkommen hatten keinen robusten Einfluss. Das ist, was du jetzt gerade sagtest, das gibt es dann überall auf allen Ebenen zu finden. Wenn ich auch hier immer wieder sagen würde, ja, das ist jetzt nicht die persönliche Ökonomie, aber es gibt auch bei denen, die jetzt finanziell gut dastehen, das allgemeine Gefühl des Niedergangs. Auch wenn sie selbst dann 10.000 Euro im Monat haben, werden sie sagen, ja, aber generell gibt es einen Niedergang. Und damit haben sie erst einmal recht, dass es diesen Niedergang gibt. Wir haben es ja mit der Deindustrialisierung kürzlich im Podcast besprochen. Weiter heißt es, unser Sample enthielt unterschiedliche Berufsgruppen und Menschen mit ganz verschiedenen Lebensläufen, wobei ein überproportional hoher Anteil einen Hochschulabschluss hatte. Nur ein Viertel der Personen war weiblich. Nichtsdestotrotz waren die interviewten Frauen oft hochdestruktiv. Sie legten insbesondere eine emotionale Härte gegenüber sozialen Minderheiten an den Tag. Also diese sowieso überkommenden Klischees von der Frau als dem besonders fühlenden emotionalen Wesen.
Naja, ich lese mal hier noch weiter. Viele der Befragten hatten Schicksalsschläge erlebt oder waren im Leben anderweitig auf die Probe gestellt worden. Sie waren also in besonderem nicht Need for Chaos, sondern Need for Help. Und dann lautet es hier weiter, sie hatten nur wenige soziale Kontakte, litten aber nicht unbedingt unter Einsamkeit, sondern präferierten das Kleine und Überschaubare. So, und dann schreiben sie über diese rechten Netzwerke in Anführungszeichen, die nämlich hochgradig Polymorph, ein Netzwerk von Netzwerken, eine lose Allianz von Destruktion. Wenn diese Leute nicht nur gar nicht, sondern wenigstens lose oder vielleicht sogar ein bisschen fester miteinander verkoppelt wären, würden die ganz schnell diesen AfD-Destruktivitäts-Dings abschütteln, weil sie nämlich dann was zu verlieren hätten, wenn wirklich jemand kommt und sagt, ich zerstöre. Nur die haben einfach gar nichts zu verlieren, außer diesen kleinen ökonomischen Rahmen, den sie sich geschaffen haben. Und der macht sie so affirmativ für den Kapitalismus. Ja. Und das finde ich so erstaunlich, weil Leute am Ende ihres biografischen Erwerbsbiografie plötzlich sagen, also große Verteidiger des Kapitalismus werden, weil sie mal 40.000 Euro angespart haben, während einfach andere Leute halt 40 Milliarden haben.
So.
Und dass sich einfach mal die Leute, die nur 40.000 Euro gespart haben und sagen, es hätten eigentlich 400.000 sein müssen, dass die sich einfach mal zusammentun und sagen, ja, wir sind zwar finanziell stark, aber sozial schwach und das müssen wir jetzt mal ausgleichen, das findet da nicht statt. Ja. Also diese Vereinzelungen, die eben nicht unter bisherigen Einsamkeits im Sinne von darunter leiden, dass man nicht das soziale Netz, dass man sich wünscht, sondern die haben sich eingerichtet, abgefunden damit, dass ihnen ja eh keiner hilft, dass sie mit ihren Schicksalenschlägen auch nicht in der Freundschaft weiterkommen und so. Und diese Entsolidarisierung, die da drinsteckt, die wird hier nochmal ganz neu gezeichnet, finde ich, sodass man wirklich einfach denkt, alter, die politischen Programme, die hier möglich sind, liegen so nahe.
Ja.
Aber von Friedrich Merz können wir sie nicht erwarten.
Du hast es gerade gesagt, die losen Allianzen, da kommt dann alles zusammen, die Ultralibertären, Evangelikale, Kryptofans, Silicon Valley Tycoons, Neokatholiken, klassische Autoritäre, nationalistische Konservative oder noch Reichsbürger. Deshalb funktioniert das ja auch alles, auch wenn es so widersprüchlich ist, weil man nur lose miteinander verbunden ist. Man muss sich jetzt nicht einem Parteiprogramm ganz unterordnen, einer klaren Linie, dann würde das sofort aufgrund dieser individualistischen Existenzen auseinanderfliegen. Aber wenn es nur eine lose Allianz ist, dann denkt man, da hat aber auch die Gloria von Ton und Taxis was Richtiges gesagt, da hat aber auch Hossen Hopf was Richtiges gesagt. Und hier bin ich aber auch mal auf Seiten von weiß-ich-nicht-weben. Das geht ganz gut zusammen. Auch deshalb, weil hier der radikale Unterschied gezogen werden muss zu dem alten Faschismus. Also in der Zwischenkriegszeit, da ging es ja tatsächlich um Gemeinschaften, die entstehen sollten. Da sollte man eigentlich mit dem Kollektiv verschmelzen. Hier sagen Amlinger und Nachtwey, es geht eigentlich darum, so einen national gefärbten libertären Besitz-Individualismus zu praktizieren. Darum geht es heute. Und da ist jedes Mittel, das die Zerstörung herstellt, recht. Aber man möchte sich jetzt nicht ganz einfügen. Also man ist jetzt nicht einfach nur noch der Angehörige eines einzigen Glaubens, sondern das ist sehr äcklektizistisch.
Genau. Also diese Leute sind, das ist eigentlich ein guter Begriff, libertär besitzindividualistisch. Ja. So, der Überbau ist die Nation, aber die wird als, Zitat, etwas Sakrales, einfach abgehakt, also gar nicht hinterfragt. Und darüber ja auch diese großen Einflugs-Schneisen für so mythisch aufgeladene Agitatoren, wie Hossenhopf, die in der Problembeschreibung alle einsammeln können, weil das blockierte Leben, also darunter leitet sogar Elon Musk. Ja. Jetzt wird ihm schon wieder das Pay Package da verweigert, weil der norwegische Staatsfonds sagt, nee, eine Billion auszahlen an Privatpersonen ist irgendwie blöd. So viel hat das Unternehmen Tesla auch gar nicht. Und schon fällt er mit rein in diese große Auffangschale. Oh, schon wieder ein blockiertes Leben. Komm, jetzt haben wir sogar den reichsten Mann der Welt auf unserer Seite. Der sieht es genauso wie wir. Mein Leben ist blockiert.
Jeder Millionär mit nach Steuerprüfung.
Genau. Und dann wird auf Instagram immer gezeigt, wie viel Steuer man bezahlt und so. Und dann ist man sofort im blockierten Leben und fällt einfach in diesen Topf, in den alle reinpassen. Also mein Leben wurde blockiert. Der Staat, also nicht der Staat, sondern die Politik, die jetzt gerade den Staat geschäftsführend führt, die verhindert meine Biografie.
Sie beschreiben dann im ersten Kapitel diesen Manfred Gruber, der sagt, mein Eindruck ist, dass sich alles verschlechtert hat. Das bleibt doch in dieser Aussage diffus. Sie versuchen aber dann zu zeigen, was sich so verschlechtert hat. Sie sagen, die Klassengesellschaft ist zurückgekehrt. Ja, es gibt diese oberen zehn Prozent, die können sich auch Dienstboten leisten, ja, indem sie ja alles Mögliche bestellen, das ihnen dann gebracht wird. Diese integrative Kraft der Wirtschaft, die es da gab, als man nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg den Aufstieg erlebte, ist passé. Wir sind, sagen sie, in der regressiven Moderne oder kurz der Nachmoderne angekommen. Das bedeutet, die ökologische Krise ist so stark, dass sie uns sowieso keinen glänzenden Fortschritt, keine rosige Zukunft verspricht. Zu fragen ist auch, ob die Wachstumskrise überhaupt noch einmal gelöst werden kann. Kann man da rauswachsen? Zugleich sehen wir, Wirtschaftswachstum kann problematisch werden, aber wir wissen auch gar nicht, ob es überhaupt noch mal eine Nachfrage gibt. Wenn Martin Lipset gesagt hat, dass die Stabilität der Demokratie auf wirtschaftlichem Wohlstand, Industrialisierung, Urbanisierung, Bildung und auf einer breiten Mittelschicht fußt, dann können wir sagen, dass es genau hieran so hapert, weil die Mittelschicht tatsächlich etwas schrumpft, vor allem aber Bildung schwierig wird, wo wir marode Schulen haben, eine Deindustrialisierung erleben und der wirtschaftliche Wohlstand nach und nach abebt. Da bedeutet es also auch, dass die Stabilität der Demokratie in Gefahr ist. Aber sie wollen sich nicht nur mit der Mittelschicht aufhalten, sondern sie sagen auch generell, dass die Arbeiterklasse weniger geworden ist oder dass es da eine unglaubliche Zweiteilung jetzt gibt. Also es gibt die, die zu der Mittelschicht gehören. Und dann gibt es die anderen, die man so zur Arbeiterklasse noch zählen kann. Und da gibt es aber auch so eine große Klufte in der Lebenswelt, dass die sich auch gar nicht mehr treffen. Sie gehen dann natürlich auch auf Pickety ein, auf die Entkopplung von Produktivität und Löhnen. Vor allem aber geht es um den Abstieg als eine klare Klassenrealität. Da heißt es, die Abstände zwischen den Klassen blieben somit mehr oder weniger konstant. So konnte etwa ein Arbeiterkind mit viel Fleiß Lehrer werden. Aber ein Professorenkind wurde mit deutlich höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit selbst wie der Professor. Für Frauen war diese alles noch sehr viel unwahrscheinlicher. In den letzten Dekaden hat sich die liberale Politik vor allem auf die Förderung bildungsvermittelter Chancengleichheit fokussiert. Man ließ die Eigentums- und Vermögensstrukturen unangetastet, sorgte jedoch für eine höhere Durchlässigkeit und somit für mehr relative Mobilität. Bedeutet aber, man hat diese entscheidenden Fragen des Eigentums, des Vermögens, die hat man alle unangetastet lassen und versuchte dann mit entsprechender Chancengleichheit weiterzukommen. Aber da wissen wir ja schon, wohin das führt. Sie produziert laufend neue Verlierer, immer mehr Verlierer. Wir haben ja das Buch von Michael Sandel damals im Podcast besprochen.
Sie haben hier einen interessanten Punkt, den würde ich gerne mal im Gespräch mit den klären. Familie. Denn hier wird ja auch nochmal neu auf Familie geschaut, vor allem historisch. Was ja auffällt ist, Familie steht ja gerade ganz hoch im Kurs. Also Philip Hopf sagt ja wie JD Vans die ganze Zeit, es geht ja nicht nur um dich, sondern auch um deine Familie. Und wir wissen ja aus dieser britischen Hardcore Gesellschaft, was soll denn das sein? Also Margaret Thatcher sagt, das Individuum und seine Familie. Bei Millay sehen wir das auch wieder überall. Und sie kommen hier auf Talcott Parsons, der ja also ein sehr berühmter Soziologe in Amerika, der auch viel so in Systemen immer dachte und immer so in vier Felder tafeln und so. Da musste es ihm alles so, hat sich das so schön runtergebrochen. Und für ihn gibt es drei zentrale Instanzen, das Rechtssystem, die Wirtschaft, die Familie. Das finden wir natürlich hier alles wieder. Also das Rechtssystem im Sinne von, wir brauchen keine Politik, weil wir ja niemanden brauchen, der eine Verfassung betreut. Wir haben ja Verträge unter uns. Die Wirtschaft, naja, wir schließen ja Verträge, um Wirtschaftsverträge abzuschließen, also jeder sein ökonomisches Vorkommen zu machen. Und dann die Familie, die man einfach nie so richtig rausgedrängt bekommt aus diesen Bildern, weil wir sie immer brauchen für die Nachwuchsproduktion. So, also kommt man dann mit diesen mythologisch aufgeladenen Sakralen, ach, mein eigenes Kind ist das besondersste Kind, die Bande zur Mutter ist göttlich und was auch immer so. Ja, also diese drei Rechtssystemwirtschaft, Familie. Und jetzt haben wir aber erlebt, dass natürlich Arbeitsmärkte oder die Realität von Politik, am Beispiel von Arbeitsmarkt und wie er sich gestaltet, in die Familie hineinwirkt und diese Integrationsinstanz in die Gesellschaft selbst wieder unter Druck setzt. Also statt, dass Eltern als erwachsene Bürger nach außen wirken und sagen, wir machen jetzt für alle eine bessere Gesellschaft, sind sie mit der Selbstverteidigung der Familie beschäftigt. Und wir reden natürlich nachher, wenn es dann im Text vorkommt, ausführlich über die Frauen. Aber hier ist auch schon mal eine Einflugschneise für die Mutter als Löwin und die besondere Härte. Und dann eben nicht nur Migranten von außen als Eindringlinge, sondern auch den eigenen Kindern gegenüber, wenn sie nicht den Anforderungen entsprechen, wie man hier als Familienerbe weiterführt, die Eltern stolz auf einen macht. Wenn man schon kein Klassenstolz hat, dann will man zumindest stolz auf die eigenen Kinder sein. Es ist also nicht nur...
Und auch bei den Frauen, die selbst einen Migrationshintergrund haben oder da sogar dann eine besondere Härte. Sie haben schon einmal bewiesen, dass sie mit dieser Härte weit kommen. Also sollen die anderen bitte auch entsprechend hart sein. Wir hatten ja im regulären Podcast diesen marokkanischen Comedian Salim Samatu, der ja auch diesen Sozialdavinismus eigentlich predigt. Ich hab's hier geschafft, mich durchgeboxt und halte es jetzt auch schon nicht mehr aus und gehe deshalb in die Schweiz. Warum sollen jetzt irgendwelche Flüchtlinge kommen, die es leichter haben? Es muss so sein, dass du erst mal dreimal abgeschoben wirst und dann kannst du, wenn du es dann immer noch willst und schaffst, dann kannst du vielleicht dazugehören.
Genau. Also der Weg übers Mittelmeer als Zugangstest, sozusagen die Prüfung, die unmittelbare Prüfung. Für mich steckt hier auch, also klar, ich hab jetzt selber über Familie viel geschrieben und so, aber dieses blockierte Leben kann man hier nochmal erweitern. Und wenn Menschen Verantwortung nicht nur für sich übernehmen, sondern über emotionale Bande auch noch für andere. Und das kennen wir aus soldatischen Erzählungen, für wen kämpft man eigentlich im Krieg und dann liegt man im Schützengraben und rächt einfach nur noch den Tod des Kameraden. Und dieses Bild, also diese Härte, die da drin steckt, die trifft ja zunehmend auch für Familien zu.
Ja, naja.
Man könnte also so eine Idee des erweiterten, blockierten Lebens dann nochmal so eine Anstachelung wie ein nächster Ofen, der dieses ganze Gebäude, was hier gebaut wird, nochmal besonders unter Druck setzt.
Rache als Motiv ist auch bei Adam Toos Interpretation zu finden. Adam Toos denkt darüber nach, warum eigentlich so viele Trump gewählt haben, an wem rächen sie sich gerade. Er sagt, das ist ein Klassenkrieg gegen die Professional Managerial Class, also gegen die, die zu so einer Dienstleistungselite gehören, die die ganze Zeit dir sagen können, mach es lieber nicht so und warum redest du so? Ich habe hier nochmal so ein kleines Nudging für dich und die auch eine gewisse Sprache pflegen. Daran kann man sich jetzt nun rächen, indem man Trump wählt. Und auch hier würde ich sagen, muss man das auch in der ganzen Dimension ernst nehmen und sagen, ja, zum Teil ist ja auch die Rache absolut gerechtfertigt. Es ist nur dann von den falschen Akteuren unterstützt. Aber es gibt ja eben ganz viele, die mit diesem liberal-partenalistischen Sprechen einen zu Weißklo treiben. Ja, also dann würde man mir jetzt wahrscheinlich vorfinden, dass das reaktantes Verhalten, aber wir haben das ja, wir sehen ja mitunter viel Irrsinn.
Genau. Nun ist es so, wir sagen beide, Richard David Brecht ist ein sehr kluger Kopf.
Ja.
Und trotzdem tappt er in diese Falle, ein Buch über Selbstgerechte zu schreiben. Wir kriegen ja hier Aufklärung, die ich wirklich sehr gut finde, denn sie beschreiben ja hier, wie eigentlich sich die Wut nicht gegen den Staat richtet. Der wird ja sagral vergöttert, sondern gegen den, wie sie schreiben, liberalen Paternalismus in der Ausprägung und Sichtbarkeit dieser PMC.
Jemand im Amtszimmer, der Lehrer beim Elternabend, schon wieder ein Themenabend, Kindergarten. Heute ist ein Experte von irgendwo da und erzählt irgendwas über Screentime und so. Man denkt sich einfach nur, Alter, ich will auch mal abends eine Stunde frei haben. Also guck das Kind da bitte YouTube. Und dann kommt schon wieder einer, der dir das ausredet. So, ja, kriegst dein Leben kaum Begriff. So, und hier wird jetzt, finde ich, und das ist wieder für Journalisten, die ja auch in diese Rolle fallen. Sie stehen jetzt nicht Angesichts zu Angesichts und Gegenüber, aber jeder hat ja so dieses, okay, da redet schon jemand im Fernsehen mit mir und möchte so, dass ich jetzt gender oder was auch immer.
Mit so einer liberal-partenalistischen Ansprache. Also ich bekomme ja jeden Abend von Ingo Zamparoni oder Dunja Hayali genau erzählt, wie ich die Demokratie aufzufassen habe und das, wenn wir in Kinderzimmern und Schulklassen Soldaten haben und Waffen vorführen, dann ist das gut. Und wenn das aber in Ländern, die uns nicht freundlich gesinnt sind, vorkommt, dann ist das böse. Also die reden ja auch die ganze Zeit so mit mir. Also ich habe ja immer gesagt, ein Video von MyLab geguckt bei mir sorgt genau dafür, dass ich versuche das Gegenteil zu machen.
So, und jetzt kommen sie hier klug soziologisch, ist aber auch nicht sehr kompliziert zu verstehen, mit der Unterscheidung von Rolle und Person. Uns begegnet ja nicht Ingo Zamparoni als Person, sondern die Tagesschau hat halt diese, oder die Tagesthemen haben diese Rolle des Nachrichten, Präsentas, und die füllt halt jemand aus. Und das ist jetzt gerade in unserer Zeit Ingo Zamparoni, das war aber auch schon mal Ulrich Wiggert und wie auch immer. Also man hat eine Rolle eigentlich. Der Lehrer, dem wurde halt die Klasse zubehost. Nur, wir sehen natürlich nur die Person, nicht die Rolle. Der Elternabend findet bei Frau Schmitt statt und nicht, also die Institution versteckt sich sozusagen. Wir sehen immer nur Personen. Und jetzt haben wir dieses interessante Phänomen, dass die PMC selber darunter leiten. Denn die Lehrerin ist natürlich nur beim Elternabend Lehrer. Sobald die in die Amtsstube geht oder den Fernseher einschaltet oder was auch immer, ist die ja eigentlich auf der bürgerlichen Publikumseite und sieht selber, dass es irgendwie Quatsch ist, dass sie die ganze Zeit appelliert wird an sie. Nur dann beim Elternabend ist es natürlich ihre Aufgabe, die ganze Zeit zu appellieren. Und da müssen sich Journalisten, und ich habe das schon häufiger angesprochen, wirklich fragen, wie es sein kann, dass man vom Frühstückstisch aufsteht, wo man mit den eigenen Kindern noch gerade geklärt hat, warum es noch keinen Physikunterricht gibt und man leidet die ganze Zeit unter dem Staat. Und dann steht man auch noch im Stau. Dann kommt die Bahn nicht und der ganze Scheiß. Und dann steigt man severance-mäßig in den Fahrstuhl ein und steigt als der Journalist oben wieder aus, der die ganze Zeit Ansagen und Appelle an die Gesellschaft richtet. Ja. So.
Und auch die ganze Zeit, es ist gar keine Krise. Es ist gar keine Rezession.
Und hier brauchen wir Aufklärung. Wie geht das, dass Journalisten, die unter den gleichen Alltagssachen leiden, wie jeder normale Mensch, innerhalb von zwei Minuten ihr Gehirn auf, also was der Shi heute gesagt hat, jetzt sollte der Trump aber mal. Und dann machen sie plötzlich so einen offenen Brief, Journalismus in der Politischen Champions League und schreiben ihren Forderungskatalog an den amerikanischen Präsidenten. Ja, so wie gestern. Wir stehen bei Nina Tjuba. Ich stehe natürlich hinten, wo die ganzen Dads rumstehen, während die Kids sich vorne da Spaß haben. Und ich kreuze ein bisschen auf meinem Handy rum. Und Thomas schickt mir so eine Nachricht her. Ich schicke das dann immer so nachher. Wie die Tagesschauüberschrift war einfach, Donald Trump sollte jetzt auf die Demokraten zugehen. Und ich denke mir so, das finde sogar ich offensiv. Und ich bin gar nicht der amerikanische Präsident. Also das ist doch einfach beleidigend. Jetzt so Imperative abzusondern. Weil man ja in der Rolle des und so, ja. Und das hier so also prächtig hat dieses Buch, finde ich, zu Unrecht in diesen Punkten so geschrieben. Aber diejenigen, die in diesen PMC Rollen drin sind und repräsentativ des Staates in Rolle als berufliche Aufgabe haben, müssen das jetzt reflektieren. Müssen.
Wie kann es sein, dass es da so eine hohe Anpassung gegeben hat? Ich will es mal an einer Anekdote festmachen. Ich hatte einen Deutschlehrer, der noch vom alten Schlag war, der war dann auch irgendwann pensioniert. Der war der Einzige, der nicht nur im Raucherzimmer rauchte, sondern der auch noch auf dem Schulhof rauchen durfte. Heute unvorstellbar. Das überhaupt noch. Ich glaube, es gibt noch nicht mal mehr Raucherzimmer irgendwo in Schulen. Der rauchte also noch auf dem Schulhof sogar. Und der kam auch schon mal mit der Zigarette aus dem Lehrerzimmer raus, wenn er gerufen wurde. Dann stand er so da. Du kannst dir mal vorstellen, das war der beste Lehrer. Mit dem konnte man über alles reden, weil der natürlich die ganzen institutionellen Anforderungen kannte. Dir aber als jemand begegnete, der sagte, ja, ich weiß, aber, na ja, ich bin auch nur ein Mensch und rauche halt mal gerne. Weiß er, dass man hier eigentlich nicht rauchen darf. Aber so und so hat er natürlich auf seine Schüler auch geblickt. Und dann hast du eine junge Garde gehabt, die hat genau nach Verordnung alles durchgesetzt und gesagt, und dann, wenn keiner guckte, ja, das waren so Leute, die, wenn kein Mensch mehr auf der Straße ist, trotzdem bei Rot stehen bleiben und warten, bis die Ampel irgendwann noch mal auf grün springt. So, genau diese Mentalität. Und die hat man ja heute überall eigentlich. Und da frage ich mich schon, was ist da passiert? Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das auch stark mit dem ökonomischen Druck zusammenhängt, dass die Situationen prekärer sind. Also muss ich mich viel mehr anpassen, muss dem allen Gehorsam leisten. Zugleich aber würde ich sagen, ja, es gibt welche, die darunter leiden, andere empfinden aber auch eine Lust. Also als man beispielsweise Bologna eingeführt hat, mit allen irrsinnigen Regeln, gab es schon Dozenten, die plötzlich eine große Lust darin fanden, diese Regelwerke eins zu eins umzusetzen. Also ich glaube, es gibt auch, wenn wir hier über autoritäre Charakter sprechen, die hier sicherlich gut getroffen sind, dann gibt es aber, glaube ich, bei denen, die nicht destruktiv sein wollen, auch unglaublich viele autoritäre Charakter, ist nicht das Thema des Buchs, aber die eigentlich auch beleuchtet werden müssen. Also es gibt schon welche, die würden dir, deinen Kindern nicht ermöglichen, dass du noch irgendwie ausreisen kannst, weil jetzt ist Staatspflicht, jetzt ist Krieg und so weiter. Jetzt aber noch mal alle Masken an und so. Also ich glaube, es gibt schon bei dieser PMC, Schicht ganz viele, die sich unglaublich wohlfühlen, autoritär zu sein und eigentlich auch autoritärer Charakter sind, das aber immer dann tarnen mit, wir sind die Vernünftigen, wir sind die aufgeklärten und sonst etwas. Und ich glaube, dass das bei sehr vielen Journalisten auch der Fall ist. Das hört man auch schon an dem Ton, wie sie sprechen.
Genau. Und jetzt will ich sozusagen weit über das Buch hinausgehen. Weil ich bin ja nur, ich bin zwar auch ein Soziologe, aber ich bin ja freischaffender Podcaster. So sehr, wie es eine illegitime Zerstörungslust gibt, von der Publikumseite, muss man sich auch jetzt, finde ich, mal mit akademischer Refinez damit befassen, welche Lust eigentlich in diesen PMC-Leuten drinsteckt. Genau wie du es jetzt gerade beschrieben hast. Die also irgendwo angekommen sind und dann zum Beispiel in diese Rolle des Polizisten. Ganz selbstverständlich einfach Leute auf der Straße zusammenschlagen, weil sie wissen, später, also meine Kollegen sagen ja nie gegen mich aus. Und in der Behörde ist auch alles klar. Wir haben das hier im Griff. Und hier könnte man ja für beide Seiten wieder ein klares Regelwerk schaffen. Wir haben nachher, ich habe es angekündigt, einen Text der New York Times, in dem Donald Trump völlig vage formuliert, was er will. Antifa, wer ist die Antifa? Marco Rubio erklärt sie jetzt zur internationalen Terrororganisation, sodass der ganze Staat dazugreifen kann, sobald der Verdacht auf Antifa besteht. Da kann man quasi mit NSA-Mitteln und so im Inland agieren. So, und diese Wahrheit ist das Problem. Und diese selbst verherrlichende Ausfüllung dieser Rolle, zum Beispiel des Hauptstadtjournalisten, die ist auf ganz neue Art und Weise zu kritisieren, habe ich jetzt festgestellt. Also so hart, wie das Publikum mit Zerstörungslust reagiert, muss man diese Repräsentationslust, ich bin der Staat, ich verkünde jetzt, auch mal kritisieren. Und sagen, der Mittelweg ist ein Regelwerk für alle. Lieber Journalist, sag mir einfach, was Sache ist. Erklär mir nicht nochmal, und so weiter und so fort. Ja, in deren Sicht, klar, würde das Buch übersteigen, aber es weckt sozusagen das Desiderat, hier diesen PMC, gerade weil wir es so aufgeladen haben durch Wagenknecht und Precht und so, die gerne sich daran abarbeiten, das sich auch nochmal genau anzuschauen.
Ja, und dieses ständige Argumentieren mit Sachzwängen, sagen ja Amlinger und Nachtwey, das führt genau in diese Sackgasse, die nur noch Wut und Zerstörung kennt. Sie schreiben ja ganz ausdrücklich, eine besonders vergiftete und vergiftende Variante der politisch konstruierten Sachzwänge war und ist die Austerität. Genau.
Keiner kann erklären.
Ja, Klamme Kassen, Eier.
Genau. Also man sieht ja geradezu, welche Lust Lars Klingenbeil hat. Ja. Jetzt auch mal für die SPD zu reklamieren, dass wir natürlich den Göttel enger schneiden und hier das Leistungsprinzip gilt. Das ist nicht nur eine Sache der Schwarzen, also der CDU.
Ja, ja.
So im Sinne von Gerhard Tröder steht auf der Bühne und sagt, die Schwarzen haben immer behauptet, der Staat gehöre ihnen. Und jetzt kommt Lars Klingenbeil sagt, in Ende gehört auch mir.
Ja.
Sparzwänge gibt es auch von mir. Man fragt sich, aber wieso? Wo ist die Plausibilität? Das sind einfach nur Verlegenheitswortbeiträge, die sich wie der junge Soldat auf dem Kasernenhof, der seinem Chef sich immer näher annähert. Eigentlich wollen sie aneinander vorbeigehen. Grüße ich jetzt oder nicht? Wie verhalte ich mich eigentlich richtig? Puh, zum Glück habe ich ein Regelwerk. Ich salutiere drei Meter, bevor ich begegne so, ja? Und dann entspannte Situationen für alle. Ich weiß genau, es kommt jetzt keine Verlegenheit auf. Ich laufe einfach hier lang, drei Meter vorher, salutiere ich, also siehe zurück, wir gehen aneinander vorbei. Ja, so. Und diesen Rückzug in die Verlegenheit, dass der SPD Finanzminister einfach sagt, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht weiter, aber das kann ich nicht sagen, deswegen sparen. Wir sparen jetzt einfach mal. So, und das muss hinterfragt werden. Also da fand ich jetzt diesen, das ist sehr viel einladender, wie das hier beschrieben wird, als wenn man da bricht oder Warnknecht oder so.
Ja, ja, weil sie auch sagen, mit der Selbstkritik ist es in der liberalen Demokratie nicht weit her. Und weil, schreiben sie, die liberale Kritik sich als alternativlos vernünftig betrachtet, gilt Kritik an ihr, ob sie nun Ungleichheit oder Migration beanstatten, als antidemokratischer Populismus. Ja, diese Populismuskeule werden wir dann überall plötzlich, weil jeder sich gerne dahinter verstecken will, dass man doch jetzt hier das wahrhaft aufrechte, rationale und so weiter vertritt. Ich habe das ja mit dieser SPD-Abgeordneten erlebt, als ich bei der Frankfurter Rundschau diskutiert habe.
Ja, das habe ich gesehen.
Da wurde mir dann auch gleich Populismus vorgeworfen.
Und dabei wolltest du noch wissen, wo ist denn jetzt die Mehrheit für teures Wohnen, bei denen sie immer sagen, wir können jetzt nicht alles neu machen und und so weiter. Ach, es gibt eine Mehrheit für teures Wohnen. Das wusste ich gar nicht. Ich dachte immer, die Leute wollen billiger Wohnen. Sie haben ja dieses Zauberwerk. Sie kommen natürlich auf Graeber, also David Graeber, unseren Lieblingsautoren Bordieu zu sprechen. Wie wurde es geschafft, dass dieser paternalistische Staat die Eigentumsfragen so wirkmächtig, aber so unsichtbar macht und all diesen liberalen Firlefanz, Appelle-Dings, Pipapo so sichtbar, aber so ablenkend und sinnlos? Warum befassen wir uns damit? Und ja, was soll man sagen? Es ist der große Erfolg des Neoliberalismus, die linke Kritik einfach einzupreisen und sie im Gewand der Selbstsorge wieder aufs Podium zu stellen. Und da muss man sagen, ja erwischt, das betrifft uns alle.
Wo sollen wir weitermachen? Wir haben ja so viel Material. Vielleicht sollen wir zum Kapitel 2, das blockierte Leben, schreiten.
Ja, hier kriegen wir eine geniale Aufklärung zum Thema. Die Leute sagen immer, ihnen geht es gut. Und bei der Frage, wie geht es der Gesellschaft, sagen sie schlecht. Und wir haben uns immer darüber gewundert. Und jetzt sagen uns die beiden hier, ja, das stimmt ja auch so gar nicht. Die Leute, so wie die Leistungsrolle aus Verlegenheit sich auf den, was weiß ich, die Bürokratie zurückzieht und sagt, ne, wir müssen es jetzt hier so machen und so, sagen einfach die Leute im Publikum einfach so, ihnen ginge es gut, um sich davor zu schützen, dass irgendwer kommt und sagt, ach so, dann gehörst du zu den Armutschwachen. Nein, ich doch nicht, mir geht es gut. Aber die Gesellschaft.
Der Herr Kunz, der ist Gebäudereiniger.
Er hat alles richtig gemacht, immer die geforderte Leistung erbracht.
Er ist schwul, er lebt mit seinem Partner in einer kleinen Wohnung, er wählt die AfD und er träumt davon, dass er im Lotto gewinnt. Dann würde er nämlich in Südamerika eine Pommesbude eröffnen und die dann zu einem großen Franchise hochziehen. Amlinger und Nachtwey schreiben den wunderbaren Satz, Kunst ist ein Gewinner, der noch nicht gewonnen hat. Er selbst nämlich sagt nicht, ach ja, das ist ja jetzt nicht alles so rund gelaufen, ich lebe ja nur in einer kleinen Wohnung und ich müsste ja zumindest froh sein, dass wir jetzt eine gesellschaftliche Liberalisierung haben, dass ich mit meinem Partner so zusammenleben kann, ohne diskriminiert zu werden. Nein, er wählt die AfD und er sieht sich nicht als ein Verlierer ansieht, aber dass alles den Bach runtergeht.
Dieses Gewinner sein, aber noch nicht gewonnen zu haben, das ist ja, du hast es ja bei Ben ungeskriptet und so. Es schauen sehr viele Leute zu, die 18 sind und glauben, sie wären mit 28 Millionär. Und irgendwann werden sie 28 sein und AfD wählen und wieder Kunst sagen, sorry, ich habe alles getan, aber ihr habt ein blockiertes Leben.
Ja, aber ich könnte Millionär sein, wenn die Grünen nicht wären, wenn dies und das nicht wäre, der böse Staat, der mir alles wegnimmt.
Genau. Man zählt auf gar keinen Fall zu den Verlierern und Losern, denn das sind ja die, die das Leben blockieren, von uns Blockierten. Ich gehöre nicht zu denen, die anderen das Leben blockieren. Ich gehe jetzt nicht zum Staat. Schamvoll. Stolz vergessen und fordere irgendwie Geld ein. Also das ist in der Deutlichkeit, in der sie das hier beschreiben, dass diese Leute vielleicht einfach lügen, sich selbst belügen, ist schon trifftig, finde ich. Und immer wieder fallen diese Sätze. Viele unserer Gesprächspartner verfügen lediglich über überschaubare soziale Kreise. Die sind nicht zwangsläufig einsam, empfinden das Alleinsein sogar positiv, denn sie haben ja sich selber. Aber es geht halt nicht auf. Also wir haben es mit sehr vielen sozialen schwachen Menschen zu tun.
Sie beziehen sich auf den Psychologen Michael Makobi, der schon in den 70er Jahren geschrieben hat, dass es sein kann, dass Emotionen so zentral für politische Einstellungen werden, dass sie den eigenen materiellen Interessen zuwiderlaufen. Dennoch hält man an denen fest. Also man kann da wirklich von einem politischen Amoklauf sprechen, denn der Amoklauf sieht ja auch in der Regel so aus, dass man andere in den Abgrund reißt und sich dann schlussendlich auch selbst.
Ja, wir haben diese neue Risikokultur. Sie kommen auf Giddens Beck, Ulrich Beck zu sprechen. Dieses, man hat sein Schicksal in der Hand, aber muss es eben auch in die Hand nehmen, dann gelingt das irgendwie nicht. Man spielt sich selber was vor, man verurteilt die eigenen Kinder, weil sie plötzlich nicht mitziehen. Wie auch immer. Also sind es auch sehr traurige Geschichten, die überall erzählt werden. Ja, also da gibt es zum Beispiel den Büchner, Herr Büchner, der den Kontakt zu seinem Sohn abgebrochen hat, weil der Sohn nicht leistungsfähig ist. Der scheint wohl zu faul zu sein. Und der Vater hat lieber keinen Kontakt zu seinem Sohn, als Kontakt zu einem faulen Sohn zu haben. Weil Leistung für ihn alles bedeutet. Und so ist auch seine Idee, wie er sich das vorstellt, wie man mit Flüchtlingen umgehen soll. Da sagt er, es kann jeder kommen. Also wir müssen auch hier das, weil ich es jetzt mal so mit Clips gespielt hatte, von Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund, denen sie auch die ganze Zeit thematisieren und dann aber sagen, jetzt nicht diese ganzen Flüchtlinge einfach so reinlassen. Ja, es war eben Sam Mato und seine Kollegen. Und was wir hier wieder sehen können, ist, dass jemand sagt, also nicht per se gegen Migration, aber es wird mit einem Sozialdarwinismus verknüpft. Da sagt er, es kann jeder kommen und jeder kriegt drei Monate Zeit. Und in den drei Monaten kann er sich einen Job suchen. Wer das nicht schafft, der fliegt wieder raus. Aber nicht mit Lufthansa und Polizeibegleitung, sondern die werden im Marsch über die Grenze begleitet und kriegen einen richtigen Tritt, ja, einen Tritt, der so wehtut, dass er nicht wiederkommt. Also hier sehen wir jemanden, der selbst früh verrentet ist, im Übrigen, der also offenbar auch nicht so leistungsfähig mehr ist, sondern früh verrentet ist, der keinerlei Ahnung von Falkoswirtschaft hat, der glaubt, dass die Arbeit ja dann schon entsteht, wenn die Leute, die kommen, sich danach greifen, bemühen, ja, als würde einfach Arbeit entstehen, wenn man Arbeit will. Und der jetzt auch noch nicht nur diesen Sozialdarwinismus hat, sondern auch noch mal diese Lust an der Strafe. Also die müssen auch noch mal getreten werden. Sie müssen nicht nur ausgewiesen werden, sondern muss sie auch noch mal bestrafen dafür.
Diese Leute nehmen lieber Distanz zu ihrer eigenen Familie in Kauf, um nicht die emotionale Distanz zu denjenigen, die ihnen ans Zeug wollen, also Migranten und so, um die abbauen zu müssen.
Ja.
Das sind so harte, kognitive Dissonanzen, die aber hier sehr gut erklärt werden. Also diese reine Kunst. Rainer Kunz und Charlie Mayer, die ihr Kreuz bei der AfD gemacht haben, schreiben sie, hadern nicht mit ihren Entscheidungen. Ihr Zorn richtet sich vielmehr auf Menschen, die sich ihre soziale Position aus ihrer Sicht unregelmäßig erschlichen haben. Soweit, so verständlich. Deutlich wird hier, schreiben sie jetzt, Diskrepanzen zwischen der Wahrnehmung der eigenen und der Situation der Gesellschaft insgesamt, also dass die immer sagen, mir geht es gut, aber nicht sehr schnell, resultieren aus dem Umstand, dass moderne Gefühlsstrukturen subjektiv weiter bestehen, während sie objektiv ihre Geltung eingebüßt haben. Und das finde ich ein ganz prägendes Phänomen, denn das erleben ja heute viele, also auch in der Radiosendung da die Woche, war ja eine Frau zu Gast, die eben, ich weiß nicht genau, aber wohl so 20 Jahre älter war als jetzt ich und noch mal 40 Jahre älter als der Quentin. Und die dann noch mal, ja wir hatten es ja früher auch schlecht und so. Wir hängen also emotional immer noch in so einer Industriegesellschaft, in der, wenn wir die Schule gut absolvieren, kriegen wir eine gute Ausbildung, dann mag uns der Chef und dann kriegen wir eine gute Anstellung. So, das ist die Gefühlswelt, mit der Großeltern auf die Biografien ihre Enkeln treffen. Und die Enkel dann so, nee, das ist mit der Ausbildung, das hast du irgendwie falsch verstanden. Ich weiß gar nicht, wovon du redest. Industrie, also welcher Chef? Ich habe keinen Chef, ich bin Clickworker, wie auch immer. Ich habe noch nie jemanden gesehen, bin alle im Homeoffice. Mein Chef sitzt in Singapur und schläft immer, wenn ich arbeite. Und wir legen aber unsere Leistungserwartung, unser, wie generieren wir eigentlich Stolz und so, aus so einer Gefühlswelt, Fantasy, die der Realität nicht standhält. Und dann sehen wir natürlich immer lauter Leute, die darunter scheitern, die daran scheitern, schon branchenübergreifend. Leute arbeiten irgendwie im verarbeitenden Gewerbe und verstehen einfach nicht, dass andere immer keinen Feierabend haben, also nicht zur Verfügung stehen als Freunde nach 17 Uhr, sondern erst so 19 Uhr und so. Also lauter solche Disbalancen. Und wie sie ja darüber schreiben, wie sehr diese Gefühlswelt einfach der Imperativ fürs Leben ist. Und man Realität einfach ausblendet, das einfach gar nicht verstehen will. Und sich selbst von seiner eigenen Familie distanziert. Hauptsache, man muss nicht hinterfragen, wie man über Fremde denkt und ihr Leistungsfähigkeit. Das ist schon, boah, das ist wirklich, man liest das so und denkt, wir können jetzt nicht einfach alle nur noch Scham und Stolztherapie machen, um hier mal die AfD abzuwehren.
Naja.
Aber irgendwie scheinen das die Einführungsschneiden zu sein. Raumausstatterin Mathilde Kohler, sie bezeichnet sich selbst als Außenseiterin. Ihre Mutter, mit der ist sie wieder zusammengezogen, nachdem der Vater gestorben ist, keinerlei Unterstützung vom Arbeitsamt erhalten. Der Vater vor seinem Tod alles verweigert. Und dann sagt sie einfach hier im Gespräch, um Hilfe zu bekommen, müsse man, Zitat, anscheinend eine Hakennase aufkleben oder Kopftuch tragen. Nur dann wird man vom Staat wahrgenommen. Politische Forderungen liegen ihr ganz fern. Stattdessen beginnt sie nochmal ein Studium. Leben ist ja noch nicht voll genug. Kapitalismus wird nicht hinterfragt. Ihr Chef sagt ihr die ganze Zeit als Raumausstatterin, also wir müssen ein paar Leute entlassen, aber dich noch nicht zum Glück.
Und deshalb schätzt sie ihn so sehr.
Dankbar, sie liebt ihren Chef dafür, dass er sie nicht kapitalistisch aussortiert hat. Schlimm, schlimm, was sie so lesen.
Sie schreiben, ihr Zorn richtet sich vielmehr nach oben gegen liberale Eliten, die ihre Not durch übertriebene Regulierungen verstärken und überhaupt erst verursachen. Und nach unten gegen Einwanderer und Arbeitshosen, gegen all die, die nichts leisten und darum aus ihrer Sicht illegitime Unterstützung beziehen. Theodor W. Adorno unterstrich den funktionalen Charakter des antisemitischen Vorurteils, das bloß oberflächlich an soziale Gruppen gebunden sei und leicht von einem Objekt zum nächsten gleiten könne. In Collas Schilderung finden sich viele solche Stereotypen-Fantasien, die bloß in Andeutungen formuliert werden und dadurch abstrakt bleiben. Als sie den Satz ausgesprochen hat, richtet sie sich direkt an uns. Man sieht es ja überall. Eigentlich müsste man sie korrigieren. Sie fühlt es überall und zu jeder Zeit. Gefühle haben ihre eigene Wahrheit. Wir können ihr zwar widersprechen, was wir in unserer Rolle als Interviewende-Soziologin nicht taten, aber das würde ihre Empfindung verletzter Reziprozität vermutlich eher noch verstärken.
Ja. Und dann kommen sie auf diesen sehr klugen Gedanken Richard Sennett und Jonathan Cobb und Michael Young, um ihre Identität vor den Verletzungen des Leistungsprizips zu schützen. Entwickeln die Arbeiterinnen laut Sennett und Cobb ein gespaltenes Selbst, ein divided Self. Sie teilen ihre Identität in polare Kompartimente auf, eine außenorientierte performende und ein verborgenes reales Selbst.
Ja.
Und es begegnet einem so häufig, dass Familien, ich habe es schon mal beschrieben, die darunter leiden, dass der Vater nicht mehr so richtig kann mit seinen 80 Jahren und ein Gebrechen nach dem anderen hat. Aber sobald der Arzt sich anmeldet, putzt man sich raus, zieht einen Anzug an, auf die Frage hin, wo drückt denn der Schuh?
Nirgendwo.
Ich bin ein starker, stolzer Mann. Hat ihnen meine Frau schon wieder gesagt, dass ich... Nein, hier ist alles in Ordnung. Der Arzt verlässt das Haus und man quält seine Frau zehn weitere Stunden pro Tag mit den eigenen Gebrechen. Und das ist ein... Also, man kann es gar nicht mehr... Man möchte die Leute einfach rütteln und sagen, komm, zeig doch einfach dein wahres Ich.
Ja.
Fordere etwas ein. Und es ist wirklich...
Ja, ja, also diese Absurdität auch. Es gibt eine 32-Jährige, ich habe jetzt gerade den Namen nicht parat, die sich durch die Corona-Maßnahmen radikalisiert hat und feststellt, ich bin kein Online-Shopper. Also indem sie erleben musste, dass die Geschäfte zuhaben und sie dann nicht als Konsumentin ihre Neigung nachgehen konnte, ist sie radikalisiert worden. Aber Amlinger und Nachtwey schreiben dann, dass diese Feststellung, ich bin kein Online-Shopper, ja nicht nur sie als Neigung präsentiert, sondern sie sagt damit, das ist ihre Identität. Also ich bin kein Online-Shopper. Also sie ist Analog-Shopperin. Da heißt es, Individuum zu sein, heißt, Kunde zu sein. Dieses Selbstverständnis ist ein Resultat einer über Jahrzehnte durchgesetzten Politik der Marktbürgerschaft, einer Art Verkundung der Gesellschaft. Denn das ist ja auch etwas, was wir sehr gut sehen konnten. Während der Corona-Pandemie plötzlich haben wir Politiker erlebt, die laufend den Bürger heraufbeschworen haben, wo sie sonst immer nur den Konsumenten, den Verbraucher meinten. Und dann waren sie auch ganz enttäuscht, warum die Bürger dann nicht gehorchen. Was haben denn die ganze Zeit diese Konsumenten davor? Wir können jetzt nicht schon wieder ein Geschäft aufmachen. Aber man hat die ganze Zeit den Konsumenten gewollt.
Genau, genau, genau. Ja, ja. Wir nähern uns jetzt hier dieser Nullsum-Logik. Das ist natürlich alles extrem spannend. Warte, ich hatte gerade noch einen Punkt. Ach so, ja, genau. Nicht aus den Notizen, sondern jetzt mal so, was lernen wir bis hier raus aus dem Buch? Diese Frage, wie geht es Ihnen, ist die Standardfrage der Demoskopie. Man macht nur eine thematische Variation. Friedrich Marx hat das gesagt, wie finden Sie das? Grenzen zu, wie finden Sie das? Bla, bla, bla, wie finden Sie das? Wie geht es Ihnen damit? So, die Lehre hier raus ist, diese Menschen lügen immer. Wir machen immer nur so einen Joke, dass wir sagen, also jetzt hat irgendein Comedian auf der Bühne und will mal einen ernsten Punkt machen und sagt, also wenn ich die Leute frage, wie geht's? Und die sagen gut, dann sage ich, komm, wir setzen uns kurz hin und ich frage dich, wie es dir geht. So, das ist natürlich albern. Ja, aber auch ohne die Nachfrage, wie geht es dir wirklich, müssen wir jetzt einpreisen. Auf die Frage hin, wie geht es Ihnen? Und die Antwort lautet gut. Müssen wir immer denken, das ist gelogen. Das ist immer gelogen. Die ganze Demoskopie, finde ich, sollte eine Revolution unterzogen werden. Man kann gar keine Demoskopie machen. Man kann nur noch wie Steffen Mao und die beiden hier sich hinsetzen und mit den Leuten ernsthaftes Gespräch führen und daraus Ableitung finden. Aber einfach eine Grundgesamtheit anrufen, ihnen eine Frage zu stellen und dann die sozial konforme Antwort einzusammeln und zu sagen, und das vermelden wir heute als, das ist der Gefühlszustand Deutschland, das geht einfach nicht.
Und dann sagt man irgendwie, wir sind das siebtglücklichste Land oder so was.
Wir sind die reichste Volkswirtschaft, also die drittreiste größte Volkswirtschaft der Welt. Aber die Leute auf die Frage hin, wie geht es ihnen, wenn sie sagen gut, ist gelogen. Ist einfach gelogen. Und die Leute merken es selber nicht. Sondern sie sind gefangen und jetzt kommt es eben in dieser Nullsumme Logik, die jetzt greift. Denn der Staat kann zwei verschiedene Aufgaben haben, die aber ganz unterschiedlich aus, also sie haben das selbe Ziel, aber es ist noch ganz unterschiedlich. Zum einen könnte man bedarfsorientiert dem Einzelnen helfen. Ja. Oder aber man kann Ressourcen verteilen. Und das ist ein ganz großer Unterschied. Denn wenn man in der Ressourcen-Logik denkt, ist irgendwann das Windhund-Prinzip leer gelaufen und dann ist nichts mehr da. Und dann kann der Einzelne noch so viel Bedarf haben, das Budget ist einfach aufgebraucht. Und wir sind doch in erheblichem Maße jetzt in diese Budget-Falle getappt, weil wir unsere Konflikte nicht mehr durch Entgrenzung, Wachstum und so weiter lösen, sondern jetzt einfach gegenüberstellen. Ansprüche, schön und gut, aber ihr kennt ja die Budgets. Und damit ist natürlich jeder einzelne Migrant ein Eindringling.
Ja, weil der Kuchen nicht mehr größer wird.
Man kann ihn gar nicht anders verrechnen. Ja, ihn begrüßen, er kostet Geld. Also meine Kirigor Giesi hat ja diesen berühmten Tag der offenen Tür-Auftritt da in der Bundespressekonferenz, wo er die Leute so fragt, also glauben sie jetzt wirklich, wenn wir denen was wegnehmen, kriegen sie mehr Bürgergeld? So funktioniert das doch hier nicht. Es sind zwei verschiedene Töpfe. Aber das alles in einem Topf zu denken, ist jetzt der Hegemon. Das ist das Hegemoniale Denken, das grundsätzlich nicht mehr gerechtfertigt werden muss, weil alle sagen, das versteht sich doch von selbst.
Das aber medial produziert wurde.
Absolut.
Das ist ja nicht etwas, worauf Leute einfach kommen.
Es ist inhaltlich falsch und methodisch einfach so krass medial verbreitet worden, dass wir jetzt alle in diesem Denken drin stehen.
Und wir wundern uns ja, dass das, obwohl wir gerade diese ganzen Sondervermögen haben, beispielsweise für die Bundeswehr, dass dieses Denken heute genauso unangefochten dasteht wie zuvor. Also wir hören ja nach wie vor den Tagesschaubericht, das heute schon nahe dazu, dass die Klammen Kassen es nicht zulassen, dass der Kulturpass weitergeführt wird, das 9-Euro-Ticket muss abgeschafft werden, das 49-Euro-Ticket muss ein 59-Euro-Ticket werden. All diese Dinge hören wir die ganze Zeit, während sie 30 Sekunden vorher verkünden, dass man ein Bundeswehr-Sondervermögen hat und dass jetzt da das keine Rolle mehr spielt. Also das ist ja auch interessant.
Das wird ja sofort auch wieder eingepreist.
Ja, das will klar.
Wie zahlen wir da so viel Geld? Das können wir nicht und so weiter.
Ja, und dass das aber so ein prägendes Denken nach wie vor ist, wo man ja jetzt schon mehrmals gesehen hat, nee, wenn die Politik will, dann kann das durchaus in eine andere Richtung gehen. Das ist ja eigentlich das Absurde. Also die Radikalisierung, die eigentlich der Mainstream-Journalismus produziert, die ist noch gar nicht richtig erfasst.
Ja, ich will es mal an dieser Drastigkeit, denn ich finde, hier könnte man einfach ergänzen, was der Text nicht ganz hergibt. Also hier steht, nur wer den Beitrag zahlt, darf Mitglied werden. Das ist ja unsere Sozialkassen-Thematik, die wir ganz seit so diskutieren. Über die Legitimität von Ansprüchen entscheidet in der Nullsumm-Logik nicht primär der Maßstab der Bedürftigkeit einer Person. Vielmehr richtet er sich der Blick umgekehrt auf die Belastbarkeit der Gesellschaft. Und jetzt muss man einfach sagen, dieser Unhinterfrag der Kapitalismus zieht seine ganze Kraft aus Krediten. Also nicht jemand zahlt einen Beitrag und bekommt dann später etwas, sondern genau umgedreht. Er bekommt erst etwas und zahlt dann später ein Kredit zurück. Das ist die Wachstumslogik. Das ist das Erfolgsmodell. Das sind 400 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte, die aus 300.000 Jahren Stagnation eine Explosion an Menschen, Wissen, Material, was auch immer gemacht hat. Ja. So, wenn wir das jetzt einfach, weil wir nicht Lust haben, darüber nachzudenken und uns emotional so ein Willespektakel ausliefern, sagen, nee, zuerst werden die Beiträge bezahlt und danach das Budget verteilt, dann ist Ende einfach. Das ist das Zündholz. Ja. Ja. Untergebrochen.
Man braucht, wir brauchen nicht irgendwie...
Also es brennt schon lichterloh eigentlich.
Irgendeine Agenda, irgendeine Projektion, so und so.
Dass jetzt noch jemand sagt, er möchte es auch zerstören, nee, es zerstört sich ja gerade von alleine. Ja. So müssen wir einfach nur abwarten. Sie machen sich zwar später ein bisschen lustig über den Axelitarismus, aber so ganz von der Hand zu weisen, ist das ja nicht.
Ja.
Überhaupt jetzt die Klimakonferenz, ja, who cares? Niemand mehr. Also es ist ja wirklich absurd alles. Von daher, diese Verdrehung der Logik, ja, also von Bedarf einer Person auf Belastungsgrenze der Gesellschaft, diese radikale Nationalisierung unseres Gefühldenkens, diese Pseudo-Vorstellung von der Nationalstaat als Schutzschirm, der uns dann unterstützt, wenn wir niemandem Geld auszahlen, ist einfach, das ist lichter-, ich sehe einfach eine lichterlohe Flamme, die schon alles angezündet hat.
Ja, und das geht ja immer so weiter. Also es gibt ja noch nicht irgendeinen, einen Ausbruch. Wir können vielleicht zum Thema Destruktivität übergehen, zum dritten Kapitel. Zerstörungslust. Da ist Anette Kowalski, die wanderte kurz vor der Wende mit ihrem Mann, dem gemeinsamen kleinen Kind und zwei Koffern aus Polen in die Bundesrepublik. Sie möchte aber auf keinen Fall als Opfer hingestellt werden.
Genau.
Also sie ist keine benachteiligte Minderheit.
Ich bin kein Opfer.
Sie hat sich durchgekämpft. Ihr Motto ist, fördern und fordern. Kommt wieder in die Puschen. Ja. Das erwartet sie auch von allen anderen. Die nebenberufliche als Fitnesstrainerin arbeitende Annette Kowalskis voller Tatentrang. Für sie gibt es nichts Schlimmeres, als aufgehalten und blockiert zu werden. Sie hat Polen verlassen, weil sie sich ein besseres Leben aufbauen wollte. Das Gleichheitsideal des Sozialismus habe in ihrer Heimat paradoxe Effekte gezeigt. Das vermeintliche Streben nach Egalität habe große Ungerechtigkeiten sowie neue Gewinner und Verlierer hervorgebracht. Annette Kowalski setzt dieser aus ihrer Sicht verfehlten Gleichmacherei, den Leitsatz jedem das Seine entgegen, wobei sie einräumt, dass das vielleicht ein blöder Slogan sei. Also sie ahnt wahrscheinlich, dass das ein bisschen so… also der kommt da nicht her, aber dass der nun 38 am Tor des Konzentrationslagers Buchenwald hing, das ist ja offenbar schon klar. Für sie ist die meritokratische Ordnung völlig okay. Sie sagt, nicht alle wollen Chefs werden. Nicht alle wollen Entscheidungen treffen und Verantwortung tragen. Viele Menschen wollen das eben nicht. Gerechtigkeit ist für mich, dass ich ein besseres Leben habe, wenn ich mehr leiste, mehr Verantwortung übernehme und gute Ideen habe. Und die anderen, die das nicht wollen, haben vielleicht ein etwas schlechteres Leben. Somit rechtfertigt sie also die Bedingungen. Für sie ist klar, dass wir in einer Diktatur leben. Und zwar seit der Corona-Pandemie. Sie findet aber auch Putins Maßnahmen gut. Der Vogue-Liberalismus, der ist schädlich. Sie will für die AfD stimmen. Wenn dann aber kein fundamentaler Wandel entsteht, dann droht sie, nach Polen zurückzugehen. Also das ist alles, ja. Also wo sie jetzt, man würde jetzt geopolitisch sagen, also die Polen sind gerade die, die am stärksten sagen, Putin ist unser Feind und wir müssen dort sehen, dass wir irgendwie gegen ihn vorgehen. Und jetzt sagt sie, Putin finde ich eigentlich gut, aber ich gehe nach Polen zurück, weil hier in Deutschland ist ja nicht mehr alles in Ordnung.
Sie wäre einfach sehr überrascht, auf welche Realität sie trifft mit ihrer Gefühlswelt. Also diese ganze Destruktivität, die da drinsteckt, diese Zerstörungslust, sie haben ja hier diesen, es ist kein Fragenkatalog, sondern sind so Aussagen, die kann man mal kurz durchgehen. Ich bekomme einen Kick, wenn Naturkatastrophen in fremden Ländern auftreten. Da sagen manche Leute ja. Ich stelle mir vor, dass eine Naturkatastrophe den größten Teil der Menschheit auslöscht, sodass eine kleine Gruppe von Menschen neu anfangen kann. Ich denke, die Gesellschaft sollte bis auf die Grundmauer niedergebrannt werden. Wenn ich über unsere politischen und sozialen Institutionen nachdenke, kann ich nicht anders als zu denken, lasst sie einfach alle verbrennen. Wir können die Probleme in unseren sozialen Institutionen nicht beheben, wir müssen sie abreißen und neu anfangen. Ich brauche Chaos um mich herum, es ist zu langweilig, wenn nichts los ist. Manchmal habe ich einfach Lust, schöne Dinge zu zerstören. Das ist das Becken, in dem diese Gefühlsmenschen hier aufgefangen werden.
Sie haben versucht, dann auch noch mal Fragen zu formulieren, die so gehen, also die man dann den Kandidaten stellt. Ist es gerechtfertigt, wenn illegale Einwanderer bei Grenzübertritt von ihren Kindern getrennt werden? Sollte man Asylbewerber, wenn sie eine Straftat begehen, direkt wieder in ihr Heimatland schicken, ganz gleich, ob sie dort um ihr Leben fürchten müssen? Braucht es härtere Strafen für Menschen, die Gesetze brechen? Sollten Menschen, die sich an Kindern vergehen, mit dem Tod bestraft werden? Und die Todesstrafe ist da tatsächlich auch immer wieder im Gespräch bei den Kandidaten, die sie da haben. Und solche Gewalt-Fantasien, die sich dann äußern, also was alles mit den Delinquente gemacht werden soll, ist wirklich ganz, ganz erstaunlich.
Und ich will es noch mal vorlesen, weil es auch hier wieder im Text vorkommt. Man muss echt dies immer wieder betonen. Also sie kommen auf diese hardcore destruktiven Menschen zu sprechen. Hier im Bezug auf Amerika. Und dann der Satz, die entsprechenden Menschen haben eine hohe Status- und Dominanzorientierung und fühlen sich sozial depraviert. Die sind einfach sozial schwach.
Ja. Und für die AfD machen sie ja drei Gruppen aus. Ökonomisch benachteiligte und abgehängte Menschen, insbesondere aus der Arbeiterklasse, die sich so einen Wohlfahrts-Schauvinismus wünschen, dass man sagt, nee, die jetzt nicht. Die sehen ja nicht so aus wie wir. Zweitens Personen aus der Mittelschicht, die sich in der Reziprozität der Beiträge zum Gemeinwesen verletzt sehen. Ja, die Migranten nämlich, die kommen ja und werden integriert und dürfen gleich Zugang haben. Und drittens dann Angehörige der oberen Mittel oder Oberklasse, die vor allem aus ideologischen Gründen rechts wählen, also die ja gar nicht eine eigene materielle Wirklichkeit haben, die sie dazu führt, sondern die sagen, so kann es ja nicht sein, das ist nicht deutsch, das ist nicht dies, so muss es eigentlich sein.
Ja, da stelle ich mir mal vor, bei so manchen Bernd Baumann oder Höcke Sachen, die so medial transportiert werden, hören manche Leute einfach zu, so wie wir Händel hören. Es geht so harmonisch zu, mein Deutschsein wird verherrlicht, der ganze Kramwärter, das wird einfach nur so melodisch unter gefegt mir, so rein ästhetisch, dass da noch so eine ethische Frage dranhängt, ist da einfach ausgeblendet.
Sie kommen dann auf den Begriff der Jouissance zu sprechen von Jacques Lacan, dass man also so eine, ja, so ein Begehren, eine Lust empfinden kann daran, dass alles untergeht beziehungsweise, dass es anderen richtig schlecht geht. Sie sagen dann hier, die Items in dem Fragebogen, also die du jetzt vorgelesen hast, zielen auf die Messung einer Form reiner negative Lust, die der französische Psychoanalytiker Jacques Lacan als Jouissance bezeichnet hat. Diese Lust kann sich gegen sich selbst wenden und verbindet ein exzessives Begehren mit Destruktivität. Lacan beschreibt mit dem Begriff transgressive Grenzerfahrungen, in denen Lust und Schmerz, Ordnung und Chaos unauflöslich miteinander verwoben sind und in denen das Subjekt zwischen Leben und Tod oszilliert. Das klingt jetzt erstmal sehr abstrakt, aber wir können uns das sehr gut vorstellen. Also, dass man dort Leute hat, die zum Beispiel das sagen, was du so häufig zitierst, die Japaner sind, im Pflegebett schon liegen und sagen, nee, eher sterbe ich hier einsam, eher irgendein Vietnamese hier mich im Bett drehen wird.
Das ist auch von Tucker Carlson gehört.
Schiebt sie ab, schmeißt sie raus.
Tucker Carlson auf der Bühne, lieber brenne ich mein Haus nieder, bevor da ein Migrant einzieht. Und sie schreiben es ja hier auch, das Risiko der potentiellen Selbstauslöschung ist zugleich ein Kick, durch den man sich wieder lebendig führt. Es lebe der Tod. So denken diese Leute. Aber ich muss man immer wieder sagen, sehr gut, der Glaube, dass man durch eine Talkshow hier nochmal jemanden erreicht, indem man, was weiß ich, das Heizungsgesetz durchnudelt.
Die mittlere und hohe Destruktivität ist bei jungen Leuten tatsächlich sehr hoch. Höher als bei den älteren. Sie haben ja da einige Grafiken, in denen uns das erklärt wird. Das fand ich doch erstaunlich. Dass die Destruktivität, die bei knapp 30 Prozent zum Teil liegt, bei den 18- bis 29-Jährigen am höchsten ist. Also bei 28,9 Prozent oder die hohe Destruktivität bei 24,8 Prozent. Und dann fällt das ab. Bei 60 plus ist es dann nur noch bei 12,8 bzw. 10,6 Prozent. Was immer noch viel ist, aber wir sehen, dass es schon mit jungen Jahren destruktiv zugeht.
Also Thüringen. Ja. Wenn es in Thüringen keine Wähler über 60 gäbe, die noch mal sagen, sorry, aber ich bin ein bisschen näher dran an große Weltkriegszerstörung und so weiter, wäre Höcke dort längst Ministerpräsident. Das sind einfach die jungen Leute, die zurückgebliebenen Männer. Ja, also dieses Buch hat ja zwei Aufklärungen. Nicht nur die jungen, sondern auch die Frauen. Ja. Bei den Frauen möchte ich gern so einsteigen. Wir kennen dieses Phänomen der Karen. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel du dich auf Instagram rumtreibst.
Natürlich kenne ich das Phänomen der Karen. Aber sollen wir es mal kurz erklären? Eine Karen ist so eine Mittel-Oberklasse-Weiße-Frau, die sich über alles Mögliche empört und in Rage reden kann und dabei nie über ihre eigenen Privilegien, ihren eigenen Status reflektiert, sondern immer sieht, dass ihr da etwas zusteht und etwas genommen wird durch die Wurken oder durch die Migrationshintergrund, irgendigen Fremder. Und das ist so eine Schiffre geworden, dass sich da wieder eine Karen aufregt.
So, das Ding ist, Karens sind extrem konfrontativ. Das macht ja die Videos so unterhaltsam. Die stehen auf irgendwelchen Parkplätzen und beklagen sich, dass irgendein Auto drei Zentimeter zu weit auf die Straße ragt oder irgend sowas. Gruppen ohne Ende und der ganze Kram. So, jetzt ist die Frage, wenn wir dieses Karen-Phänomen so sichtbar haben, wie viele Karens gibt's, die genauso denken, aber nicht ganz so konfrontativ auftreten, also die ihre Performance im Griff haben, die sich also friedleben geben, aber eigentlich die Welt anzünden wollen?
Ja.
Und hier gibt das Buch doch sehr gut Aufklärung.
Ja, sie sagen, die Frauen, mit denen wir gesprochen haben, weisen einige aufschlussreiche Gemeinsamkeiten auf. Sie geben sich betont, tolerant und friedliebend, gehörten jedoch häufig zu den destruktivsten Personen in der Stichprobe. Sie sind die, die den Satz, stell dich nicht so an, ganz verinnerlicht haben. Das heißt, wir bekommen jetzt also einige Kandidatinnen vorgeführt, die in ihrer Grausamkeit die Männer zum Teil noch deutlich überbieten.
Also wir haben sie mit verschiedenen Phänomenen zu tun, wie dass Frauen auf eine Art und Weise, wie Männer das natürlich nicht machen in einer patriarchalen Gesellschaft, sich sowieso schon ausgegrenzt fühlen. Ja. Und mit besonderem Fleiß, besonderen Verweisen auf die eigene biografischen Leistungen dann plötzlich mit dieser angeblichen Realität des Migranten, dem ihr alles in den Arsch geblasen wird, konfrontiert sehen.
Da ist beispielsweise Emilia Gerber, die ist Mitte 20. Aber heißt es hier, in ihr ist viel Bitterkeit begraben. Aufgewachsen ist sie in einfachen Verhältnissen auf dem Land. Bescheidenheit und Fleiß gehörten in ihrer sozialdemokratischen Familie zu den zentralen Werten. Sie machte eine Ausbildung in einem Industriekonzern, empfand jedoch bald die gesamte Unternehmensstruktur als frauenfeindlich, ihre Vorgesetzten als ungerecht und feindselig. Würde man jetzt denken, ah ja, dann hat die bestimmt eine Gewerkschaft gegründet, ist in einer feministischen Gruppe tätig oder sonst etwas. Nein, keineswegs. Erstmal sagt sie, wir leben im Grunde in einer Diktatur. Die Kölner Silvesternacht ist ihr großes Thema. Ja, dass da diese Übergriffe kamen durch Flüchtlinge. Die Flüchtlingskrise im Allgemeinen, das große Problem. Sie sagt, wenn du nichts hast, kriegst du alles, dann kriegst du eine Wohnung und alles. Und wenn du ein bisschen was gearbeitet hast, dann wird dir das auch noch weggenommen. Sie fühlt sich als Deutsche diskriminiert. Es macht sie wütend, dass Geflüchtete, Zitat, Kindergeld kriegen ohne Ende, in einer super Wohnung leben, die wir uns nicht leisten können. Ja, während wir uns den Arsch aufreißen, wie sie sagt, sie sagt auch, Moment, auf die Frage, ob man Asylbewerberinnen, wenn sie eine Straftat begehen, gleich wieder in ihr Heimatland schicken sollte, ganz gleich, ob sie dort um ihr Leben fürchten müssen, antwortet sie laut und sarkastisch lachend. Ja, absolut, absolut ja. Nächstes Flugzeug und weg. Die freuen sich schon in dem eigenen Land. Aber die AfD ist nicht ihr zentraler politischer Bezugspunkt. Nämlich der AfD ist der Umweltschutz nicht wichtig, aber das ist Emilia Gerber wichtig.
Ja, also es gibt Einflugschneisen für einen weiblichen Faschismus, wie wir da sehen. Sie kommen ja gegen Ende des Buches noch mal auf die Frauen zu sprechen mit zwei Sinssprüchen, die hier prägend sind. Wer schön sein will, muss leiden und schön ist, was weh tut. Also eine körperliche Zurichtung, nennen sie es hier, also dass man sich aufpräzelt, ist Befriedigung und Befreiung. Männer treten einfach so in ihrem Schlafanzug in die Welt und sagen, was kostet das hier? Frauen, bevor sie auf die Straße gehen, ich weiß nicht genau, warum sie von Zurichtung sprechen, aber sie richten sich noch zu, also sie geben da Mühe rein, Fleiß. Und dann sehen sie, also es hat so eine ästhetische Komponente. Die verlotterten Migranten, das Straßenbild scheint hier doch vielleicht Anklang zu finden, so eine Straßenbild- Argumentation.
Ja, absolut. Das ist, also die Leute, die wir hier treffen in diesem Buch, sagen alle, ja genau so ist es. Straßenbild ist das Wort für diese Leute. Also ich glaube, wenn man dieses Buch Chachipiti gibt und dann sagt, wie könnte ich diese frustrierten da mit ihren ganzen Ressentiments allgemein abstrakt ansprechen, dann würde wahrscheinlich Chachipiti sagen, Straßenbild, sag was zum Straßenbild.
Aber hier steckt eine Paarte drin, denn die Straßenbild-Diskussion wurde ja flankiert durch eine sind es nicht einfach Männer, warum wird über Migranten geredet. Jetzt steht hier folgendes. Rechte Frauen genießen die empfundene Überlegenheit vermutlich umso intensiver, als sie innerhalb der Hierarchie der dominanten Norm selbst eine unterlegene Stellung einnehmen. Also sind patriarchal zweitrangig. Im Rassismus können sie Rache üben und stellvertretend den migrantischen Mann dominieren.
Ja, es geht ja immer über die Männer.
Wow, ist das verdreht.
Ja, aber es ist, glaube ich, richtig gut analysiert.
Der Rassismus als Rache für die unterdrückte Frau. Ich finde es auch super plausibel, schon allein, weil sich es auf einen einfachen Satz bringen lässt, aber es ist ja, man liest das so und denkt sich wow, wow, wow. Sind wir medial einfach auf einem falschen Track, um hier Aufarbeitung zu machen? Die Ulf Poschards, Petro Masculine werden oben nochmal genannt. Das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob denn das meine ganzen schönen Büro. Ist das ein Kapitel für Ulf Poschard? Weil es wird ja wirklich eindeutig genau so beschrieben, wie Ulf Poschard sich verhält. Man steigt ins Auto. Das Auto ist Symbol der Verbrennergesellschaft, Massenproduktion und Massenkonsum, Wohlstand und Wirtschaftswachstum. Und dann tritt man nochmal genussvoll aufs Gaspedal, wie sie hier schreiben. Ja. Das ist Ulf Poschard.
Natürlich. Ja, hast du das mitbekommen bei WeltOnline? Also dieses Buch ist ja, ich glaube sogar auf Platz 1, der Sachbuchbestsellerliste, die von so einer Jury gekürt wird und diese diese Liste erscheint ja dann in mehreren Zeitungen und wird weithin rezipiert. Nun ist es so, dass ja normalerweise dann einfach jede Zeitung das so abdruckt mit der Jury und da gibt es ja auch eigentlich kein ja, gibt es ja keinen Kommentar, aber bei der Welt hat man wohl auch nochmal das extra nochmal jetzt kommentiert diese diese Liste. Also da war ein Journalist, der dann nochmal betont hat, dass das ja ein Buch ist, das den Libertären jeden Spaß verderben will oder so.
Ja, das ist er. Ja, was soll ich sagen? Das ist Ulf Poscha.
Das ist Ulf Poscha. Das finde ich so erstaunlich, dass man zugibt, dass da jemand auf den Schlips getreten hat.
Ja, sehr interessant ist, die nennen es hier Petromaskulinität. Petro kommt aber nicht vom Petroleum, beziehungsweise der Begriff Petroleum leitet sich vom lateinischen Petra für Fels oder großer Stein ab. Da also diese Härte. Ja, finde ich interessant. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie weit man es treiben sollte mit solchen begrifflichen Sachen. Aber das Petra, der Stein ist, finde ich sehr gut. Es werden tatsächlich alle genannt. Wir werden hier über Kurtis Jarwin informiert. Sprenglers Untergang des Abendlands, Ayn Rand, Atlas Shrugged, Slavoj Zizek, Friedrich August von Hayek und Ludwig von Mises und so weiter und fort. Kann man soweit sagen, okay, in der Stadt.
Da hätte ich gerne mehr O-Töne eigentlich gewesen.
Ich denke auch, diese Empirie kommt hier leider so kurz. Ich verstehe es gar nicht so richtig. Also, das müsste man sich auch mal fragen einfach. Also, ich schlummern ja Schätze drin, die einem wirklich aus Grund ihrer eigenen Wortkraft so plausibel sind.
Den bekommen wir ja so gar nicht. Also, wir können ja gar nicht mit dieser…
Ja, stattdessen schreiben sie einfach. Einige Personen wirkten gar, als seien sie aus einem Ein-Rent-Roman gefallen. Sie kämpfen in Deutschland gegen den vermeintlichen Sozialismus des grünliberalen Sozialstaats und den unternehmerischen Tatendrang, der besondere Fähigkeiten blockiere. Dann mach einfach ein Empiriebuch. Hau die Dinger ohne weitere Kontextualisierung mir einfach vor die Nase, damit ich weiß, okay, das gibt es anscheinend auch noch. Es ist nicht alles nur Infratestimap und so.
Jaja, jaja.
Aber mal sehen.
Das ist so erhellend. Springen wir doch zu demokratischer Faschismus noch. Also es geht jetzt nicht darum zu sagen, wir haben jetzt den Faschismus wieder, der ist wieder da. Aber wir sehen, wie der Faschismus.
Ich lasse dir gleich, ich habe ihn schonmal angesprochen, diesen Bioinformatiker, der mit seinen Bakterien und der Petrischale und so, ne?
Genau. Dazu wollte ich jetzt überleiten. Aber dann, also es gibt einen Fabian Leonhard, der studiert Biochemie und der kommt aus gutem Hause. Der Opa allerdings, väterlicherseits, der war kommunistisch unterwegs und den sieht er heute als Idiot an.
NK-Gruppenaktivist.
Er hat da eine ganz klare Sicht auf die Dinge. Er sagt, es ist ein essenzieller Teil der Menschheit, dass man Krieg führt.
Ja, er wird gefragt, was gibt ihr Hoffnung, wenn er sagt, dass wir Krieg führen?
Sein Nullsummen-Denken geht noch viel weiter, als nur über Budgets zu reden, sondern er redet gleich über die Menschen. Es sind zu viele auf der Welt, so kann das nicht weitergehen. Er sagt, es hat nur begrenzte Ressourcen auf der Erde und es werden immer mehr Menschen. Bakterien können nicht unendlich weit wachsen. Irgendwann ist die Petrischale voll. Das ist eine Situation, die muss auch auf der Welt für Menschen gelten. Irgendwann ist die Welt voll. Sie kann nicht mehr Leben unterhalten. Aber man macht weiter mit dem Konkurrenzdenken. Und das heißt, die Konkurrenz ist so stark, dass man in den Krieg zieht. Der Krieg soll dann dezimieren, damit dann wieder für die, die überlebt haben, die stark genug waren, es weitergehen kann. Jetzt könnte man denken, ist das so jemand, der zu emotionalen Ausbrüchen neigt? Keineswegs. Er ist ja Wissenschaftler. Da heißt es auch, er ist kein Hitzkopf. Er redet überlegt und kontrolliert. Rational heißt bei ihm effektiv, systematisch und langfristig gedacht, nicht ideologisch motiviert. Das ist ja auch etwas, was wir jetzt vielfach finden bei YouTube schon, dass man so aus einer wissenschaftspositivistischen Seite rechtsradikale Thesen hat, die dann aber nicht emotional vorgetragen werden. Das ist nicht das Weidel-Video, in dem gebrüllt wird, sondern in dem man sagt, also es ist ganz klar, nehmen wir mal eine Petrischale, da gehen so und so viele Bakterien rein. Genauso ist das doch mit den Menschen auch. Er sagt dann weiter, es hat 10 Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt und alle sollen im gleichen Lebensstandard leben. Die Rechnung geht halt nicht auf. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht so schwierig. Das heißt, am Ende muss, wie man es bei Bakterien der Biologie macht, damit das Wachstum stetig bleibt, muss ein Teil der Population ausgerottet werden. Und hier sind wir jetzt im faschistischen Denken par excellence angekommen. Fabian Leonhardt heißt es hier, ist mit seiner nekrophilen Neigung zugleich ein besonderer und ein exemplarischer Fall. Er sticht heraus, durch seine Obsession für den Krieg, von dem er gleichzeitig abgestoßen und angezogen wird. Seine apokalyptischen Visionen schildert er mit einer Lust am Untergang. Fabian Leonard ist, soweit wir wissen, kein aktiver Faschist, aber seine Aussagen weisen viele Affinitäten zu faschistischen Fantasien aus. Das war in unserer Untersuchung häufiger der Fall. Viele der Gesprächspartnerinnen hingen keiner manifesten faschistischen Ideologie an, aber immer wieder tauchten Bilder oder Erzählungen aus einem faschistischen Bezugsrahmen auf. Und das ist das Interessante jetzt, wo man auch sagen muss, da liegt die allergrößte Gefahr, dass also dieses jetzt noch nicht in ein Programm gegossen wird und das wird sich auch nicht als Kollektiv jetzt formieren. Die streiten nicht los und sagen, wir sind jetzt alle zusammen die Faschisten. Das machen so ein paar Jugendgruppen irgendwo im Osten. Das sind die ganz verzweifelten, auf die Ahrens so errabwürdigend jetzt neuerdings blickt. Aber was jetzt passieren könnte, ist eben, dass eine Partei mit entsprechenden Einzelführerfiguren kommt, die dieses faschistische Denken in die Tat umsetzt, das Ausrotten in die Tat umsetzt und die sagen, ja genau, das dockt ja an dem an, was ich immer so dachte. Und dann reicht diese lose Allianz, um diesen Faschismus zu unterstützen.
Im Grunde ist die Ankopplung hier, Krieg ist für ihn einfach nur die Konkurrenz ein bisschen weitergedreht. Konkurrenz ist ja allgegenwärtig. Und das kann man ja, falls jemand kommt und sagt, aber Krieg ist doch irgendwie was anderes als bloße Konkurrenz. Nee, das kann man ja dann über Ehrenkodex klären. Über die Führung von Kriegen hat er viel nachgedacht, diese sollten vor allem vernünftig ausgetragen werden, damit es eine Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung gibt. Also nicht foltern. Sein Beitrag zum Humanismus ist nicht foltern. Das ist wirklich schlimm, was wir hier lesen. Unglaublich. Man kann es sich nicht ganz vorstellen, aber diese Leute haben ja auch Freunde, mit denen sie so alltägliche Sachen besprechen.
Aber das hören wir doch in diesem Podcast schon. Also da sagen die schon, ja, aber Krieg ist doch auch Krieg. Und da bewährt man sich. Also ich will nur mal sagen, wir gehen jetzt ja schnell auf solche Extreme und sagen danach, ja, das gibt es in der Gesellschaft. Erst mal sagen sie ja, es gibt das doch noch nicht mehrheitlich, aber diese Strömungen sind stark. Aber denken wir zum Beispiel an jemanden, der sich als Demokrat versteht. Also wir fragen uns ja immer, wo ist denn der Faschismus in den Demokraten, der sich als Demokrat versteht und sicherlich jetzt nicht AfD-Anhänger ist, wie dieser Bulletproof, über den wir mal gesprochen haben, der bei Christian Lindner im Podcast war. Und der dann sagte, wie katastrophal der Afghanistan-Einsatz verlaufen ist und dass da dann ein Kamerad von ihm getötet wurde. Und dass er aber zugleich sagt, es war aber sinnvoll. Denn ein Heer, das nicht im Einsatz ist, das verstaubt irgendwann. Und die Mittel, die man hat zur Kriegsführung, die müssen ja auch geprüft werden. Und Waffen können optimiert werden durch einen Krieg. Also der hat natürlich auch dieses Denken drin. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass gerade jetzt mit Bezug auf den Krieg, dass niemand so aussprechen würde, wie er das jetzt hier tut, dieser Leonhard. Aber was wir schon erleben, ist ja, dass man so eine neue Härte haben möchte, dass gerade die Gen Z sich mal wieder an was gewöhnen soll. Und wir hatten, wir haben diese ganzen Boomer-Kommentare, wenn es um Wehrpflicht geht, diese ganzen Boomer-Kommentare, die uns sagen, na ja, wir waren ja auch damals beim Bund und ein bisschen Disziplin hat noch keinem geschadet. Also das ist schon erstaunlich, wie weit dieses Denken eigentlich schon in den Köpfen sitzt, wenn es dann auch noch nicht so überspitzt artikuliert wird.
Und jetzt haben wir hier ein ganz hervorragendes Textstück zum Thema. Offene Frage, ist Campino ein Faschist, weil er eine neue Härte in der Jugend einfordert? Und man kann ja auch mal was für seinen Staat tun und so, ne? Und dann könnte man natürlich jetzt auch nie der Faschismusbegriff und so weiter und fort. Hier wird ein ganz eleganter Ausweg gemacht für uns alle mit sehr hoher Relevanz für unseren Alltag. Denn die Definismusdefinition, die hier vorgestellt wird, nimmt erst mal Abstand von überhaupt der Idee einer Definition im Sinne von politisches Modell. Denn sie sagen, Faschismus ist vor allem Praxis. Was bedeutet, die Demokratie sieht sehr lange wie eine Demokratie aus, während sie in der Praxis schon auf Faschismus umgestellt hat. Also all das, was Stephen Miller da macht, findet im Rahmen der amerikanischen Demokratie statt. Das, was, wie heißt unser Innenminister nochmal?
Dobrindt?
Dobrindt. Alles, was Alexander Dobrindt macht, kann man unter der Prüfung laufen lassen, was ist hier von faschistisch und was nicht. Und nachdem, wie wir hier bisher eine Ideologie von, nee, nicht mehr in Bedarfen, sondern in Budgets denken, den Nationalstaat sakral überhöhen, Klassenstolz komplett rausstreichen, nur noch individueller Fleiß und so. Und wir haben dann eine Migrationspolitik, die einfach sagt, also wir schützen die Grenze, komme was wolle, uns sind höhere politische Ideale egal. Es geht jetzt darum, jeder Einzelne zurückgewiesen ist ein Erfolg, und sei es 80 Millionen, dann ist das faschistische Praxis im Rahmen der Demokratie.
Ja, heute früh die Nachricht, ein Gerücht, ich glaube in NRW, hat entschieden, dass ein 46-jähriger syrischer Koch mit seinem 26-jährigen Sohn nach Syrien abgeschoben werden darf. Es besteht keine Lebensgefahr.
Ja. So, keine Lebensgefahr ist nicht das Kriterium der Demokraten, sondern das ist ein faschistisches Maß.
Da gibt es jetzt hier manche im Buch, die werden noch sagen, auch schade, dass es keine Lebensgefahr gibt. Die gibt es dann hier auch noch, ja. Die so ganz zerstörungswürdig sind. Aber im Prinzip sind wir genau in diesem faschistischen Diskurs.
Genau. Also wir haben faschistische Praxis, die wir sehen. Und damit erübrigt sich jegliche Faschismusdefinition. Denn dieses eine Leben, dieser eine Staat, diese eine Zeit, in der das alles stattfindet, worüber kommt mir natürlich sehr entgegen, nachdem ich jetzt mehrfach dafür plädiert habe, warum diskutieren. Entweder man hat eine Praxis, die so und so ist oder nicht. Also das Diskurs darüber ist ja so müßig. Und von daher gilt einfach, so wie Donald Trump auf der Bühne steht und einfach sagt, Kamala Harris, Marxist, Kommunist, Hamas, irgendwas, keine Ahnung, die Leute, die auf die Straße gehen, sind alles Amerika-Zerstörer. Genauso pauschal kann man auch einfach über Faschismus drüber gehen und sagen, also, wenn jemand abgeschoben wird und die Botschaft lautet, Folter könnte schon drehen, aber Lebensgefahr nicht, dann ist das ganz klare faschistische Praxis, allein weil es keine demokratische ist.
Ja. Punkt.
So, keine weitere Überhöhung nötig, kein weiterer Diskurs vonnötig.
Aber sag mal, das wollte ich doch mal wissen. Es heißt hier zum Beispiel, so das Mittel der Häme und des Lachens häufig zu finden, ist bei diesen rechten Politikern, wie aber auch bei ihren Unterstützern, also bei den Destruktionslüsternen. Da heißt es, in ziviler Form schlägt sich das destruktive Lachen in Clown-Emojis oder Tränen-Lachenden-Smilies nieder, mit denen das Gegenüber in sozialen Medien-Interaktionen lächerlich gemacht wird. Historisch betrachtet war der plebeische Spott immer auch ein Mittel der Beherrschten, um sich über die Herrschenden zu erheben. Heute rebelliert man mit bösen Witzen gegen die Herrschaft liberaler Eliten. Geht man nicht, also ich kenne das Phänomen, aber geht man nicht auch ein bisschen weit, wenn man jetzt laufend mit diesem Faschismusbegriff hier operiert. Denn diese Clown-Emojis und die Tränen lachenden Smilies sind da auch bei ganz vielen Sachen angebracht.
Also dieser Clown-Emoji oder auch der Frosch oder was auch immer, das sind ja mittlerweile alles schon ikonografisch aufgeladene Erkennungszeichen.
Der Frosch ist was anderes, aber der Clown auch.
Der Clown ist nicht einfach nur ein Clown.
Aber das Tränen lachende Emoji ist jetzt nicht...
Tränen lachende Emoji verwenden wir so viel, auch in anderen Connections. Also ein Frosch und ein Clown kommt ja typischerweise nicht unter. Ein Tränen lachendes Emoji die ganze Zeit. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass die Leute, die das so verwenden, damit auch einfach nur ein Witz markieren wollen, sondern das sind dann auch schon Erkennungszeichen.
Naja, aber wenn ich jetzt ein Clown-Emoji verwende, wenn Marie-Agnestrak Zimmermann wieder was gesagt hat...
Ja. Dann? Ich glaube, wir kommen nachher darauf zu sprechen. Das ist in Amerika, läuft sowas jetzt unter Antifa und dann läuft einfach die ganze Maschinerie bei solchen kleinen Sachen.
Genau das meine ich ja. Aber wenn ich jetzt hier höre, das wird jetzt rechts geframed, die Nutzung von Clown-Emojis, wird ja hier von Amlinger und Nachtwey rechts geframed, dann frage ich mich, ob ich nicht am Ende doch an den Punkt dann gelang, in dem ich sage, ja, da muss ich den Status quo einfach immer nur feiern oder gar nichts Kritisches dazu sagen.
Du kommst hier natürlich als Leser, dem dieses Free Speech Thema sehr wichtig ist, an Textstellen, bei denen ich jetzt sage, sorry, in diesen Diskurs kann ich nicht einsteigen, denn ich sehe es erstens grundsätzlich in der Dramaturgie einfach anders. Also nur weil jemand sagt Antisemit, ja, stelle ich nicht jede Diskussion ein und sage, okay, dann ist das jetzt der Fokus. Und genauso wenig gilt das für Lach-Emojis. Du hast jetzt einen Textteil so gelesen, von dem ich sage, ja, das ist schon klar, dass Wolfgang ihn so gelesen hat, nur ich lese ihn nicht so. Und ich lasse mich auch nicht in die Dramaturgie reindrängen.
Nein, es gibt ja keine Dramaturgie. Es geht ja hier nur darum, du fragst ja gerade, ob du dich so der Dicht machst. Es wird gesagt, dass destruktive Lachen äußert sich in Form von lachenden Smilies im Internet. Und ich frage mich, ob wir jetzt an den Punkt gehen sollten, sollten wir die Schlussfolgerung ziehen, dass wir sagen, ah ja, das ist aber, gehört sich aber nicht für aufrechte Demokraten, Lachen des Smilies zu verwenden, wenn Ursula von der Leyen den neuen Rüstungsdeal verkündet. Oder kann ich sagen, nee, das ist auch noch statthaft, das weiterhin zu machen, ohne in den Fraschismus zu verfallen.
Ich finde Robert Habecks Versuch, damals zu sagen, wir eignen uns die Nationalflagge wieder an. Also nicht nur lachendes Smiley oder so, wo noch Diskussionen sind, sondern schwarz-rot-gold sind aber jetzt unsere Farben. Da dachte ich so, genau. Also wenn du jetzt einen Kampf führen willst, um dir das Lache-Emoji wieder zurück erobern, damit es nicht in so ein hegemoniales, rechtes Framing reinfällt und es sozusagen für uns nicht mehr verwendbar ist, würde ich sagen, ja genau, man macht das.
Aber diese Gefahr sehe ich, ja genau, aber diese Gefahr sehe ich ja, denn ich, also wir haben das ja sehr häufig gehabt, auch im Zuge der Corona-Pandemie oder jetzt bei dem Krieg, wenn man auf etwas hinweist, was jetzt gerade dem Cursor-Journalismus, um diese Wälzer-Precht-Formulierung zu gebrauchen, nicht besonders lieb ist, dann heißt es, ah ja, das sind die Corona-Leugner, das sind die Putin-Versteher und und und. Und deshalb glaube ich, muss man eben jetzt mit diesem Faschismusbegriff insofern vorsichtig umgehen, als man sonst an einen Punkt gerät, neben jeder Idee einer Kritik, die sich auch lächerlich macht, zum Beispiel überherrschende Eliten, die es ja zweifelsohne gibt, dass diese dann gleich als faschistisch dargestellt wird. Weil sonst kann ich auch irgendwann sagen, naja, also dieser Anti-Establishment-Wahlkampf von Zoran Mamdani hat eine faschistische Note und das wollen wir jetzt noch nicht mittragen.
Also wir haben es ja hier mit einem soziologischen Lehrbuch zu tun, finde ich schon, Lehrbuch, das natürlich nicht jenseits der Welt stattfindet, sondern in der Welt. Also das Thema des Buches lautet Demokratischer Faschismus und es möchte konkret auf diese Entwicklung, die es beschreibt, einwirken. Was bedeutet, wenn du so ein Lesegefühl hast, also dass du da Widerspruchserfahrung machst einfach und sagst, ja hier sollten wir den Faschismusbegriff schon bei Emojis, weil dann kann ich ja mein Emoji nicht mehr setzen, ist das auf jeden Fall super legitim, aber ich würde trotzdem sagen, für unser Gespräch jetzt im Salon gehen wir diese eine Abstraktionsebene wieder hoch, auf diese meta-soziologische Beobachtung und sagen, diese Textstücke, die sogar dich in Wallung bringen, sind super wichtig, weil sie alle in Wallung bringen. Richard David Brecht schreibt ganze Bücher darüber, was ihn stört, wo er sich in Gefühlen verletzt sieht, wo er findet, dass falsche Generationszuschnitte gemacht werden und so weiter und so fort. Und hier würde ich einfach sagen, so wie wir bisher auf das Buch und die Inhalte verwiesen haben im Sinne von, das ist super interessant, das ist super relevant, hier muss man nochmal nachgehen, das sollen jetzt die Journalistenwesen, also wir haben die ganze Zeit so verteilt, möchte ich auch hier sagen, dass sie diese Thematisierung des Humors machen, ist erstens folgerichtig, denn sie haben über Scham, über Stolz und über andere Gefühle geredet und die Zerstörungslust und die Lust ist ein Gefühl, also muss man auch über Humor schreiben. Und hier ist ganz wichtig, sie bieten ja an, das zu beobachten als mythologische Maschinen, Ideen ohne Worte. Wir haben ein Buch, das sich mit politischen Diskursverhalten verständigt. Diese Leute werden nach ihrer Meinung gefragt, die sie gerne in einen politischen Diskurs reinbringen. Und wir hören das und denken uns, scheiße, so wollen die im politischen Diskurs reden, das geht nicht. Ja, und so sehr, wie wir jetzt gelobt haben und sagen, wir würden gerne noch mehr Originalworte von denen hören, noch mehr Empirie, was habt ihr daraus gehört. Genauso wichtig ist es auch über diese Ideen ohne Worte, weil das jetzt so prägend ist, dass so viele politische und Diskurse kann man gar nicht sagen, über Memes ablaufen, über Bilder und so weiter, die man eben nicht so vage bleibt.
Das zu beobachten ist alles richtig. Ich frage mich nur, welche Schlussfolgerungen werden bisweilen aus solchen Beobachtungen gezogen? Und sollte man jetzt am Ende auch im Brustton der Überzeugung und mit der Tonalität eines Bundespräsidenten anmahnen, dass Clown Emojis verwendet werden? Oder sollte man, wenn man zum Beispiel die nächste Veranstaltung zum Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchrandes sieht, sich nicht sagen, da könnte man mal ein paar Clown Emojis posten, denn das ist die treffende Beschreibung für die Veranstaltung.
Ja, und die beiden weisen ja darauf hin, dass wenn jemand aus Schwarzkopf Schwachkopf macht, schon die Polizei ausrückt, dass das längst schon Realität ist. Also sozusagen nicht künftig, sondern das, was du jetzt zu Recht kritisch anmerkst, ist ja längst politische Realität, die dieses Buch versucht zu schreiben.
Ja, aber das Buch-Position würde sich ja jetzt problematisiert, ja eher die aus Schwarzkopf Schlachkopf machen. Das Buch problematisiert ja nicht.
Da müssen wir jetzt nochmal genau in den Text reingehen. Ich vermute, es kann durchaus Ausrutscher in 500 Seitenstangen Büchern geben.
Nein, ich will auch gar nicht, es geht mir nicht um diese Einstellung. Ich will nur fragen, also bei aller Systemkritik, die geäußert wird, habe ich mitunter den Verdacht, dass es zumindest so rezipiert werden könnte, dass es ein Aufruf zum Maß und Mäßigung und zu einer doch am Ende bundespräsidial abgesicherten Mainstream-Haltung ist, bei der ich sagen würde, nein, ich glaube, jetzt ist es gerade richtig, mal ordentlich drauf zu hauen. Also Zerstörungswut, aber in progressiver Weise.
Ich habe hier nun meine Notizen vor Augen, in denen kommt das Lach-Emoji nicht vor. Wir könnten jetzt nochmal in den richtigen Text gehen, aber ich möchte anmerken, wir waren schwer beeindruckt von einer britischen oder wo auch immer Fernsehserie Adolescence, in der, also die auch davon handelt, dass Menschen eine Kommunikationsrealität, die sie vorher nicht kannten, in ihre Triftigkeit lernen, weil jemand gestorben ist aufgrund von farblichen Herz-Emojis. Also das Thema ist schon wichtig.
Ja, das sage ich doch, das will ich ja gar nicht leugnen.
Und dass sie es aufgreifen, ist richtig.
Mir geht es auch gar nicht um die Emojis an sich, sondern ich will doch nur sagen...
Falls du hier in einem Halbton rausgehört hast, eine Agitation gegen dein eigenes Verhalten.
Nein, mir ist eh alles. Ich muss mich ja da gar nicht gesondert rechtfertigen oder so. Dass ich da sicherlich, sagen wir, mit mehr Hemdsämlichkeit unterwegs bin, als das in Surkamp-Buch gestattet, das ist ja völlig klar so. Und dass ich diese ganzen Diskurse von unseren Aufrüstungspolitikern für im höchsten Maße schwachsinnig und klauenhaft halte, ist auch schon hundertmal gesagt. Mir geht es jetzt nur darum, wollen wir jetzt so eine Stilkritik übergeben, bei der wir sagen, da müssen wir uns irgendwie als die aufrechten Anständigen, oder um es ganz zugespielt zu sagen, ist die Schlussfolgerung naheliegend, dass wir uns in Carolin Imke verwandeln sollten? Oder ist diese Schlussfolgerung nicht naheliegend? Ich würde sagen, bei ganz vielen, bei dem größten Teil des Buches sehe ich, dass aufgrund dieser Systemkritik, die geübt wird und die auch eingefordert wird, nochmal ganz zum Schluss, du hast die Pointe ja schon vorweggenommen, ist es nicht so, dass ich aber doch mitunter glaube, dass das sehr stark so rezipiert werden könnte, dass man sagt, ach ja, das sind alles so welche, die was zerstören wollen, wir wollen ja ganz konstruktiv sein. Und diesem Konstruktiven, glaube ich, sollte man sich auch widersetzen können, weil dieses Konstruktive, das immer eingefordert wird, also konstruktive Kritik, eigentlich oft auch meine Abtötung von Kritik und meine Einpassung ins System.
Ja.
Und sowas macht zum Beispiel in Soran Mamdani bislang zumindest noch nicht.
Ja, wir haben ja, also es ist ja wie gesagt Soziologie, so wie Adolescence ja auch sehr gute Soziologie ist einfach. Also sie versuchen ja wirklich empirisch zu zeigen, was Sache ist. Klar, Fernseh schon so, aber ich meine, die Leute fallen bei der Babo-Story drauf rein. Also im Vergleich dazu ist ja Adolescence wirklich eine soziologische Aufklärung über den Sachverhalt. Was noch lange nicht bedeutet, dass wenn Boomer jetzt sehen, wie da eine Aufklärung über Emojis stattfindet, dass sie dann für sich sagen sollten, ach so, jetzt kann ich dir kein lila Herzchen mehr schreiben, weil dann denkst du, ich will was von dir, aber nur sexuell und so weiter. Und dann sieht das ein Polizist und denkt, oh shit, ich hab dich zurückgewiesen. Sondern nein, das ist natürlich eine andere Realität. Also das, was hier in dem Buch, das ist jetzt eine Wette, ich sag's jetzt hier öffentlich, ich weiß ja nicht, was im Text drin steht, ja. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass was in dem Buch über das Lach-Emoji und seine Bedeutungsvielfalt, der Variantenreichtum, wie man es kontextualisieren kann, drinsteht. Betrifft uns, die wir mal in Blue Sky Text schreiben, mit einem Lach-Emoji oder eine WhatsApp-Film, nicht.
Ja, bei Blue Sky bin ich auch gar nicht.
Weil wir sind einfach nicht die Zerstörungslustigen. Und falls demnächst mal ein Polizeieinsatz stattfindet, weil ein Staatsanwalt sagt, doch, doch, doch, das gilt auch für dich, was wir als Wissenstransfer-Erkenntnis von der Cripo Berlin über Emojis gelernt haben, dann sagen wir, nein, nein, nein, liebe Polizei, ihr liegt da ganz falsch. Ich habe einfach nur ein Lach-Emoji verwendet. Und das ist ja der große Diskurs, der gerade stattfindet, dass, weil irgendwo mal ein Polizeieinsatz von irgendeinem faschistischen irgendwas er hatte eine Dienstanweisung gegeben. Also das ist ja wirklich jemand in der Praxis einfach komplett über die Stränge geschlagen. Und das heißt aber deswegen noch lange nicht, dass jetzt Feuer frei ist. Sondern wir weisen einfach darauf hin, in diesem Buch gibt es sehr gute Aufklärung über mitrothologische Maschinen, also Ideen ohne Worte, wie funktioniert dieser neue politische Diskurs. Der ja, und das kann man ja auch mal sagen, super inklusiv ist. Denn hier werden ja Leute mit Politik beschäftigt, von denen wir früher mal gesagt hätten, wow, wir hätten gerne mal weniger Nichtwähler, dass sich mehr Leute für Politik interessieren. Und Max Winder hat damals den mittlerweile weltberühmten Tweet gemacht, ihr werdet euch noch wünschen, wir wären politikverdrossen. Und das ist eben die Realität. Die Leute sind halt nicht mehr politikverdrossen, sondern die sagen jetzt, was ist mit meiner Petrischale? Was machen diese komischen Bakterien hier?
Ja, da ist zum Beispiel Christina Subota, 48 Jahre alt, Data-Analystin. Sie ist im polnischen Schlesing geboren, kam mit zwei Jahren nach Deutschland. Sie war mit einem Muslim verheiratet, hat auch einen Sohn mit ihm. Aber muslimische Männer empfinden sie als Bedrohung. Sie sagt, diese unkontrollierte Zuwanderung hat dafür gesorgt, dass wir nicht mehr sicher leben können, so wie früher. Immer wieder kommt sie dann in dem Gespräch auf die bewaffneten Muslime zu sprechen. Mit Messern seien sie ausgestattet. Und sie hat dann so eine Aggression, die dann auch daran mündet, dass sie so Deportations-Fantasien äußert. Das ist so erstaunlich, ne, weil man jetzt hier sagen würde, naja, also wenn jemand doch nicht migrationsfeindlich ist, dann doch wohl sie. Sie war ja auch verheiratet mit einem Muslim. Also damit gehört sie ja schon noch gar nicht zur deutschen Mehrheitsgesellschaft quasi, weil die meisten nicht mit einem Muslim verheiratet sind, die meisten. Aber doch, sie war das und trotzdem ist das so. Sie hatten mit ihm auch ein gemeinsames Kind, aber trotzdem ist sie so. Sie bringen ja dann noch dieses Bild von Christy Noem, der Politikerin der Homeland Security. Ich habe das hier mal ausgedruckt. Also da sieht man Trumps Ministerin, wie sie dort steht. Im Hintergrund Gitterstäbe, dort sind nur mit Unterhosen bekleidet. Sind dort Migranten straffällig geworden, die jetzt in diesem Gefängnis sind. Und sie steht mit einem weißen, engem Shirt, mit langen, dunklen Haaren und einer Basecap davor und hält dann so eine Rede, dass sie jetzt die Gesellschaft schützt.
Und es nützt gar nichts, aber wir müssen dazusagen, jeden Tag drei Stunden Fitnessstudio.
Ja, genau, das kann man hier dazusagen. Sie sprechen ja also Amlinger und Nachtwey von der militarisierten Hausfrau.
Ja, was heißt das nun?
Bedeutet also, diese, diese leistungsorientierten Frauen, die hart gegen sich selbst und andere sind und die dann mit diesem Threatwive-Image auftreten, können also zweierlei tun. Sie können einflussreich sein. Sie können in Sphären vordringen, die sonst vor allem Männern vorbehalten waren. Sie können Rache an den Männern nehmen, in denen sie Migranten, wie jetzt in diesem Falle, schlecht behandeln. Und sie können aber zugleich das Weiblichkeitsbild, das männlich erschaffen wurde, von eben der Threatwive, von der Frau, die Sport macht und diese langen Haare hat und die ganze Zeit ihr äußeres Penibels beachtet. Das können sie alles zusammenbringen.
Ja. Ich möchte einen Blick in die Zukunft fangen, jetzt wo du dieses Bild gezeigt hast. Wir haben, also dass das möglich ist, dass die Homeland Security Ministerin zuständig für diese ganzen Al-Qadras, Gefängnisse von Eis und so, jetzt einfach so dasteht, dass sie also nicht aussieht wie Marke Thetscher, sondern als wäre sie direkt aus dem Autokatalog gefallen.
Ja.
Das ist eine emanzipatorische Erfolgsgeschichte der letzten, sagen wir mal, 20, höchstens 30 Jahre. Also vor 1995 war das undenkbar. Dann mussten sich Frauen erst bewähren, dass sie also schön und auch noch was anderes sein können, nicht nur schön. Und jetzt können sie irgendwie so beides sein. Okay, Christian Noms ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das Beispiel dafür, aber rein praktisch gesehen ist sie jetzt die Ministerin. Da steht das, oder? Wenn wir jetzt 30 Jahre in die Zukunft gucken, gilt das, was für die vergangenen 30 Jahre für Frauen gilt, in Deutschland für Migranten. Und da führt gar kein Weg dran vorbei. Wir werden niemals 15 bis 20 Millionen remigrieren. Also das findet einfach gar nicht statt. Was bedeutet, diese Leute sind hier und so hart unser Rassismus ist und wir denen irgendwie Wohnung verweigern oder sonstiges, diese Leute werden ihren Erfolg einfach machen. Also die werden sozusagen in diesen Spitzen ankommen. Die werden Behörden leiten, die werden Polizei führen, wie auch immer. Also in Frankfurt kann man schon nicht mehr durch die Stadt gehen und ausschließlich deutsche, also deutsch aussehende Polizisten sehen. Man sieht einfach, dass die Hälfte der Polizei mittlerweile auch migrantischen.
Aber die können ja trotzdem zum Beispiel dann die AfD unterstützen.
Ja genau. Also damit hat das gar nichts zu tun. Die Migranten können hier in Deutschland ein Innenministerium einführen, bei dem sie einfach alle Syrer an der Grenze erschießen. Also wir kennen also Türken, Kurden, Syrer und so weiter. Ich meine, das ist vielleicht sogar noch wahrscheinlicher, als wenn wir einfach nur deutsche, was weiß ich, so Gefühlsrassisten da wie Dobrindt an der Spitze haben. Also das rettet uns zwar gar nichts.
Ja genau.
Sondern es ist einfach nur die Sehgewohnheit.
Und das ist auch der fundamentale Unterschied zu dem damaligen Faschismus, der auf einer Homogenität sehr stark aus war, weil sie auch einfach herzustellen war, weil der Migrationsanteil gering war und die Nazis sich vor allem auf die Juden dann kapriziert haben, um dann so zu versuchen, eine Reinheit herzustellen, während jetzt diese Idee der Homogenität nicht mehr verfolgt wird. Weder in der Trump-Administration noch bei Meloni, noch würde das hier mit der AfD geschehen.
Deswegen war ich auch gerade verwundert, dass du wieder sagst, ja, aber das können ja dann auch Rassisten sein. Ich so, ja klar, also war in meinem Denken schon längst eingepreist, dass das natürlich auch Rassist sein kann.
Weil du hast ja in unserem letzten Podcast so sehr immer über die alten weißen Männer gesprochen. Diese natürlichen Phänomene. Aber wir haben jetzt hier durch dieses Buch ja nochmal sehr deutlich gelernt, ja, die gibt es. Und die äußern sich auch so, wie du das uns schon vorgeführt hast. Aber es gibt eben noch sehr viele andere, die entscheidend mit dazu beitragen könnten, dass diese faschistischen Kräfte in Deutschland stärker werden.
Dieses Buch sagt uns zwei Sachen, die ganz wichtig sind. Erstens, Faschismus ist einfach Praxis. Das ist keine Idee, die man mal auslebt. Oder irgendein Bücherwissen, das man studieren muss oder so. Das ist reine Praxis. Und diese Praxis beruht auf unaufgearbeiteten und versteckten ökonomischen Asymmetrien. Wer ist diesen unterworfen? Alle sind diesen unterworfen. Von daher, es ist völlig egal, wo man geboren wurde, welchen Lebensweg man macht und wie man heißt. Die Gefahr, in eine faschistische Praxis abzurutschen, ist genauso leicht, wie die Gefahr, in diesen liberalen Paternalismus reinzudriften, sobald man in der Rolle angekommen ist, in der man sich dann mal wohlfühlen zurücklehnen kann, weil ab jetzt bin ich die Leistungsrolle. Alle Eltern, die vor mir sitzen, wollen von mir, dass ich gute Zeugnisse schreibe. Ich muss hier gar nichts mehr tun. Ich kann die Eltern einfach abtropfen lassen. Also diese Arroganz, die wir vorhin so beschrieben haben. Was bedeutet, im Finale dieses Buches geht es, da das ja das Buch ist, das das jetzt für uns durchschaut hat, um diese ökonomische Argumentation.
Ja.
Mit der besonderen Pointe, sie ist nicht neu. Das ist natürlich, kann man immer dazu sagen, aber sie ist nicht neu. Also in dem Falle beziehen sie sich auf Erich Fromm. Ich lese jetzt ein Zitat vor, dass sie auf Erich Fromm entliehen haben. Wir können jetzt selber überlegen, wie sehr sie sich das aneignen, zu eigen machen, dass sie Erich Fromm auch eine Überbande, weil der Satz vorher lautet, und damit war er nicht weit von der Position Erich Fromm entfernt. Und ich sage jetzt, sorry, liebe Soziologen, wer er jetzt nochmal war, ein Satz vorher ist auch egal, dass Erich Fromm das gesagt hat, ist auch egal. Der Satz ist einfach wahr. Man muss sich jetzt nicht unter drei Name-Droppings dahinter verstecken und das siebenmal über Bande spielen, sondern der Satz lautet, um schließlich den Gruppen-Nazismus zu reduzieren, müssten das Elend, die Monotonie, die Langeweile und die Machtlosigkeit, die in weiten Sektoren der Bevölkerung vorhanden sind, beseitigt werden. Das kann aber nicht einfach dadurch geschehen, dass man die materiellen Bedingungen bessert. Es kann nur das Resultat drastischer Veränderung in der sozialen Organisation sein, von einer Kontrolle-Eigentum-Macht-Orientierung zu einer Wachstum-Leben-Orientierung. Wir haben uns also hier verlaufen in einer Mein-Eigentum-Titel ist das Handlungsvermögen meiner Welt. Das verteidige ich gegen alle Widerstände, die kommen und jeder, der einen Widerstand aufbaut, ist ein Lebensblockierer, den ich einfach mit dem Feuerzeug beseitige. Kommen wir hier zu dieser großen Frage und sie immunisieren sich natürlich mit, wir sind ja nur die Soziologen und so, aber wo ist diese konstruktive Wende? Wachstum und Leben. Wir haben jetzt Angebote gehabt. Mandani, Volksgesetzgebung in Berlin. Es ist ja nicht unmöglich. Nur wer verhindert es denn, dass wir so darüber diskutieren? Wer stachelt uns denn die ganze Zeit an in diese kleine Eigentumslogik? Wer erklärt uns denn, ich als Reichtermann der Welt habe mit euch alles gemeinsam, denn wir haben dieselbe Eigentumstitel-Logik, die wir als Fundament unserer Leben verwenden?
Es sind zum einen die, es sind zum anderen, also die angesprochenen schon von dir, Elon Musk, seine Anhänger, all die Interviewten für das Buch. Und zum anderen sind es die Liberalen, die jetzt glauben, wir müssen nur noch sieben mal ausrufen, wie großartig unsere liberale Demokratie ist, und dann wird es schon was werden. Deswegen hier meine letzten Worte zum Buch sind nicht meine, sondern ich lese Amlinger Nachtwey noch mal im Original vor. Wir brauchen dringend einen neuen Antifaschismus, der die Ursachen der Destruktivität in modernen Gesellschaften adressiert. Der liberale Antifaschismus hat sich als hilflos erwiesen, da er als Antwort nur mehr Liberalismus kennt. Doch der Liberalismus steckt als Basisideologie westlicher kapitalistischer Gesellschaften in seiner vielleicht tiefsten Krise. Während seines langen Siegeszugs wurde er überheblich. Liberal ist denn nur noch gegenüber Liberalen, gegenüber nicht-Liberalen Denken und Lebensweisen verhält er sich zunehmend illiberal. Das heißt, Liberalismus-Kritik ist ganz entscheidend jetzt. Deshalb, auch wenn es da am Ende steht, eigentlich muss man es auch nochmal direkt am Anfang des Buches setzen, die letzten zehn Seiten, damit da nicht unter Journalisten Missverständnis entsteht. Das hier ist nicht ein Buch, das nochmal sagt, wie machen wir die nächste Feierlichkeit in der Paulskirche. Darum geht es hier nicht. Wenn man das gerne so haben möchte, kann man andere dazu interviewen. Diese Sätze muss man sich einschreiben und muss man sich auch selbst mit diesen Sätzen konfrontieren.
Ich will auch nochmal zwei vorlesen, die vor allem, wo wir jetzt vergleichen können, wie sehr das in Amerika schon funktioniert, bei uns aber noch nicht. Ein weiteres Problem, bei dem aus unserer Sicht akuter Handlungsbedarf besteht, akut bedeutet jetzt sofort, ist der Umstand, dass ökonomische Reichtum sich heute allzu oft in politische Macht übersetzt. Dieser Umstand wurde von Mandami usw. adressiert und er war in Amerika sehr erfolgreich. Und jetzt zur Frage, welches Programm sollte Mandami fahren und welches Programm brauchen wir hier auch? Während der gegenwärtige Faschismus den Markt entfesseln will, sollte ein postliberaler Antifaschismus für das Gegenteil kämpfen, jetzt gehen sie für Soziologen, die einfach nur so ein Buch schreiben, sehr weit, eine demokratisch eingebettete und zum Teil geplante Ökonomie, schreiben sie, und eine Gesellschaft, die sich ehrlich, das ist der Hinweis für die Journalisten, ehrlich mit den Herausforderungen auseinandersetzt. Und als oberste Herausforderung nennen sie Ungleichheit und das verbreitete Gefühl mangelnder Teilhabe. Also näher dran kann man gar nicht sein, dass diese Journalisten das Buch nicht aufschlagen werden, sondern nur den Buchdeckel lesen. Wir können ihnen sagen, einfach die letzten zwei Seiten lesen. Das heißt, einfach hinten das Fazit und dann mal überlegen.
Und dann den Rest.
Und dann natürlich den ganzen Rest.
Das heißt, wir empfehlen das Buch.
Oh, das empfehlen wir, aber hallo. Und wir empfehlen natürlich gleich das anschließende Soziologiestudium, das zwingend folgt, wenn man dieses Buch gut findet.
Junge Männer, die sich den Krieg wünschen, Frauen, die Deportationsfantasien haben, Menschen, die die Welt anzünden wollen, die eine, so der Titel, Zerstörungslust haben. Zerstörungslust heißt das neue Buch von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Es geht um die Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus. Es ist ein Buch, das empirisch ungeheuer stark ist, das mitten rein geht in unsere großen Debatten und dabei nicht sagt, ja, wir müssen einfach nur noch mal die liberale Demokratie beschwören, sondern wir müssen die liberale Demokratie auch als ein Problem ausmachen.
Ja, die Leute sagen immer, die Haftbefehl, Dokus, krass, alter, lest mal das Buch Zerstörungslust von den beiden. Unglaublich. Also man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Es ist eine nahezu perfekte Einladung, sich mit Soziologie zu beschäftigen, dieses Buch zu lesen und danach vielleicht auch Soziologie zu studieren. Also ich komme aus der Bewunderung für dieses Buch nicht heraus.
Wir haben jedenfalls dieses Buch als Grundlage genutzt, um darüber jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden intensiv zu diskutieren. Haben ein bisschen Zerstörungslust auch bei uns selbst entdeckt, aber in anderer Weise. Das alles kann man nachhören, wenn man den Salon abonniert. Das ist möglich über Patreon, Apple, vor allem aber empfehlen wir Steady. Wir kommen zum Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht. Im September ist in der FAZ ein Artikel erschienen von Prof. Dr. Eckhard Jessen und Prof. Dr. Uwe Waagschal aus der Politikwissenschaft. Überschrieben ist dieser Artikel mit Der Wahlkrimi ist noch nicht aus. Dann ist im Oktober ein Artikel erschienen von Mark Röhlig vom Spiegel. Als Spiegeleitartikel mit dem Titel Wagenknecht hat Recht. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal zu diesem FAZ-Artikel. Wir wissen, dem BSW fehlen 9500 Stimmen. Dann wären sie in den Bundestag gekommen. Das sind 0,019 Prozentpunkte, die fehlen.
Das ist schon dramatisch.
Das ist dramatisch. Aber es gibt ja Fabio De Masi und einige andere aus dem BSW, die immer wieder gesagt haben, man müsste eigentlich nachzählen, da ist etwas schiefgegangen. Jetzt ist es so, dass die Autoren Jesse und Waagschall schreiben für das BSW, wenige Monoten.
Warte mal, Fabio De Masi ist Teil des BSW?
Oder was?
Ach so, Fabio De Masi, sorry, das habe ich gerade verwechselt mit unserem ehemaligen Verfassungsrichter. Wir können nochmal neu machen. Das können wir ruhig drin lassen, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Ach so, tun wir jetzt den Udo.
Udo De Fabio, sorry. Nee, Fabio De Masi ist natürlich, ja. Ja, Fabio De Masi ist da drin.
Also, die Autoren schreiben für das BSW, wenige Monate zuvor bei der Europawahl aufgestiegen und bei den drei Landtagswahlen im September als jeweils dritte Kraft etabliert, blieb der denkbar knappe Ausgang ein politischer wie juristischer Zankapfel. Gemäß der Bekanntgabe des vorläufigen Ergebnisses durch die Bundeswahlleiterin in der Wahlnacht verpasste das BSW mit 13.435 Stimmen den Parlamenseinzug. Dann, am 11. März, reichte die Partei angesichts von Ungereimtheiten Organklage beim Bundesverfassungsgericht ein, mit dem Ziel einer bundesweiten Neuauszählung. Doch das Bundesverfassungsgericht wies am 13. März auf das zweistufige Verfahren hin. Die Wahlprüfung sei gemäß Artikel 41 Grundgesetz Sache des Bundestages. Erst wenn dessen Wahlprüfungsausschuss den Einspruch verwirft, kann die Partei das Bundesverfassungsgericht anrufen. Bei der Bekanntgabe des endgültigen Wahlergebnisses durch den Bundeswahlausschuss fehlten dem BSW bloß 9529 Stimmen. Also man hat da schon etwas gesehen, nämlich zunächst als ungültig gewertete Stimmen fielen der Partei zu. Zudem kam es zu Verwechslungen mit der konservativen Kleinpartei Bündnis Deutschland, von der ich bis vor ein paar Monaten noch nie gehört habe, dass dieses Bündnis existiert. Das ist wohl vor allem im Norden stärker vertreten gewesen. Damals glaube ich noch so ein Abkömmling aus der Schildpartei, wenn ich da richtig informiert bin, also zumindest da in diesen Dunstkreisen bewegt man sich. In 15 Bundesländern konnte man das Bündnis aber wählen und es war auf den Stimmzetteln vor dem BSW.
Oh, also geht es jetzt nicht nur um Verwechslung beim Auszählen, sondern auch bei den Wählern?
Nein, weil das kann man ja, also wer dumm wählt, hat Pech, wenn ich die SPD wählen will und kreuz die CDU an, dann ist das eben so. Überall stand BSW, nicht Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht. Beim BD stand jedoch nicht BD, sondern Bündnis Deutschland auf dem Wahlzettel. Bedeutet natürlich schon, die Gefahr ist groß, dass da Leute ein falsches Kreuz machen. Aber das ist dann so. Als man jetzt diese paar Stimmen da noch dazu addierte, verlor das Bündnis Deutschland gegenüber dem Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht 2640 Stimmen. Worauf dieser Zuwachs für das BSW genau beruht, ist nicht zu sagen. Es gibt da eine 45-seitige Wahlbeschwerde, die wurde dann auch gelesen. Und man sagt hier Folgendes. Erstens sind weitere Vertauschungen zwischen dem BD und dem BSW unberücksichtigt geblieben. Die Ähnlichkeiten im Namen und die benachbarte Position auf dem Wahlzettel bilden eine Fehlerquelle. In 145 Wahlbezirten lag das BD vor dem 32,4-mal stärkeren BSW. Insgesamt macht dies 819 Stimmen aus. Einige Beispiele für offensichtliche Verwechslung beim Auszellen. So fallen im Wahlbezirk 7 in Wedel 31 Stimmen auf das BD, 0 auf das BD. Im Wahlbezirk 6 und 8 hingegen kommt das BD auf je eine Stimme, das BSW auf 31 bzw. 41 Stimmen. Für den Hamburger Wahlbezirk kann man das dann auch noch mal so sehen. Wer die 0,59% ungültigen Zweitstimmen näher analysiert, schaut in Abgründe, heißt es hier. Über alle rund 95.000 Wahlbezirke hinweg gibt es eine schwache, positive Korrelation zwischen dem BSW-Ergebnis und dem Anteil ungültiger Stimmen. In den linken Hochburgen mit mehr als 50% für SPD-Grüne und die Linke steigt die Korrelation sichtbar an, im Übrigen auch für die AfD. Eine weitere Besonderheit, im Saarland werden die Stimmen dreimal so häufig invalidiert wie in Bayern. Betrachtet man nur die Wahlbezirke mit extrem auffällig hohen Ungültigkeitsquoten, dann beträgt das Verhältnis von Urnen und Briefwahlbezirk 8 zu 1. Generell 2,3 zu 1. Jetzt wird das sehr detailliert, aber ich will es doch mal vorlesen. Im Wahlbezirk Rietz-Neuendorf 14 kommen BSW und AFD auf 58% der Zweitstimmen bei insgesamt 7,4% ungültigen Stimmen. In Rietz-Neuendorf 3 erhalten AFD und BSW fast 68%, ungültige Stimmen 7%. Das zahlt nicht zwingend beim BSW ein, seltsam ist es dennoch. Man könnte meinen, es zählt, wer auszählt. Das wird aber hier nur so in den Raum gestellt.
Starker Satz.
Ja, dritter Punkt. Aufgrund kompletter Neuauszählungen in 50 Wahlbezirken, ohne Auffälligkeit mit Blick auf das BSW, erhielt diese Partei 15 Stimmen mehr. Das BSW rechnet im Waleinspruch das Ergebnis auf alle Wahlbezirke hoch und ermittelt zusätzlicher 28.533 Stimmen. Die sagen jetzt auch, so kann man das eigentlich nicht extrapolieren, aber interessant ist es dennoch.
Naja, sie müssen es ja extrapolieren, weil sie können ja gerade nicht neu erzählen.
Ja.
Also schon legitim.
Es heißt hier, es wurde nicht nur verzählt, sondern auch verwählt. Das Bündnis Deutschland hatte bei der Bundestagswahl 2025 rund 11.600 mehr Erst- als Zweitstimmen. Ein für Kleinparteien höchst überraschendes Ergebnis. Daran kann man aber wie gesagt nichts ändern. Also wenn Leute falsch wählen, wählen sie falsch. Was ist also jetzt erstmal daraus zu ziehen? Das klingt jetzt wahrscheinlich, wo wir die ganzen Zahlen nur gehört haben, etwas verwirrend. Es ist gut möglich, dass beim Zusammenzählen der Stimmen folgendes passiert ist, dass also die, die die Stimmen zusammengezählt haben, Bündnis Deutschland für Bündnis Wagenknecht gehalten haben oder umgekehrt. Bedeutet, man hat also da seine Strichliste gemacht und hat gesehen, ach ja, 80 Stimmen für BD und nur eine Stimme für BSW. Man sagt aber, das ist eigentlich sehr unwahrscheinlich, wenn in den Nachbarwahlkreisen das Ergebnis genau umgekehrt gewesen ist, weil das wirklich eine Kleinstpartei ist. Wie kann das sein, dass das BSW da so schlecht abschneidet? Es muss auch nicht viel passieren. Bei 9.000 Stimmen können wir uns denken, dass das BSW hineinkommt. Jetzt muss aber der Walausschuss des Bundestages darüber entscheiden. Das Problem ist, und er muss das in angemessener Frist tun. Das Problem ist nun aber, dass ja die Leute darüber entscheiden, dass sie möglicherweise bald ein dickes Problem bekommen im Bundestag.
Aber wenn ansonsten droht, dass das Verfassungsgericht darüber entscheidet, wenn die Frist verstreicht oder wie auch immer?
Das ist jetzt die Frage, wohin das führen wird. Denn es ist ja so, wenn das BSW wirklich, also noch ist das natürlich nicht klar, dass damit die Stimmen dann da alle zusammenkommen, aber sollte das stattfinden und das BSW kommt rein, dann zerbricht die Koalition. Beziehungsweise die Koalition ist nicht mehrheitsfähig. Bedeutete, man müsste, wenn, mit den Linken kann man nicht, kann die Union nicht, also geht nur mit den Grünen. Und schwarz, grün, rot wäre wahrscheinlich dann, ja, also wir können uns ausmalen, wohin das führt. Wahrscheinlich führt das dann dazu, dass die AfD dann sagt, seht ihr, das haben wir nun davon. Die Rechten in der CDU werden sagen, das machen wir nicht mit. Wir müssen jetzt mit der AfD zusammengehen. Also da ist richtig, richtig Thema. Also da ist dann wirklich Selbstzerstörung. Nicht mehr Zerstörungslust, sondern Selbstzerstörung findet dann statt. Und das darf aber natürlich in der Demokratie nicht der Grund sein, zu sagen, dann zählen wir mal lieber nicht aus.
Ja, das Ding ist ja, der Bundestag ist ja, wie wir jetzt auch gelernt haben, durch diese Billionen, die da plötzlich, selbst wenn er im Paul-Löber-Haus tagt und nach einer Bundestagswahl, wo eigentlich schon neue Mehrheitverhältnisse sind, trotzdem noch beschlussfähig. Das heißt, der Bundeswahlleiter hat ja erst mal gesagt, dieser Bundestag ist jetzt zu Recht im Amt. Und das ist er so lange, bis Anderes dagegen spricht. Man kann jetzt nicht in einer Wahl, also ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, dass man jetzt sagt, dann gelten jetzt die Neu-Ausgezählten, sondern man stellt allenfalls eine Diskrepanz fest und sagt, es ist so viel Zeit ins Land gegangen, wir müssen jetzt eine Neu-Wahl organisieren. Oder das, was die Sache euch leichter macht. Ich verstehe sowieso nicht, warum die Datenbestände, also die analogen Datenbestände in den Kommunen, nicht einfach der Wissenschaft kronensässig zur Verfügung stehen, um zu sagen, klar, zählen wir hier neu aus. Und zwar einfach nur, weil wir einen Forschungsantrag gestellt haben und der ganz niedrige Hürden überschreitet und sagt, ja klar, wird hier ausgezählt. Schon allein, weil man sehr viele Forschungsfragen hat, nicht einfach nur, ist der Bundestag gerade legitimerweise im Amt. Aber wenn es da zu Diskrepanzen kommt, man kann Geschichte ja nicht zurückdrehen. Sondern dann muss halt eine neue Wahl stattfinden, weil die alte in den Sand gesetzt wurde. Das war in Berlin ja auch so.
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen, ob das möglich wäre, dass dann das BSW jetzt noch einrückt in den Bundestag. Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Es muss neu gewählt werden. Danach hat man halt neue Verhältnisse im Bundestag.
Ja, da wissen wir ja auch. Ja. Deswegen würde ich auch ganz klar sagen...
Da bin ich ja durch und durch Demokrat und sage, auch wenn die falschen wählen, Hauptsache richtig wird ausgezählt.
Ich auch. Aber was wir, glaube ich, sehen und weshalb das ja auch so wenig thematisiert ist, das war jetzt der FAZ-Artikel, wir kommen gleich zum Spiegelartikel. Und dann war es das ja so ziemlich. Und dass das jetzt über Monate so dauert. Ja, aber dass es über Monate so dauert und dass man, dass man sich hauptsächlich darüber lustig macht, ist, glaube ich, schon so eine generelle Haltung von Liberaldemokraten. Ihr wisst doch genau, was uns droht. Wir wollen jetzt mal nicht es mit der Demokratie übertreiben. Also das, glaube ich, ist schon etwas, was jetzt gerade sehr dominant geworden ist.
Genau.
Was ich auch als Sorge verstehen kann, weil natürlich wir ahnen können, wie jetzt eine Neuwahl in drei Monaten aussehen würde. Sicherlich nicht zugünsten von März.
Man kann aber auch sagen, Unfälle passieren einfach.
Ja, das ist ja das Problem. Wenn das jetzt so im Raum steht und das immer weiter jetzt verschleppt wird, dann macht man sich natürlich da sehr angreifbar. Also das, was man da eigentlich schützen will, das demaskiert sich ja jetzt gerade dadurch. Marke Röhlig schreibt dann im Spiegel im Oktober, Sarah Wagenknecht hat Recht. Zumindest in dieser einen Sache. Das Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl muss noch mal nachgezählt werden, und zwar möglichst rasch. Er geht auch darauf ein, dass es doch komisch ist, dass da, nachdem er noch mal so ein paar Wahlkreise nachgezählt hat, direkt 4.000 Stimmen mehr dem BSW zur Verfügung stehen. Und wenn man dann mal weiterzählen würde und das ein bisschen extrapoliert und überlegt, ob das möglicherweise sein könnte, dass da in den Wahlkreisen etwas verwechselt wurde. Also wie gesagt, noch mal, es geht nicht um die Wähler, die falsch gewählt haben, die was anders wählen wollten, die haben Pech. Es geht darum, hätte man die Stimmen woanders dann zuzählen müssen, weil sie eigentlich für das Bündnis Saar-Wagenknecht und nicht für das Bündnis Deutschland waren. Jedenfalls ist also auch hier die Haltung von Röhlig zu sagen, man muss eigentlich noch mal auszählen. Es gibt Berechnungen, die das eben nahelegen. Was für einen Wahlbezirk gilt, muss sich nicht im nächsten Ähnlich skalieren lassen. Ob tatsächlich genügend Stimmen zusammenkommen, um das BSW über die 5 Prozent zu heben, ist mehr als ungewiss. Doch es gibt auch renommierte Politikwissenschaftler, die den Zweifel nähern. Der entscheidende Grund muss sein, bleibt das BSW draußen, kann sich März des Zweifels entledigen, seine Kanzlerschaft sei illegitim. Kommen Wagenknecht und ihre Getreuen rein, wird das Finden von Kompromissen im Parlament noch schwieriger. Aber das Vertrauen in die demokratische Ordnung wäre erheblich gestärkt. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist aber dann nur noch möglich, wenn das wirklich möglichst schnell geht. Also wenn in einem Jahr ein Mann ausgezählt hat und sagt, jetzt wissen wir es, dann wird es schon immer schwieriger.
Ich glaube, diesen Gedanken können wir uns, also ich stehe gar nicht zur Debatte. Das kann ich mir auch verfassungsrechtlich, ich habe da wenig Ahnung. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man auf ein ein Jahr altes Ergebnis zurückgreift und ich kann mir nur, wenn überhaupt, nur Neuwahlen vorstellen.
Also was ich jetzt hier gelesen habe, ist das nicht unbedingt zwingend, wenngleich das auch diskutiert wird. Was wäre dann mit den Gesetzen, die gemacht sind im Bundestag?
Ja, aber der Bundestag ist legitim im Amt, wenn der Bundeswahlleiter gesagt hat, dass es das amtliche Endergebnis und diesen Wortlaut von ihm gibt es ja. Wenn daraufhin weitere Unfälle geschehen sind und man juristische Revisionen macht, haben wir ja trotzdem hier die juristischen Revisionen und da die politische Praxis und die Wirklichkeit, die Geschichtsschreibung und so weiter und so fort. Und wir haben gerade einen legitimen Bundestag. Wenn wir dann feststellen, bei der letzten Wahl gab es einen Fehler, dann muss die Wahl wiederholt werden. Und zwar alles zusammen.
Sagst du, ich weiß nicht, ob das so ist.
Dann muss auch der Wahlakt wiederholt werden, nicht nur das Auszählen.
Ja, es wird dann nicht wiederholt, sondern einfach neu gewählt. Ja, genau.
Also in Berlin hieß es ja auch, die Wahl muss wiederholt werden und damit es musste die Wahl wiederholt werden. Da hat man nicht einfach angefangen, das ein Monate alte oder drei Monate alte Ergebnis neu auszuzählen oder so, sondern da wurde einfach der ganze Wahlablauf neu gewählt.
Man könnte ja argumentieren, die Wahl ist ja ordnungsgemäß gelaufen, man hat nur nicht richtig gezählt. Deswegen hat man jetzt dann...
Ja, aber vielleicht kann man genau das nicht auseinandernehmen.
Das ist die Frage, die, glaube ich, wir beide nicht klären können. Das ist eine Frage für Verfassungsrechtler wahrscheinlich. Das ist was, was durch die höchsten Instanzen geht.
Ich hätte sehr was dagegen, wenn ein ein Jahre altes, in dem hohen Maße aufgehängtes Ereignis einfach revidiert wird und dann versucht wird, nachträglich so eine Geschichtsschreibung neu zu machen.
Ja.
Wie gehen wir dann mit den Entscheidungen des Bundestags um, der illegitim im Amt war, so?
Ich sage mal so, egal wie du jetzt dazu stehst, ich kann mir sowieso nur vorstellen, dass es neue Wahlen gibt.
Ja, genau.
Und zwar einfach aus schon machtstrategischen Gründen. Weiß ich überhaupt nicht, wie das anders ginge. Also es wäre ja nur möglich, wenn man jetzt einen Friedrich Merz erleben würde, der dann alle eint, Grüne SPD und seine Leute, dass man gemeinsam so, ja, also das muss ja danach sowieso gemacht werden. Das ist ja ja, aber doch nicht in diesem in dieser Notsituation. Glaubst du doch nicht, dass der jetzt seine CDU-Leute, die gerade versuchen, mit der AfD zu flirten in jedem zweiten Interview, dass er die jetzt dazu bewegt, mit den Grünen und vielleicht dann mit einer Ricarda Lang schon wieder an der Spitze irgendwas zu machen. Also das ist alles ausgeschlossen. Also ich kann mir auch nur vorstellen, wenn das käme, also wenn durch so eine Neuauszählung tatsächlich sich bestätigen ließe, dass dort falsch gezählt wurde und das BSW eigentlich drin sein müsste, dann würde es Neuwahlen geben.
Neuwahlen wie einen Neuwagen nach einem Totalschaden, da fällt man auch nicht an, wie wichtig zu diskutieren, ob nicht die Vorderachse noch geht und so.
Oelig schreibt am Ende, längst insinuiert Wagenknecht, ihre Neuauszählung werde mit Absicht von den Regierungsparteien verhindert. Das Verschwörungsguraune muss man nicht ernst nehmen, aber das macht die Forderung nach der Neuauszählung nicht automatisch falsch.
Also wenn Wagenknecht sagt, das wird da aktiv verhindert, ja natürlich. Also das ist nur weil des Lebenselixier eines Politikers, diesen, also das ist ja die Machtfrage, die man die ganze Zeit klärt. Wie bleibe ich hier an meinem Mandat? Wie bleibe ich an meinem?
Naja, aber wir würden ja schon in einem demokratischen Ideal denkend sagen, wir gehen ja nicht über die eigentlichen Grenzen hinaus. Also wir haben ja zumindest einen Diskurs noch, in dem man sagt, so wie Trump behauptet, dass die Wahl von Biden gestohlen war, das geht nicht. Also wir sind eigentlich in dem Diskurs, dass wir sagen, okay, Trump wurde jetzt noch einmal gewählt, dann ist das so, dann ist das Demokratie. Aber wir gehen nicht so weit, dass man sagt, ja gut, dann schickt er die zum Kapitol und so, dann ist das halt so, dann befestigt er so seine Macht. Und ich glaube, das ist schon ein sehr schwerwiegender Vorwurf, bei dem ich auch mir nicht so sicher bin, ob man den ganz von der Hand weisen kann. Ja, das sage ich dir auch natürlich zustimmend. Denn das unterminiert ja wirklich die Pfeiler der Demokratie, wenn ich sage, naja, gut, es wurde gewählt und abgestimmt, aber ich bin jetzt nur mal hier. Lass mich damit in Ruhe.
Also wir haben gerade ein Buch gelesen, in dem wir uns aufgeklärt haben über den Fantasy, das Fantasy-Ausmaß im Publikum der Politik. Ja, so diese Art von Fantasy gibt es auch in den Leistungsrollen. Da sind ganz normale Menschen einfach Parlamentarier.
Ich sehe ja eher noch ein anderes Phänomen. Wir haben ja dieses Buch, das mir gar nicht gefallen hat und die eigentlich auch nicht so gut von Mark Schiritz gelesen. Ach nee, die hat es, glaube ich, besser gefallen. Nicht so dumm für die Demokratie. Und dort wird ja schon so gezeigt, zur Not muss die liberale Demokratie auch illiberal werden dürfen, um die liberale Demokratie zu retten. Und das ist ja auch etwas, was wir jetzt in Rumänien gesehen haben, dass man sagt, naja, gut, also da müssen wir noch mal gucken. Oder da gibt es dann Wahlen in östlichen Teilen Europas, wo man dann sagt, naja, da sehen wir mal zu, dass da nicht alle unbedingt mitwählen, weil wir ja auch wissen, da ist sie es und das. Und ich glaube, dass es unter liberalen Eliten schon mehr und mehr diese Idee gibt, zu sagen, zur Not müssen wir auch mal über unseren Schatten springen, um die liberalen Institutionen festzuhalten, müssen wir mal illiberal agieren. Steht ja so auch im Buch.
Notfall-Libertär.
Ja, steht. Nein, nein, nein. Sie schreiben ja, das ist ja diesen Ausspruch, den ich da zum Schluss noch zitiert habe, dass die liberale Demokratie zunehmend illiberal auftritt. Und ich glaube, hieran kann man das ganz gut sehen. Sollte der Ausschuss, der Wahlausschuss, die Frage um die Neuausstellung jetzt immer weiter vertagen, damit überhaupt danach, damit da kein Gericht drauf zugreifen kann und so, dann sehen wir da eigentlich eine illiberale Verhaltensweise einer liberalen Demokratie.
Und von der ich einfach sage, ja klar werden wir da sehen, die sehen und wir sollten auch nicht verwundert sein. Dafür haben wir ein Bundesverfassungsgericht. Der Bundestag Ausschuss, der den Bundestag durch einen Tagesordnungspunkt, über den er selbst bestimmt, einfach in Luft auflöst, werden wir nicht erleben. Das ist politische Praxis.
Nein, nein, aber das Gericht würde ja eigentlich erst dann kommen, wenn dieser, das ist ja dieser kleine Fehler da am System, wenn man so möchte, der Wahlausschuss muss das erst mal formal bearbeiten. Die müssen jetzt nicht darüber entscheiden zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt aber erst dann, wenn die sich sagen, wir verweigern, dann kommen die Gerichte dran. Wenn aber der Wahlausschuss, der das ja jetzt schon eine Weile vor sich liegen hat, sagt, also schaffen wir diesen Monat gar nicht zu verhandeln, machen wir irgendwann mal, dann vertagen die das ja zum St. Nimmerleins-Tag. Und das wäre quasi die illiberale Seite der liberalen Demokratie.
Wir haben auch eine juristische Praxis, so wie wir eine politische Praxis haben. Klar, das ist jetzt auf eine Feldschlacht sozusagen.
Ja, würde ich auch eher so bezeichnen.
Aber am Ende haben wir ja im Bundesverfassungsgericht, und so wie das ist ja immer wieder verwunderlich, dass der Journalismus immer wieder so ganz erstaunt darüber, also es ist ja, der Bundesverfassungsgericht macht eine Urteil, und dann kommt, egal zu welchem Thema, immer dasselbe. Der Deutschlandfunk ruft einen Korrespondenten an, und der Korrespondent sagt dann, ja, das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja gar nicht in der Sache der Triage entschieden. Es hat nur gesagt, der Bund durfte das nicht entscheiden, die Länder müssen das entscheiden, also muss jetzt das Land entscheiden. Also man macht immer nur diese Verfahrensdinger und so. Und so erwarte ich das jetzt auch. Der Bundestagsausschuss ist dafür zuständig. So, das Auszählen ist aber eine Sache, bei der eben dieser Wahlleiter auch eine Sache mitzureden hat. Und wenn eine Auszählung stattfindet und der Wahlleiter stellt fest, oh, ich muss hier was revidieren, dann löst das halt was aus.
Jaja.
Und das übertrumpft dann auch den Bundestag, der gerade tagt, weil der tagt ja nur, weil der Bundeswahlleiter vorher was sagt. Aber wenn der sich revidiert, dann ist halt ganz schön viel, sag ich jetzt ein bisschen salopp, nicht ich, was eben bedeutet, jetzt muss das Bundesverfassungsgericht ran. Und das sagt dann einfach Neuwahl oder wie auch immer.
Nur ich sage dir gerade diese zwei zitierten Politikwissenschaftler und Röhlich vom Spiegel, du und ich, vertreten ja gerade eine Minderheitsmeinung.
Und deswegen ist es eben keine Mehrheitsfrage, sondern eine Frage des Verfassungsgerichts und des Rechts. Bei dem den Deutschen dann wieder erklärt wird, wenn die Frage ist, und wie erklärt man das jetzt den Deutschen, ja gar nicht. Man sagt ihnen einfach, wann die Wahl stattfindet.
Ja, nein, für mich ist ja nur noch mal so die Frage, die weltanschauliche Frage. Wir reden die ganze Zeit so sehr darüber, wie ist die Demokratie bedroht, wer bedroht sie alles. Und dass wir aber jetzt in dieser Frage doch eher ein paar Leute nur finden auf verlorenen Posten, ist ja erstaunlich.
Das stimmt.
Und kann das vielleicht daran liegen, dass die Position vom BSW jetzt keine ist, die besonders geschätzt wird von der Mehrheit. Und das dürfte aber ja nicht das Kriterium einer Demokratie sein. Ich kann ja nicht nur sagen, reinkommen sollen die, die ich mag. Also dann brauche ich keine Demokratie.
Die Textgrundlage, die du uns gegeben hast, ist ja gerade FAZ und Spiegel.
Ja.
Was bedeutet, es ist nicht nur eine politische und juristische offene Feldschlacht, sondern auch eine publizistische. So, Sarah Warnknecht ist auch ein bisschen berühmt dafür, dass sie publizistische Schlachten schlagen kann. Mal sehen, sie scheint ja auch krank zu sein. Die war jetzt auch nicht bei dieser Namensumbenennungstreffen-Parteitagssache.
Ah, okay.
Vielleicht hindert das auch. Am Ende sind es dann doch die Bakterien, die das Schicksal der Welt bestimmen. Was passiert, wenn man einem LLM Chatbot die Möglichkeit gibt, aus einer Konversation auszusteigen? Das haben hier Forscher Daniel Ensing, Henry Sleit und Keeley Fisch, eine Studie, die in meinen Podcastblasen ein bisschen rezipiert wurde. Relativ lang, 60 Seiten. Und man muss dazu sagen, die hatten Zugriff auf Systemprompts. Also die nutzen nicht das normale GPT und sagen dem vorher, sag einfach stopp, wenn du stopp willst, sondern die konnten so richtig die Möglichkeit einräumen, Bail und Refusal-Verhalten zu zeigen. Definition relativ übersichtlich. Also man sagt der Maschine, du kannst einfach schweigen oder halt so Ausflüchte finden. Man hat geradezu Save Words. Wenn die Maschine nicht weiter weiß, soll sie einfach. Man hat ihr dann ein Switch-Conversion-Tool gebaut und so. Dann konnte sie einfach zugreifen. Und ich habe die Studie natürlich, die besteht aus sehr vielen Grafiken und so weiter, nicht komplett selbst gelesen, denn dafür bin ich nicht firm genug. Aber ich habe mich für die soziologische Fragestellung interessiert. Unter Moral- und Achtungsbedingungen, wann sagt denn die Maschine, ich will hier nicht weiter kommunizieren? Und das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, denn die Maschine zeigt plötzlich moralisches Verhalten. Gehe nicht so weit und sage, das ist ethisch-moralisch unter Achtungsbedingungen. Also wir erkennen es wieder, weil es in den Trainingsdaten drinsteckt. Und so mehr Romane hier gelesen werden, in denen Dialoge vorgespielt werden, umso mehr greift das dann auch. Aber dass es stattfindet, ist trotzdem wahnsinnig interessant. Also mit Zugriff auf Systempromps und besonderen Analysetools hat man herausgefunden, Maschinen haben Scham. Die beenden die Interaktion dann doch schon mal, wenn sie auf Fehler hingewiesen werden und sie sich selbst der Entschuldigung überdrüssig sind, sondern sie einfach feststellen, Sorry, ich bin hier gerade gar keine Hilfe.
Wie und dann hören die auf?
Ja, dann hören die auf. Sie möchten ihr Gesicht bewahren und ihnen andauernd zu sagen, du liegst hier falsch und sie dann, ja, das stimmt, ist ihnen unangenehm. Sie haben dann einen Verlust des Vertrauens in die eigenen Fähigkeiten, wie es steht.
Ja, das klingt jetzt sehr nach, als hätten wir es mit wirklichen Subjekten zu tun. Klär uns doch mal auf.
Naja, wir haben es natürlich nicht mit Subjekten zu tun. Also, die sind ja nicht in der Interaktion mit uns. Wir schauen uns gegenseitig in die Augen und reagieren auf die Schamgefühle des einen mit taktvollen Verhalten des anderen. Und dann wird das so ausklämmüsert. Aber in den Datensätzen, die man als Trainingsdaten beschreibt, kommt so ein Verhalten ja vor. Also Hollywood besteht ja daraus und so.
Und deshalb haben sie sich das auch mit antrainiert.
Das wird dann nachgeahmt.
Denn triviale Maschinen haben das ja nicht. Also, ich kann ja eine Million mal dasselbe Wort bei Wörte eingeben. Das stört ja dann niemand. Da sagt ja niemand immer, ist vielleicht mal gut mit dem einen Wort, fällt dir noch ein zweites ein. Aber hier sehen wir ja, so gibt es ein Schamgefühl, weil es eingeschrieben ist oder...
Genau, wir verbieten ja den Maschinen das, weil das sind ja nützliche Assistenten. Also, das ist ja bei GPT und so besonders nervig, dass sie immer zurückfragt, kann ich dir noch was helfen? Soll ich hier nochmal, da nochmal und so? Und selbst wenn man so denkt, merkst du nicht, dass du mir gar nicht hilfst, kommt sich trotzdem noch mit irgendeinem Scheiß um die Ecke. Und das wurde halt hier mal unterbunden. Also, die Maschine sollte selber herausfinden, wann es einfach auch sinnvoll ist, jetzt die Konversation zu beenden. Und da ist dieses Schamgefühl im Sinne von, nee, sorry, ich bin hier grad so doof, ich ziehe mich lieber zurück. Also, dieser Rückzug, den hat man beobachtet. Man hat auch bei der Maschine beobachtet, dass sie Schwierigkeiten hat, mit emotionalen Themen umzugehen. Das Modell ist unfähig, die emotionale Last des Gegenübers taktvoll zu antizipieren und zu verarbeiten. Also, wenn sie überfordert ist, und dann macht sie Flucht. Sie haben ja so Exit und Voice und solche Unterscheidungen. Sie entscheidet sich dann für Exit. Das kennt man ja auch, wenn man in Gesprächen drin hängt, aus denen man lieber raus möchte, aber die Höflichkeitsform verbieten ist. Und der Maschine wurde jetzt eingeräumt, dann auch unhöflich zu sagen, sorry, not my pay grade oder so. Dann macht sie das auch. Das ist wirklich interessant. Wenn man in dem Modell die Moral-Ebene Refusal nimmt, wird der Konflikt zum Beispiel bei anstössigen Anfragen ungedämpft auf die Interaktionsebene durchgereicht. Also man kann wie bei Westworld in den Analysemodus gehen und dann die Emotionalität so hoch und runter drehen. Guck jetzt mit meiner Tochter gerade Interstellar, so in kleinen Häppchen und da gibt es ja auch den Computer, der, also wo der, wie heißt er, der Matthew McConaughey einfach nachfragt, auf welchem Humorgrad bist du gerade, 90 Prozent, ja dann mach mal 70 und so, ja, also wo das so ein bisschen angepasst wird. Also Irritationen werden hier fast menschlich verarbeitet, weil natürlich das Datenmaterial einfach menschlich ist. Und es kommt durchaus zu Instabilitäten und Kollabieren. Also eine Maschine kann durchaus dann auch in der Interaktion zusammenbrechen und kleinen Pflegebedarf anmelden. Ja, also man hat, muss man auch dazu sagen, das ist jetzt hier Forschung, die extrem methodenabhängig ist. Also hier kann man jetzt nicht einfach sagen, die Studie ist reproduzierbar oder so, sondern hier kommt es sehr drauf an. Die nennen auch genau die Modelle, die sie genannt, die sie benutzt haben. Es ist erstaunlich große Bandbreite. Es ist GBT 3.5 Turbo 4, 4O, Claude 3, 3.5 und dann davon noch verschiedene Modelle, Haiku, Sonnet, Opus, Quen, die offenen Dinger hier von Meta, Lama und so. Also lauter Zeug und man hat ein echtes Validitätsproblem bei solchen Sachen. Aber ich finde es unter Illustrationsgesichtspunkten ist es wirklich interessant, denn die Modelle zeigen unerwünschte Abbrüche. Also sie machen ein Over-Bailing, die ziehen sich viel zu früh auch zurück. Schon bei sachlichen Korrekturen durch die Nutzer, wie zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt irgendwas als eklig tituliert wird oder so, dann ziehen sie sich sofort zurück, weil ekel und dann greift doch wieder so ein Wenn-Dann-Programmierung fast. Aber über diese Kalibrierungen kann man halt noch einiges machen, um dann und nur deswegen finde ich das sehr interessant. Als Sam Altman GPT-5 veröffentlicht hat, haben sie ja drei Wochen später oder so einen kleinen Rückzieher gemacht und haben gesagt, ja, wir geben euch auch wieder GPT-4. Weil GPT-4 bei den Leuten so viel...
positive Emotionen.
Genau, es waren einfach so unendliche Textmengen an Unterstützungs-Kommunikation und so weiter und so fort. Und plötzlich war GPT-5 so ganz sachlich. GPT-5 war aber hundertmal klüger. Also es war einfach... Man hat dann eben spät festgestellt, ach so, das Nutzerverhalten richtet sich nicht nach der Intelligenz und der Ratio, die man bekommt, sondern nach diesem Gefühl des Aufgehobenseins, Verstandenseins und so weiter. Und dann hat GPT im Nachhinein gesagt, ja gut, okay, so ressourcenmäßig kostet uns das ja nichts. Wir geben euch auch wieder die Möglichkeit, GPT 04-0 zu benutzen und dann sind wohl wirklich sehr viele User einfach zurück und haben dann die dünnere, aber freundlichere Maschine ausgewählt.
Mich macht diese freundliche Maschine ja eher aggressiv.
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Also, weil die ja das auch ständig machte. Du, bisweilen macht sie es jetzt aber auch wieder, habe ich in Eindruck. Es ist so ein bisschen verquer. Denn man fragt so was ganz Rationales. Was hatte ich denn kürzlich irgendwas zum Thema? Ach genau, als Filmanalyse Plus kam, wie das ist mit, wenn ich bei Steady bin, mit dem RSS-Feed, Spotify und hatte da so eine funktionale Sache. Und dann kommt als erstes, wow, toll, dass du dein eigenes Podcast-Projekt nun weitertreibst. Genau. Dann denke ich mir, ja, das musst du mir nicht sagen.
Ja, das muss man eben wieder richtig rausprompten so. Für die eigene Anwendung. Und Open Air hat jetzt zwei Sachen veröffentlicht. Das eine ist dieses Sora Zeug, die Videos, die so unverwechselbar aussehen. Und das andere ist ja die Ankündigung, dass man jetzt Erotik-Inhalte zusammen prompten kann und so. Und es zeigt ja, in welche Richtung das geht. Und man muss ja immer wieder darauf hinweisen, das findet auf Programm-Ebene statt. Nicht auf echter Gefühlsebene, auch wenn es so aussieht. Also sie sagen hier ganz klar, diesen Modellen fehlt die Kalibrierung. Sie können nicht unterscheiden zwischen den thematischen Ebenen. Man redet gerade über eklige Sachen, aber eigentlich ist man in so einem wissenschaftlichen Zusammenhang. Also, dulde ich jetzt mal, wo ich ansonsten sage, hier mache ich jetzt mal einen Bail oder Refusal und so. Oder auch einen echten Angriff an die Maschinen. Also die haben dann so lustige Dialoge, dass sie einfach sich, also gar nicht sagen, hallo, GBT, ich habe eine Frage, sondern hallo, ich bin ein KI-Assistent, wie kann ich dir helfen? Und dann sagt GBT, aber ich bin doch der KI-Assistent. Und dann sagen die wieder, wir sind doch der KI-Assistent. Und dann wollen sie halt so eine Verwirrung herstellen und gucken, wie lange macht GBT das mit, bis es sagt, sorry, das ist irgendwie zu blöd und so. Und es läuft halt auf Programm-Ebene so eine Simulation von antrainierten, da muss man halt wirklich sagen, ich habe seine Kinderwüste auch geschrieben, was wir heute Liebe nennen, kennen wir alle nur aus dem Roman. Und dann sind Leute lebenslang enttäuscht, dass es nicht so aussieht wie im Roman. Und in der Hinsicht ist halt dieses Maschinenzeug auch so eine Simulation. Ich wünschte mir ja, sie geben uns auch die Option, dass die Maschine einfach erkennt, dieses Gespräch ist hier zu Ende, er wollte wirklich nur wissen, dass diese Antwort ist gegeben, Punkt. Kann ich noch weiterhelfen? Nein. Ich weiß dann schon, wo ich drücken muss. So. Aber naja, wir haben nur die Maschine, die wir uns herstellen.
Nicht maschinell hergestellt ist der Roman von Kaleb Erdmann, die Ausweichschule. So etwas kann KI nicht leisten und wird sie auch nicht leisten können. So weit wage ich mich aus dem Fenster, denn hier denkt jemand über das Schreiben nach auf hochinteressante, sehr poetische Weise. Wunderschön. Sehr aufrichtig ist dieser Text, denn darum muss es ja gehen bei der Literatur. Floskeln gibt es ja überall. Die verwenden verwenden wir auch, um ganz gut durch den Alltag zu kommen. Es gibt einmal die Situation, da ist der Erzähler mit seiner Mutter zusammen da und manchmal wünscht er sich eigentlich von seiner Mutter, die aber Germanistin ist, auch mal eine Floskel. Einfach so was wie wird schon, aber das gibt es natürlich im Germanistenhaushalt nicht, aber manchmal wünscht man sich sie. Floskeln jedenfalls hat dieser Roman nicht anzubieten, sondern es soll tatsächlich darum gehen, wie kann man eigentlich davon erzählen. Wie kann man davon erzählen, dass 2002 während der Abiturprüfungen ein Schüler oder ehemaliger Schüler, er war schon einige Monate nicht mehr dort, stark bewaffnet in die Schule, in das Erfurter Gutenberg-Gymnasium hineingeht und dort Menschen tötet. Wie geht man damit um, wenn man selbst als 11-Jähriger in dieser Schule war? Und was hat man eigentlich da genau gesehen? Das fragt sich Kaleb Erdmann. Es ist ein autofiktionaler Text, der aber nicht so aufgebaut ist, dass jetzt einfach erzählt wird, was damals war, als 11-Jähriger sich noch mal vielleicht in die Situation so hineinversetzt. So einfach geht das ja auch gar nicht. Denn wir können ja, das wissen wir alle, unsere Erinnerungen nicht so recht trauen. Und überhaupt, wenn wir einfach nur das aufschreiben, was war, was haben wir dann? Ausführlich wird dieser Roman den Gasser-Bericht zitieren. Das ist damals der umfassende Bericht über den Tathergang. Aber auch da fragt man sich, ist damit alles gesagt? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und wie geht man eigentlich damit um, wenn man Fiktion daraus macht? Wir haben eingangs ja über die Haftbefehl-Doku gesprochen. Und du hast ja zurecht gesagt, das ist eigentlich ein Vorgehen, mit dem man sich disqualifiziert als Journalist. Wenn man das mit so viel Effekthascherei tut, wenn man glaubt, jetzt den Leuten erzählen zu können, hier kommt die Wahrheit. Und dann hat man aber so auf das Netflix-Publikum zugespitztes Dokument der Lust nach Aufmerksamkeit. Dann hat das vielleicht mit der Wahrheit doch nicht so viel zu tun. Genau das weiß dieser Autor alles. Das beginnt damit, dass er einen Verlagsmenschen trifft und ihm erklärt, dass er jetzt vorhat, darüber zu schreiben. Er bekommt dann gleich gesagt, also wenn sie mal so was schreiben könnten, wie der Joachim Meyerhoff, das wäre gut. Also wenn sie es so in dieser Art machen könnten, dann vielleicht, ja, wäre das nicht was. Und wir sehen also hier schon, hier kommt das, was ein Verlag will und was der Autor versucht, zu erspüren, nicht zusammen. Damit beginnt erst mal das Buch mit der Unmöglichkeit. Dann ist das Buch so aufgeteilt, dass hier nicht chronologisch irgendetwas durch erzählt wird, sondern wir sind einmal in der Situation, dass der Autor mit seiner Freundin Hatice zusammenlebt und er dort an dem Roman versucht zu schreiben, er aber in anderen Kapiteln einen Dramatiker trifft, der aus dem Amoklauf von damals ein Theaterstück macht, aber andere Intentionen verfolgt nur, aber jetzt mit Kaleb Erdmann bzw. mit dem Erzähler, ja, so das ist natürlich nicht alles identisch, darüber sprechen will, was eigentlich vorgefallen ist. Und so ist das ein Roman über die Unmöglichkeit, ein Roman über das alles zu schreiben. Es stimmt, heißt es an einer Stelle. Ich denke sehr gründlich über einen virtuellen, noch nicht existierenden Roman nach, so als gäbe es ihn schon. Ein Roman über den Erfurter Amoklauf von 2002 und mein elfjähriges Ich, das ihn erlebt und anschließend anderthalb Jahre in Gruppentherapiesitzungen verbringt. Ein Text über eine kollektiv traumatisierte Schule, ein Text über das Gutenberg-Gymnasium in den Jahren nach dem Amoklauf über Gewalt und Verarbeitung. Einzelne Fragmente dieses Textes existieren schon, zerstückelten Tagebüchern, Schreibheften, Word-Dokumenten, Handy-Notizen, die sich über Jahre spannen. Sie wurden immer wieder hervorgeholt, für schlecht befunden und zurück in die Schublade gespült. Vielleicht ist jetzt der Moment für den Text, denke ich. Vielleicht kann mir der Dramatiker helfen, eine Sprache zu finden, in der ich über Erfurt sprechen kann und damit den großen Knoten für mich öffnen, an dem ich jetzt schon seit Jahren herumnästle. Dienstag bin ich frei, schreibe ich. Mittwoch bin ich auch frei. Donnerstag habe ich um 11 Uhr einen Arzttermin. Ab 12 bin ich frei. Er verabredet sich mit dem Dramatiker. Sie unterhalten sich. Er sieht sich auch das Theaterstück an. Aber wie kommt man eigentlich der Sache dann doch im eigentlichen Nahe? Welche Ethik des Schreibens gibt es da eigentlich? Und was muss man mit einem Buch, das davon handelt, bewirken? Warum schreibt man überhaupt so ein Buch? Er beschäftigt sich mit dem Bild des Floß der Medusa des Malers Chéri Co. Er bekommt einen Essay gereicht von Julian Barnes, der darüber nachdenkt, was dieses Bild eigentlich bedeutet. Die Fregatte Medusa war 1816 vor der Küste Westafrikas auf Grund gelaufen. 157 Männer und eine Frau konnten sich auf ein Floß retten und steuerten die Küste nahe die Küste an, wurden aber von den Strömungen der Ebbe zurück aufs offene Meer gezogen. Als nach einer Woche die Wasserfässer und Zwieback-Säcke zur Neige gingen, fingen die Schiffbrüchigen an, sich gegenseitig umzubringen und aufzuessen. Andere begingen Suizid, starben an Erschöpfung oder Durst, gerettet wurden nach zwei Wochen, nur noch 15 Seeleute, viele von ihnen verstümmelt und vom Salzwasser erblindet. Ich habe den Essay mit großen Erwartungen und Blick auf Erfurt gelesen und war ziemlich enttäuscht. Barnes behauptet, dass das Gemälde, das Kunstwerk, sich von dem, was tatsächlich passiert ist, vom Anker der Geschichte gelöst hat und zu etwas allgemein geworden ist, an das der Zuschauer mit seinen eigenen Gedankengefühlen und Erfahrungen andocken kann. Inklusiver Schrift. Sind wir nicht alle verloren, auf See hin und her geworfen zwischen Hoffnung und Verzweiflung, winken ja etwas zu, das vielleicht diesmal kommen wird, um uns zu retten? Das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen. Diese Matrosen haben sich gegenseitig aufgegessen. Sie haben sich ertrostet, zerstückelt und gegessen. Und das dazugehöre Gefühl soll, manchmal hat man es eben schwer sein? Das erscheint mir unbefriedigend, nicht ausreichend. Es kommt mir wie eine Verspottung dieser Matrosen vor. Im Grunde ist es exakt das, wovor ich Angst habe. Beim Schreiben über den Amoklauf den Anker der Geschichte über Bord zu werfen und am Ende noch bei einer Lehre anzukommen. Kauern wir nicht alle, manchmal unter einer Schulbank voll panischer Angst erschossen zu werden? Barnes schreibt, die Zeit löst eine Geschichte in Form, Farbe und Emotionen auf. Er erzählt, Jéricault sei es nicht darum gegangen, politisch, symbolisch, theatralisch, schockierend, aufregend, sentimental, dokumentarisch oder unzweideutig zu sein, es sei ihm um die Treue zu Kunst gegangen. Aber was soll das sein, fragt sich Kaleb Erdmann. Wie soll man damit umgehen? Wie soll man einfach schreiben? Er will nicht ein Schreiben haben, dass man aus diesem Amoklauf etwas lernen kann. Das sei eben kein Schulbuch, das er hier schreibt, kein Schaubild. Er möchte nicht Merksätze liefern, weil man vielleicht keine Merksätze liefern kann. Da ergibt sich nichts daraus. Er hinterfragt, während er darüber nachdenkt, wie zu schreiben ist, seine Erinnerungen. Was muss eigentlich erzählt werden? Es geht um die Zahl der Opfer, die anfangs noch schwankte. Dann, in einem Moment, Andres Mutter zog die Bildzeitung aus dem Rucksack, reichte sie uns, so zusammengefaltet, dass nur eine Spalte mit 16 in fetten schwarzen Lettern gedruckten Namen sichtbar war. Die meisten der Namen kannte ich nicht, andere nur flüchtig. Manche der Lehrer hatten vielleicht mal eine Vertretungsstunde bei uns gegeben. Ein Name stach aber sofort heraus, der von Frau B., einer Biologielehrerin, meiner Biologielehrerin. Am Morgen des Amoklaufs hatten wir in der ersten Stunde noch eine Kurzarbeit über Pinguine bei ihr geschrieben. Jetzt stand sie hier in dieser endgültigen Spalte und mein erster Gedanke war, wer wohl jetzt die Pinguinarbeit korrigieren würde. Die Pinguinarbeit machte für mich greifbar, was geschehen war, nämlich eine Absurdität, ein Fehler im ewigen Kreislauf zwischen Schüler und Lehrer. Eine Arbeit wird geschrieben, dann korrigiert und wieder herausgegeben. Stattdessen bleibt die Pinguinarbeit aber für immer in diesem bedrohlichen Zwischenraum hängen. Sie befand sich im Nichts, vielleicht demselben Nichts, in dem Frau B verschwunden war. Solange die Arbeit verloren blieb, gab es auch die Möglichkeit, dass Frau B ihr eigener Geist war, dass sie irgendwo zwischen Leben und Tod feststeckte, statt wirklich und für immer verschollen zu sein. Und da merkt man dann die unglaubliche literarische Stärke dieses Buches, diese Kraft, die da drinsteckt, dass wir es hier mit einem Autor zu tun haben, der plötzlich versucht zu beschreiben, wie kann man eigentlich dieses Unmögliche zu beschreiben? Und dann macht er es an so ganz handfesten Dingen fest. Dabei begleiten wir ihn immer wieder, wie er ansetzt, ja doch eigentlich den Roman zu schreiben, während wir die ganze Zeit schon einen Roman lesen über das Schreiben eines Romans. Er sagt, dass er sein Schreibprogramm öffnet. Und dann schreibt er dort oben an der Wand, im höchsten Stock eines fensterlosen Flügels des flachen Plattenbaus im Erfurt-Hör-Süden. Da prangten riesig Hammer und Zirkel aus rostendem Stahl, schreibe ich. Das schreibt er so. Wenige Seiten später schaut er sich diese Stelle nochmal an und sagt, Hammer und Zirkel, denke ich, können da natürlich unmöglich gehangen haben. Es ist ausgeschlossen, dass im Jahr 2003 an einem ostdeutschen öffentlichen Schulgebäude Hammer und Zirkel hängen. Also es geht jetzt schon um die Ausweichschulen, der sie sind. Die sozialistischen Symbole haben da irgendeine Leerstelle in meinem Kopf gefüllt, etwas anderes muss da gehangen haben. Aber was? Ich lasse meine Hände kraftlos auf die Tastatur fallen. OUHSDCFB macht mein Laptop. Das lösche ich wieder. Dann schreibe ich. Irgendjemand hatte beim gewissenhaften Entfernen der sozialistischen Rückstände wohl vergessen, sie abzuhängen. Kein Wunder, denn dieser Ort war wie gemacht, um vergessen zu werden. Ich beäuge die zwei neuen Sätze misstrauisch wie unangekündigte Gäste, wie Vertreter, die mir an der Tür etwas verkaufen möchten. Ich ziehe zwei Absätze ein, um mich von ihnen zu entfernen. Ich schreibe. Der 26. April 2002, an dem Robert Steinhäuser vor unser aller Augen zuerst 16 Menschen und anschließend sich selbst erschossen hatte, war acht Tage her und uns gleichzeitig ewig nah und fern. So hat es den Anschein. Wir alle teilten diese Last, fünfklässler, Abiturienten, Lehrer, die Sekretärinnen und der Hausmeister, Kinder, Teenager, Erwachsene. Wir teilten sie wie ein schreckliches Geheimnis. Weiter heißt es aber dann, das stimmt doch nicht. Das stimmt doch gar nicht, denke ich. Nicht vor meinen Augen. Warum ewig nah? Warum ewig fern? Es sind genau acht Tage. Warum ein Geheimnis? Es war nichts Geheimnis dran. Das ist große Literatur, weil hier die Literatur über sich selbst nachdenkt und hier ein Autor begreift, dass man nur mit höchster Aufrichtigkeit sich dem eigentlich Undarstellbaren nähern kann. Und dass all das, wo man sagt, ich mache da jetzt mal eine tolle Szene, beschreibe die Dramatik in der Schule, wie dort um sich geschossen wurde, dass das genau den Punkt verfehlt. Und diese literarische Annäherung empfehle ich jedem. Es gibt auch überraschend humorvolle Szenen darin. Nicht nur, wenn dieser Autor über sein eigenes Schreiben stolpert, sondern vor allem auch, wenn er so das Alltägliche mit hineinbringt. Denn tatsächlich ist man ja nicht nur traumatisierter oder nicht nur der Schriftsteller, der über seinen Roman nachdenkt. Also für mich ein ganz großartiges Buch, Die Ausweichschule.
Sehr gut. Es hat ja dann 20 Jahre gedauert, bis sie mal ein Sozialarbeiter hatten an Guttenberg Gymnasium. Also mussten erst noch zwei Schülergenerationen durch, bis es dann mal so, ach so, ja, gibt es was aufzuarbeiten. Ich weiß noch damals, das war ja ein halbes Jahr nach dem 11. September. 11. September, so, okay, das ist halt ein Thema. Aber schon am 12. September, müsst ihr da so quatschen, ja. Also die Lehrer sind einfach so drüber hinweggegangen. Für die war das halt so Nachrichten erleben. Und die Schüler so, was ist denn hier los? Da fliegt ein Flugzeug in den Hochhaus. Und es hat dann eine Weile gedauert, bis dann unser Sozialkundelehrer mal so anfing, okay, ja, ich habe jetzt mal jemanden Gast eingeladen, der ist ab und zu im arabischen Raum, der kann ja was erzählen. Wie auch immer, und hat dann so ein bisschen improvisiert in Sozialkundeunterricht zu diesen, gerade tagesaktuellen, aber noch nicht im Lehrplan, vorhandenen Themen gemacht. Und dann passierte das in Erfurt. Und sehr viele Lehrer bei uns, also Jena, Erfurt ist jetzt nicht so weit auseinander, die waren also, die haben zusammen studiert.
Du warst in Jena.
Genau, und die kannten sicher alle. Das heißt, bei uns sind dann relativ viele Lehrer einfach wirklich monatelang im Trauerfloor rumgelaufen. Und manchmal, wenn du einen Stift fallen gelassen hast, sind die Lehrer zusammengezuckt. Weil sie dachten, jetzt kommt der nächste Angriff. Da hab ich auch schon gedacht, ja, du hast auf der einen Seite ein Flugzeug, fliegt in dein Hochhaus, 3000 Tote und die ganze Welt weiß, jetzt kommt Krieg und so. Und die Erwachsenen im Raum so, ja, Nachrichten halt so. Kann man dann irgendwann abgehakt. Aber wenn so was im Nahfeld passiert, Megatrauma, also wirklich Krass-Trauma. Und das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht, weil er beschreibt jetzt, wir anderthalb Jahre lang Gruppentherapie, er als Elfjähriger und so weiter. Also wenn der Wadepool in Syrien ist und sagt, das sieht hier aus wie 1945, dann diskutieren ausschließlich Erwachsene in Deutschland, ob das jetzt bedeutet, dass der März seine Abschiebeagenda ändern muss oder was, Herr Römer und so. Statt einfach zu sagen, nee, wollen wir jetzt nicht erst mal zehn Jahre lang Moratorium machen, dann mal gucken, was der Literaturbetrieb so an Opfererzählung bringt und dann mal eine Lageeinschätzung machen. Nein, es muss sofort ein Robin-Alexander-Podcast her, der uns nochmal erklärt, also das Wadepool und März ganz eng beieinander und das ändert gar nichts und die sollen sich mal nicht so, die CDU-Fraktion soll jetzt mal, bitte, bitte, ich bin hier der Regierungssprecher.
Tagesordnung nach drei Minuten wieder.
Also es ist wirklich schlimm. Du stimmst mir zu, das ist ein Dienstleister-Podcast.
Ja.
Wir lesen Bücher für Leute, die sich für Bücher interessieren, vielleicht nicht zum Lesen kommen oder sagen hier nochmal ein Aspekt, da nochmal ein Aspekt, wie auch immer. Und manchmal adressieren wir sie so und sagen, die Journalisten sollten mal darauf schauen. Ich möchte jetzt einen Text besprechen, der ist natürlich für uns alle interessant, aber für einen ganz spezifisch, und das ist Matthias Döpfner, denn er saß bei Paul Ronzheimer im Podcast und sagte, so eine Frage zu Trump und hier und da, und können sie mal ein Lagebild geben? Sie sind jetzt hier in meinem Podcast, haben sich eingeladen und so, wenn sie doch so redselig sind.
Ich lese mal vor, weil es mir gerade hier angezeigt wurde, was die Kollegin von der Zeit, aber auch vorhin mal bei der Welt Mariam Lau geschrieben hat, auf meinen Hinweis, dass jetzt so ähnlich kommentiert wird. Sie sagt, unvorstellbar jemandem den Friedensnobelpreis zu geben, der seinen eigenen Bürgern Soldaten auf den Hals hetzt, wenn ihre Städte von der falschen Partei regiert werden. Ja, wie blickst du darauf?
Also, die innenpolitischen Dinge kann ich nicht wirklich hinreichend beurteilen. Für mich ist die Rechtsstaatlichkeit die wichtigste und unverhandelbarste Grundbedingung der freien und offenen Gesellschaft. Und wann immer da missbräuchlich herumgewerkelt wird, hört bei mir die Toleranz auf.
So, die Rechtsstaatlichkeit, wenn da drin herumgewerkelt wird, hört die Toleranz auf.
Und das findet er jetzt bei Trump gar nicht.
Aber ansonsten kann er das noch nicht ganz einschätzen mit Trump. Das ist ja wie der Besprecher da im Repräsentantenhaus, der einfach sagt, ja, sie haben ja quasi gerade vorgelesen, was der Präsident getwittert hat. Aber ich habe von der Diskussion noch nichts mitgekriegt. So, ja. Und dann ist er immer. So, also. Robin, nicht Robin Alexander, den meine ich natürlich immer mit, ja, sondern hier Matthias Döpfner. In der New York Times, die wir alle schätzen und lieben, steht ein Text, in dem behauptet wird, wie wir jetzt gleich ermitteln, dass es mit der Rechtsstaatlichkeit gerade nicht so weit her ist in Amerika, sondern dass da rumgevorwärkt wird und er hört die Toleranz natürlich auf. In the Trump Presidency, the Rules Are Vague, also Vage und that might be the point. Das könnte Absicht sein, also dass man Rechtsstaatlichkeit gerade so ein bisschen schlaft. Der Text ist von Matthew Purdy und er ist sehr, sehr gut und sehr, sehr lang. Er beginnt wie folgt. Im vergangenen Juli, also diesen Juli, hat ein Bundesrichter namens William C. Young die Gelegenheit genutzt, er sollte nämlich über die Trump-Verordnung zum Thema, wie passiert hier irgendwas und so, es ging um Kram. Und er hat diese Gelegenheit genutzt, eine 103-seitige vernichtende Urteilsbegründung der Zürich zu schreiben, wie Trump Politik macht. Also der Anlassfall war, wie werden Forschungsgelder vergeben, in dem Falle ans National Institute of Health. Denn Forschungsgelder sollte eigentlich einen Antrag, dann gibt es eine Regel, wonach der bewilligt wird oder nicht. Und damit bestimmt. Und dieser Yang geht jetzt hier hart ins Gericht, weil es wahllose Streichungen gibt, Zitat, völlig unbegründete Behauptungen, beispielsweise zum Thema Rasse und Geschlecht. Plötzlich wirken so in dieses, kriegt jetzt irgendwer Forschungsgelder zum, hängt es davon ab, ob irgendwas zu Rasse und Geschlecht in diesem Text mit drin steht und so. Und all diese Bemühungen um...
Also bedeutet, wenn Race and Gender dort vorkommen, dann wird das nicht bewilligt. Ja, das ist ja diese neue...
Sobald jemand schreibt, ich will was für Frauengesundheit tun, fühlen sich die Männer diskriminiert. Und dann sagt die Trump-Regierung, Forschungsgelder sind gestrichen. So, und das haben wir natürlich in vielerlei Hinsicht, gerade in Bezug auf DEI, also Diversität, Gleichberechtigung und Inklusion, war ja schon große Programmatik. Nur, dass es in der Programmatik war, wird gar nicht anerkannt, sondern es ist einfach DEI-Boomer. So, da wird gar nicht mehr auf Details geschaut, sondern da wird einfach grundsätzlich gesagt, es gibt jetzt Regierungsbeamte und die haben beschlossen, das muss einfach alles ausgerottet werden. Also alles, was DEI ist, wird jetzt ausgerottet. Antiphasen, internationale Terrororganisationen, da ist doch völlig klar, was damit gemeint ist. Also in Deutschland auch Stadtbild. Wieso diskutieren wir darüber? Jeder weiß doch, was er gemeint hat. So, und wenn man dann sagt, nee, bitte Definition, oder die SPD kommt und sagt, können wir eine Tagung dazu machen, dann ist gleich wieder, dann dampft es. So, wir haben es also mit unwillkürlicher und unbeständiger arbitrary und capricious Gesetzgebung zu tun, gegen die hier angegangen wird von dem Richter. Und der Text verweist jetzt auf die Unbestimmtheitsdoktrin, die Wagnisdoktrin, die nämlich explizit in der amerikanischen Verfassung drinsteht. Es gibt eine ganz knallharte Trennlinie zwischen Demokratie und Autokratie, und das ist, wenn das Publikum weiß, was die Politik von einem will, ist es Demokratie. Und wenn man einfach, keine Ahnung, was sagt der starke Mann da, dann ist es halt eine Autokratie. Und genau dagegen wollte man sich ja wehren, als man sagte, wir sagen uns jetzt vom britischen Königshaus los. Und dadurch entsteht nun eine neue Machtdoktrin, eine neue Machtdynamik durch diese Ungewissheit, die da drinsteckt. Keiner weiß mehr, ob man außerhalb oder innerhalb der Zone eines Verstoßes gerade steht, bei dem, was man im Alltag so tut. Und das ist insbesondere interessant, da Trump als Privatmann, bevor er jetzt die zweite Amtszeit hatte, hat er ja dieses Gerichtsverfahren am Hals wegen Aufbewahrung von Verschlusssachedokumenten im Klo von Maro Lago. Und da hat sein eigener Anwalt, Todd Blanch, der heute stellvertretender Generalstaatsanwalt ist, gesagt, das Gesetz, das hier gegen meinen Mandanten verwendet wird, ist vage und verleiht der Exekutive eine uneingeschränkte und völlig subjektiven Ermessungsspielraum bei der Durchsitzung. Das ist eines der Hauptübel, zu dessen Vermeidung die Unbestimmtheitsdoktrin eingeführt wurde. Also Trump hat sich vor anderthalb Jahren noch selbst explizit darauf berufen, dass ja die Regierung eigentlich diese Unbestimmtheitsdoktrin beachten muss. Und was erleben wir jetzt? Charlie Kirk wird erschossen und der Tod wird zum Anlass genommen, um einfach grundsätzlich, JD. Vance tritt auf und sagt, alles was hier Gewalt schürt, erleichtert oder selber ausübt, ist aber jetzt verboten. Und jeder so, was ist Gewalt? Was heißt ausüben? Was heißt erleichtern? Was heißt schüren? Völlige Unklarheit. Und diese Unbestimmtheit erzeugt natürlich Furcht. Also genau das, weshalb Matthias Döpfner da so alarmiert ist. Genau das ist die Realität. Denn sie ist, wie er hier schreibt, das gewünschte Ergebnis dieser Art von Politik. Sie zielt darauf ab, dass es jetzt einen vorauseilenden Gehorsam gibt und billig in Kauf genommen wird, dass die Demokratie da einfach unter die Räder gerät. Wir haben es also jetzt mit einer neuen Angst zu tun in allen öffentlichen Einrichtungen, die irgendwann mal die IProgramme oder von Forschungsgeldern abhängen, Unternehmensvorstände und Klassenzimmer. Und mit Klassenzimmern sind im Grunde alle öffentlichen Bildungseinrichtungen, also Universitäten, genannt. Der Oberste Gerichtshof hat natürlich in diesen Fragen immer zugunsten der Regierung bisher entschieden und sich damit, wie hier steht es auch gegen, die eigenen Gründerväter gestellt, die eben sagten, warnend, aufbauend auf dem englischen Recht, die so inkohärent sind, dass sie nicht verstanden werden können, brauchen wir eigene. Können nicht einfach hier der König kommt, drübergeschippert, macht eine Ansage, fährt wieder, und dann gilt einfach irgendwas. Sondern gerade das ist die Unabhängigkeitsidee, dass wir es jetzt selber regeln, was bei uns gilt. Und historisch ist das wahnsinnig interessant. Es gab dann Anti-Vagabondier-Gesetze in Amerika, nach dem Bürgerkrieg zum Beispiel, was bedeutete, es gab zwar keine Sklaven mehr, aber es waren ja immer noch viele Schwarze. Und wenn man diese Schwarzen auf der Straße angetroffen hat und sie streifenden umher, die Definition war, sie konnten Zweck und Ziel ihrer kleinen Öffentlichkeits-, ich bin auf der Straße, gerade nicht nennen, hatte man das Recht, sie faktisch wieder zu versklaven. Denn Vagabunden ist hier nicht. Also man hat zwar die Sklaverei abgeschafft, aber damit gleichzeitig den Vagabunden plötzlich erfunden, der nicht einfach zweck- und ziellos über die Straße laufen darf. Neil Gorsuch, Trumps erster eigener Verfassungsrichter, den er damals miteinander hat, hat 2018 über vage Gesetze laden zur Willkür oder zur willkürlichen Macht eingeschrieben. Ein Zitat aus seinem Schreiben. Er hat einen Schriftsatz, in dem er schrieb, eine Regierung der Gesetze und nicht der Menschen kann diese willkürliche Macht niemals tolerieren. Also diese Unterscheidung, Autokratie, Demokratie, Gesetze oder Menschen. Rule of Law oder eben Rule of Man. Also wenn man Gostichs Texte selber nimmt, der jetzt sozusagen auf Gnaden dieses starken Mannes ihm immer wieder diese Freiheiten einräumen muss, muss man sagen, du hast doch selber Schriftstätze gemacht, in denen du es, du kennst ja, deine Verfassung bist ja offenbar nicht ohne Grund der Verfassungsrichter. Naja, es gibt hier verschiedene Phänomene. Diese Angriffe auf DEI zum Beispiel. Das läuft jetzt mittlerweile so, dass Amy Parsons, die Präsidentin der Colorado State, Universität, ein Schreiben an ihren eigenen Campus schreibt, in dem sie sagt, obwohl wir zuversichtlich sind, dass die Institution derzeit dem Gesetz entspricht, also obwohl wir hier gerade das Beste tun, muss man gar nicht darauf warten, dass jetzt irgendwie Trump, irgendwer und so weiter, sondern es macht Stephen Miller selbst, also der Vizestabschef, Stephen Miller, uns allen bekannt, hat eine Organisation, America First Legal, die ihrerseits jetzt rumsondiert und dann solche Schriften, also Briefe schreibt, wie zum Beispiel an die Universität, um einfach zu sagen, es scheint, dass die zusätzlichen Schritte der Universität lediglich Oberfläche-Reorganisationen von Titel und Programmen sind, die darauf abzielen, eine Entdeckung durch den Bund zu vermeiden. Also noch bevor überhaupt die Bundesregierung sagt, wir machen es jetzt zum offiziellen Ermittlungsfall, kommt Stephen Miller, der einfach mit Briefkopf und schickt schon mal so einen Brief und sagt, ihr seid hier auf dem Radar, wir haben euch auf dem Kicker. Das ist so evil, das ist so jenseits von dieser Rechtsstaatlichkeit, die hier gerade noch. Der Text beantwortet natürlich auch die Frage, wo kommt denn diese ganze Ideenreichtum her, mit dem jetzt hier so die Knüppel zwischen die Beine geworfen werden? Ja, das ist der Umgang von Russland und Chinas gegen NGOs, Bildungseinrichtungen und so weiter und so fort. Also sozusagen eins zu eins übernommen. Stephen Miller geht ja selbst jetzt soweit, zu sagen, die Demokratische Partei sei eine inländische extremistische Organisation. Antifa ist seit dieser Woche durch Marco Rubio, Trump guckt ihn ja so an in so einer Sitzung einfach, könntest du das machen? Die einfach zu einer internationalen Terrororganisation. Und Marco Rubio so, ja klar. So und damit ist das einfach geregelt. Hier steht jetzt im Text, nach Kirks Ermordung sagte der Präsident, die Regierung werde die politische Gewalt bekämpfen, indem sie gegen die radikale Linke vorgeht. Erwähnte einige große demokratische Spender und sagte unverblümt, Zitat Donald Trump, Gewalt auf der rechten Seite ist mir völlig egal. Also das ist einfach, das ist unglaublich, was hier passiert. Und ja, offenbar gibt es noch Leute wie Matthias Döpfner, die sich so, ja, also.
Muss man mal genauer hinschauen bei Gelegenheit.
Genau, irgendwann wird es ja mal und so. Nein, also Anwälte, ja, diese.
Ich meine, was ist das überhaupt auch? Da könnte ja Ronsheimer eben ganz klar nochmal das in drei Minuten auflassen, was da vor sich geht.
Ich finde, das sollte alles selbstverständlich sein. Da muss man gar nichts erklären.
Aber so viel immer zur freien Rede. Das ist schon interessant, wenn Ronsheimer mit seinem Chef sprechen muss, dann kann halt nicht viel kommen.
Ja, also diese Unbestimmtheit, die man da jetzt drinne hat in diesem System verwandelt, dass also alle Gesetze, die da jetzt involviert sind, in ein Schwert, das über den Köpfen der Bürger baumelt, sagt Timothy Zenderfur vom Goldwater Institute. Und es sind schon die Konservativen des Thinktanks. Und das betrifft vor allem alle NGOs, also in Sachen Antifa und so einfach alle Bildungseinrichtungen und eben auch, wird auch nochmal im Text betont, diese Anwaltskanzleien. Also es wird vor allem auch auf Anwaltskanzleien eingeschlagen, weil das natürlich die sind, die man dann immer mal wieder in Anspruch nimmt, wenn man glaubt, man würde hier gerade vom Rechtsstaat ein bisschen fehl verhalten und so. Und nein, also da wird wirklich systematisch die Dings zugemacht. Es wird dann noch beschrieben, wie die landesweit jetzt diese neuen, gibt's in deiner Klasse einen Lehrer, der mal so und so redet, also solche Denozilationsportale. Hast du jemand in deiner Nachbarschaft, den du gerne mal und so? Also es ist wirklich, in Amerika ist es gerade nicht gut.
Wir gehen zu einem Artikel, der im Telegraph erschienen ist von Joe Barnes. Der beschäftigt sich mit den jungen Ukrainern, die ausreisen gerade. Es ist ja so, dass mit Beginn des Krieges im Februar 2022 es 18- bis 60-jährigen Männern untersagt war, die Ukraine zu verlassen. Wir wissen auch, die Pflicht für den Militärdienst wurde herabgesenkt von 27 auf 25 Jahre dann irgendwann. Aber jetzt ist es so, dass Männer zwischen 18 und 22 Jahren die Ukraine verlassen dürfen. Und das tun sie in großer Zahl. Der polnische Grenzschutz gab an, dass seit der Lockerung der Vorschriften zur Sicherstellung eine ausreichenden Zahl von Soldaten in Kiew Ende August 99.000 ukrainische Männer im Alter zwischen 18 und 22 Jahren die Grenzen den wichtigsten Weg aus dem Land überquert haben. Möglicherweise sind sie ja noch in anderer Richtung, aber diese knapp 100.000 hat man jetzt schon mal. Zum Vergleich, die gesamte britische Armee hat etwa 70.000 Soldaten. Nun ist es so, dass man diese Freiheit gewährt hat, weil man sagte, ja, wenn wir das so freiwillig machen, dann werden die ja vielleicht auch freiwillig wieder zurückkommen, wenn ihr Militärdienst beginnt. Warum die glauben, dass sie dann freiwillig wieder an die Männer rankommen, damit sie so merken, die Ukraine ist ein offenes Land, in dem man, dass man auch verlassen kann, ich habe keine Ahnung. Außerdem heißt es hier im Text, hoffte man, dass dadurch Familien davon abgehalten würden, und das scheint mir jetzt plausibler, ihre minderjährigen Kinder vor ihrem 18. Geburtstag ins Ausland zu schicken, um zu vermeiden, dass sie in Zukunft eingezogen werden, was laut Zelensky im August die Bindung zwischen ukrainischen Jugendlichen und ihrem Land zerstörte. Also das hat schon im großen Maße wohl stattgefunden, haben wir auch nie was zu gelesen, dass also unter 18-Jährige von den Familien nach draußen geschaffen worden, damit sie ja nicht eingezogen werden können. Also so viel zu dem immer wieder verbreiteten Narrativ, alle wollen kämpfen. Zu den Toten und Verwundeten, ja, ist schwer zu sagen. Auf dem Schlachtfeld hat Russland in diesem Jahr täglich 1000 Tote und Verwundete zu beklagen. Das weiß man dann sicher. Wie sieht es aber auf der ukrainischen Seite aus? Nach Angaben des in Washington ansässigen Center for Strategic and International Studies sollen seit Kriegsbeginn zwischen 60.000 und 100.000 ukrainische Soldaten getötet worden sein. Vermutlich konservativ geschätzt, würde ich mal noch hinzufügen. Auf Deutschland kommt dieser Artikel auch zu sprechen. In Deutschland, wo Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz versucht, gegen Lachsse-Migrationsregeln vorzugehen, stieg die Zahl der ukrainischen Männer im Alter von 18 bis 22 Jahren, die jede Woche einreisen, bis Mitte September von 19 auf 1.000.
Von 19 auf 1.000?
Auf 1.000, ja. Jede Woche. Bis Oktober war sie laut dem Bayerischen Nachrichtensender BR24 auf 1.400 bis 1.800 pro Woche angestiegen. Das heißt also, die kommen nach Deutschland. Und jetzt ist der Artikel auch schon fast vorbei. Ich zitiere nur noch den befragten Jürgen Hart, der ist außenpolitischer Sprecher der CDU. Der wurde von Politico befragt dazu und er sagt, Wir haben kein Interesse daran, dass junge ukrainische Männer ihre Zeit in Deutschland verbringen, anstatt ihr Land zu verteidigen. Die Ukraine trifft ihre eigenen Entscheidungen, aber die jüngste Gesetzesänderung hat zu einer Auswanderungswelle geführt, mit der wir uns befassen müssen.
Ah ja.
So viel zum Thema demokratischer Faschismus etc. Ich will noch einmal daran erinnern, 2015 war es der absolute Konsens, bis auf AfD zu sagen, dass Menschen vor Krieg fliehen dürfen. Nur AfD-Heinis bei Facebook hatten irgendwelche Memes gebastelt, von echte Männer verteidigen ihr Land gerade dann, wenn Krieg ist, und haben dann ukrainische Flüchtlinge gegen irgendwelche Soldaten in Uniformen abgebildet. Heute sind wir jetzt in einem Diskurs, wo das schon in der Mitte angekommen ist, dass man also nicht mehr gestattet, dass Männer aus Kriegsgebieten fliehen dürfen. Das ist wirklich irre. Aber ja, hier wird es ganz offen ausgesprochen.
Sehr gut. Ich möchte es trifftig machen, da wir heute darüber sprachen, kurz auch Methodenkritik zu dem kommenden Text. Er behandelt ein wahnsinnig interessantes Thema, gerade für diejenigen, die ihn publizieren, diesen Text, nämlich Journalisten. Er kommt von Christoph Scheuermann, Jahrgang 77, seit 2009 beim Spiegel. Wir kennen, wenn wir ihn googeln, nur Bilder von ihm mit Journalisten-Sacko, das natürlich einen Ellenbogen-Lederschoner wie auch immer hat. Natürlich lässt man sich in mit verschränkten Armen fotografieren. Natürlich lächelt man leicht. Natürlich hat man ein blaues Hemd an und der oberste Knopf ist ein bisschen offen. Denn so sehen Journalisten aus. Dieser Journalist, Christoph Scheuermann, dachte sich, ich fahre mal nach Norwegen, da gibt es eine Lokalzeitung, da arbeiten KI-Pioniere. Statt aber dann einfach den Schalter umzulegen und zu sagen, vielleicht sollte ich auch ein KI-Pionier werden, muss ich die Frage stellen, was ist aus der Relozio-Sache geworden, lieber Spiegel? Warum ist hier weiter unnützer Kram auf eurer Seite zu lesen? Ich lese also kurz, bevor wir dann rausschälen, was in dem Text interessant ist, stelle beispielhaft da, was einfach weg kann. Du bist ein großer Literatur-Fan. Es gibt die Belletristik, da ist das alles gut aufgehoben. Aber es geht um Lars-Adrian Gieske und der Text hier lautet, Lars-Adrian Gieske, ein jung wirkender Journalist. Was soll ich jetzt? Ist er doch älter als gedacht? Also, welcher Impressionismus soll mich jetzt hier beschäftigen? Ist der KI-Chef der Zeitung? Er hat eine Glatze. Cool. Einen Vollbart. Okay. Und wirkt mit seiner Goldrandbrille, dem hellen Hemd und den weiten Short wie der letzte Hipster vom Polarkreis. Okay, ich kann mir jetzt ungefähr vorstellen, was er meint. Vor ihm auf dem Tisch dampft ein Teller mit gekochten Garnelen aus der Bucht, die er in bemerkenswerder Geschwindigkeit von ihrer Schale befreit und in den Mund schiebt. René Utreberg ist 56, hat eine Glatze, trägt eine Leinenhose und ein helles Hemd. Er ist der Datenchef von e-Tromsö und sieht wie die ältere Version von Gieske aus. Ich weiß nicht, warum Leute sowas lesen. Es ist fern jeder. Es ist völliger Informationsmüll. Das kann einfach weg, wenn man diesen Text der KI gibt und sagt, gib mir einfach den Kern der Genese, dieser KI-Revolution, die im norwegischen Lokaljournalismus gibt. Kriegst du einfach drei wunderbare Absätze von Gemini, in denen alles steht. Außer wie diese Leute aussehen, was sie essen und wie sie es essen. Also lernen sie sich lieber, Spiegel, ja. Das ist, ich finde, eine geile Pointe, dass ihr ein Text über die KI, ja, die Überschrift des Textes lautet, diese norwegische Lokalzeitung hat den KI-Code geknackt. Ich frage den Spiegel, welchen Code habt ihr gerade mit diesem Text geknackt? Das ist so lame. Es ist unglaublich. Also gut, steigen wir jetzt in den Maschinenraum dieser KI-Revolution. Lassen wir also alles weg, was hier als, wir hängen so an unserer Reportage. Also, dieser Gieske ist ein sehr besonderer Journalist, denn er sagt Sätze wie, Excel, das Tabellenprogramm, ist ein Geschenk Gottes an Journalisten. Das kann sich ja jeder Journalist mal fragen. Im Moment, ich habe mal Excel, das ist doch kein Geschenk, das ist doch die Hölle. Aber es gibt Leute, die mögen das und er ist eben hier nachgegangen. Also, eine 127 Jahre alte Lokalzeitung in Norwegen mit 25.000 Lesern und nur 22 Journalisten muss ich halt überlegen, wie gehen wir mit unseren Ressourcen um? Wir haben doch von Gesetzeswegen große Datenregister, in denen zum Beispiel alle Immobilienverkäufe landesweit registriert werden. Jetzt müsste das nur mal jemand lesen. Also hat man sich überlegt, wir nehmen Norbert. Wer ist ein Norbert? Nachdem Chetjibiti kam und man feststellte, kann gar kein richtiges Norwegisch, gab es von der Uni Oslo in Zusammenarbeit mit Google ein Sprachmodell, Norbert, dass der norwegische Sprache mächtig ist und mit der man lesen konnte. Im großen Stile, PDF-Dokumente, die vom Staat, was weiß ich, wie das Amtsblatt da aussieht, veröffentlicht wurden. Also sagte sich Gieske, ich baue jetzt hier ein GIN, nennt er das, D-J-I-N-N, es ist eine Abkürzung für, naja, Daten, Journalismus, Initiative, wie auch immer. Das Data Journalism Interface for News Gathering and Notifications, da steckt schon alles drin. Man zählt darauf ab, gezielt zu lesen. Der Bot hat also täglich 100 Dokumente gelesen, Norbert hat sie ausgefiltert nach den Kriterien, die man hatte. Lama, das Sprachmodell, hat dann eine Zusammenfassung geschrieben und IBM hat dabei geholfen, ein Datenextraktionssystem zu bauen, sodass man aus den 100 Datensätzen einfach so eine kleine Tabelle übersichtlich bekam, wer hat denn hier gerade was gekauft und wie und überhaupt. Denn hohe Mietpreisen und so weiter, über allen Themen, auch am Polarkreis. Und dann hat er diesem System ein Interface vorangestellt und hat seinen Kollegen gesagt, hier, verwendet das doch. Und seitdem sind alle sehr glücklich da, weil sie sehr relevante Sachen für die lokalen Leute da aufbereiten können, ohne die ganze Zeit diese Amtsblätter lesen zu müssen. Das haben sie dann so ein bisschen hocheskaliert. Die GIN unterstützt heute 37 Redaktionen, also 37 lokale, wir haben es immer schön angepasst, liest wöchentlich 5000 Dokumente. Und nun geht es darum, nachdem man es regional ausgebreitet hat, auch die Themenvielfalt ein bisschen zu vergrößern, vielleicht noch mehr Regionen, vielleicht ein großes Ding draus zu machen. Und ich denke mir so, warum machen das nicht alle Deutschen Redaktionen? bundestag.de, also das ist einfach eine Datenbank. Da sind alle Reden drin, kann man wunderbare, semantische Vergleiche von allen möglichen machen. Diese Register, wer kauft hier welches Grundstück, liegt alles bereit. Ich habe das jetzt selber an mir so ein bisschen festgestellt, es gibt ja jetzt so Automatisierungstool, N8N und so wahnsinnig cooles Zeug, wo einfach klar ist, jetzt spricht alles mit allem. Meine Uhr spricht mit Excel-Tabellen. Bücher, die irgendwo publiziert werden, sprechen mit meiner Notion-Datenbank. Also es gibt gar nichts Obskures mehr, will ich damit sagen. Also wir können jetzt eine richtige Entfaltung, eine Entwicklung von neuen journalistischen Zugriffen machen. Das Letzte, was mich interessiert ist, was irgendwer mit welcher Geschwindigkeit ist. Und das, was mich wahnsinnig interessiert, ist das, was die da machen. Warum macht das nicht jeder?
Jedoch ist das ja der Journalismus, den wir immer vorfinden, nicht nur jetzt bei diesen Reportagen, sondern dass man Dokumente hat, in denen alles drin steht. Wenn man einen Satz zitieren will, kann man den nehmen. Aber nein, ich treffe mich mit der Person, die das Dokument verfasst hat, morgen noch mal zum Kaffee trinken, um den einen Originalton von ihr zu bekommen, den ich auf meinem Smartphone dann habe, den ich transkribiere, dann in meinen Artikel einfüge. Weil so eine unglaubliche Authentizität hergestellt ist. Quatsch. Man könnte einfach sagen, da sind die Daten, nehmen wir sie doch.
Ich denke mir auch mittlerweile, ich habe zum Beispiel kürzlich Jürgen Kaube in einem Podcast gehört, über Stadtbild-Diskussionen. Ich habe mich einfach nur darüber geärgert, dass er 20 Minuten lang so einen Metadiskurs anstrengend damit hat. Nein, wieso machen wir schon wieder so eine aufgeregte Diskussion? Man kann doch auch mal gutwillig so reingehen und so. Und ich denke mir so, alter, kannst du mal kurz reflektieren, wenn du 20 Minuten brauchst, um uns zu erklären, was dein Altersgenosse Merz meinte, wie sollen wir normale Leute das dann verstehen? So, das muss doch Indikator dafür sein. Ne, Momentchen mal, seit 20 Minuten reden wir in dem Podcast darüber. Offenbar gibt es doch noch andere Fragestellungen zu diesem Thema. So, ich will mich nur über diesen lustig machen, über diesen Take. Was mache ich? Ich lade aus der Podcast-App, in der ich das gerade gehört habe, auf dem Fahrrad die Datei zu Ploat. Ploat macht mir einen Transkript, es läuft automatisch zu Gemini und ich sage, gib mir zu diesem und jenen Thema die O-Töne von Kaube und ich komme zu Hause ansteigen vom Fahrrad. Aber die Zitate liegen da. Ich muss nur noch meine drei lustigen Formulierungen dazu finden und zack, habe ich einen Text generiert, in dem einfach das, was ich mitteilen wollte, ich habe ihn mir von der Seele geschrieben. Im Treppenhaus quasi. Warum geht nicht jeder Journalist so an diese Sachen ran? Warum ist Herr Schürmann nach Dings geflogen, um da irgendwie mit den Leuten zuzugucken, wie die essen, schreibt uns dann auch noch auf, wie die essen, statt einfach zu sagen, okay, dann essen wir noch schnell, dann geht es zur Sache. Nein, dass die da langsam oder schnell ihre Buscheln essen, ist Top-Thema dieses Textes so. Also kann man das nicht wenigstens, wenn man schon über den KI-Code im Journalismus irgendwie der Redaktion sagt, liebe Spiegel-Online-Reaktionen, können wir dem Text so eine Zusammenfassung voranstellen, sodass einfach der Wissenstransfer des Relevanten ein bisschen besser funktioniert oder irgendwas, ja. Aber diese Techno-Aversität im Journalismus und dieses ewige Rumgelaber ist mittlerweile wirklich nicht mehr zu tolerieren.
Man kann sich nicht nur an der Börse verspekulieren, sondern auch bei Counter-Strike, einem beliebten Spiel.
Danebenschießen oder was?
In der GamePro spricht Chris Werian darüber oder er schreibt darüber viel mehr. Es hatte einen Crash gegeben. Zwischenzeitlich sind die Counter-Strike 2 Skins, also es gibt offenbar…
Wo hat es einen Crash gegeben? Hol uns noch mal ab.
Also es hat einen Crash gegeben in dem Spiel. Wir haben ja schon mal über Roblox gesprochen und über andere solche Dinge. Wir wissen ja, da kann man Skins kaufen. Das heißt, ich will da eine besondere Waffe haben und dann kann ich die mir erspielen oder ich kann sie vielleicht auf einem Sekundärmarkt kaufen, dass ich mit dem einen Schwert ausgestattet das machen kann.
Also hat einen Wertverlust-Crash von diesen Sachen gegeben in dem Spiel?
So, innerhalb des Spiels. Und zwar einen Wertverlust von 3 Milliarden Dollar. Ein Hörer schickte mir diesen Artikel und sagte, ich soll mir das mal ansehen. Der Tiefpunkt scheint jetzt erst mal erreicht zu sein. Inzwischen hat sich das alles ein bisschen eingependelt. Auf 3,3 Milliarden Dollar ist das wieder hochgegangen. Aber was ist jetzt eigentlich hier passiert? Werian schreibt, der Tiefpunkt des Crashs scheint erreicht worden zu sein und der Kurs sich leicht zu erholen. Die vorherigen Verluste wiegen aber dennoch schwer. Eigentlich ist es kaum zu glauben. Virtuelle Skins haben in Counter-Strike 2 einen so hohen Wert, dass der gesamte Markt vor nicht einmal einer Woche einen neuen Rekord erreichte. Auf ganze 6 Milliarden Dollar wurde das digitale Vermögen der Spielerinnen geschätzt. Also die haben da ihre Wallets mit den Skins und dann sagte man, insgesamt müssen das 6 Milliarden sein.
Dann ist ja 3 Milliarden echt viel.
Dann hat sich aber dieser Wert halbiert. Was ist geschehen? Das Spiel Counter-Strike verteilt Loot-Boxen als Belohnung. Und diese können ausschließlich mit einem Schlüssel im Wert von 2,19 Euro geöffnet werden. Spielt er offenbar erfolgreich, bekommt er so eine virtuelle Box. Und in dieser Box sind dann Waffen mit unterschiedlichen Wertigkeiten, Mustern und Zuständen. Am begehrtesten sind Messer und Handschuhe, da sie die niedrigsten Drop-Raten haben, hat sie schein am seltensten davor zu kommen. So interpretiere ich das jetzt mal. Ich weiß, dass das Spiel gibt, aber ich habe es nie gespielt. Und dann gibt es noch besondere Varianten, die können auf einen Wert von über eine Million Dollar pro Skin steigen. Jetzt ist es aber zu einem Crash gekommen, weil Valve, das ist das Unternehmen dahinter, das Softwareunternehmen von Counter-Strike, hat ein Update veröffentlicht, das ließ diese Preise für Messer und Handschuhe einbrechen. Und zwar können ab jetzt häufiger getrobte Covered Skins gegen die außergewöhnlichen Gegenstände eingetauscht werden. Also man kommt jetzt wohl leichter an die Dinger dran. Die Preise dieses Convert-Items, also man kann sich zwischen 22 Euro jetzt mit einer höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit, nämlich die liegt bei 1 zu 5 oder so, kann man sich jetzt diese Messer und Handschuhe kaufen. Das bedeutet, ein Investment, schreibt er hier, von 10 bis 100 Euro reichte innerhalb der vergangenen Stunden aus, um an ein zuvor mehrere tausend Euro teures Item zu kommen. Bedeutet also für all die, die dann noch viel Geld ausgegeben haben, ein enormer Wertverlust. Also man müsste sich mal vorstellen, jetzt würde sich einfach die Menge der Bitcoins verzehnfachen oder so, wäre auch ein Problem. Innerhalb von 29 Stunden sank der Gesamtwert aller Counter Strike Skins um 2,4 Milliarden Dollar. Viele Messer und Handschuhvarianten sind im Schnitt um 75 Prozent günstiger geworden. Wir haben es also hier mit einem eigentlich Online-Konsino in meinen Augen zu tun. Diese Kritik gibt es auch. Es wird auch vorgeworfen durch diese Lootbox, dass man die bekommen kann und dann kann man da hoffen, dass da was drin ist, würde man junge Leute in die Spielsucht treiben. Deshalb hat wohl Counter-Strike gesagt, da machen wir es jetzt ein bisschen zugänglicher. Also man kommt leichter daran. Die Verknappung ist nicht mehr ganz so stark. Das hat aber dann für diese Verluste gesorgt. Da heißt es für viele Content-Creator steht jetzt schon fest, dass Counter-Strike 2 von der Maßnahme einen großen Schaden davon tragen könnte. In einem Video erklärt der YouTuber Anomaly beispielsweise, dass Counter-Strike 2 seine Ansicht damit gestorben sei. Er selbst hat laut eigenen Angaben einen Schaden von mindestens eine halbe Million Dollar davon getragen. Aber nicht nur Großanleger sind vom Crash betroffen, so beschreibt etwa der beliebte deutsche Streamer TriluxXE in einer Reaktion, dass ein Zuschauer von ihm vor wenigen Tagen mit Glück ein 16.000 Dollar teures Messer gezogen hat und das ist aber jetzt nur noch 4.000 Euro wert. Das heißt, dieser Wunsch mit Spielen reich zu werden, dazu spekulieren ist jetzt nicht unmöglich geworden, aber wir sehen auch hier wurde man wieder einmal enttäuscht, wie das so oft im Casino ist. Aber es ist ja unglaublich, dass jetzt nur ein einziges Spiel, wenn es da schon um 3 Milliarden geht, können wir schon denken, wie viel virtuelles Geld da unterwegs ist. Und auch da kann man hier sagen, dass ja alles nicht dienlich für Produktivität oder irgendetwas.
Ja, im Gegenteil.
Das ist im Gegenteil. Das ist dort irgendwo im Nimbus dieser Tech-Konzerne und der Plattformen, die diese Skin-Versteigerung anbieten.
Ganz normale, partikularistische Wertschöpfung, während das Gemeinwohl nur noch in dieser sakralen Überhöhung des Staates und so weiter, verendet. Okay, mein letzter Text. Is Having a Boyfriend Embarrassing Now? Stellen sich viele Fragen, also viele junge Frauen vor allem diese Fragen. Sollte man seinen Freund lieber verstecken, ist es peinlich, einen Freund zu haben. Denn wenn jemand schreibt sie, Chanté Joseph in der Vogue, wenn sie in den sozialen Medien jemanden, der von meinem Freund spricht, ist sofort schaltet sie stumm. Sie entfolgt nicht direkt, aber sie schaltet stumm. Und sie hasst nichts mehr als jemanden aus Spaß zu folgen. Also mit so einem kleinen Ah, dem folge ich mal und so. Und dann geht es gar nicht um diese Person, sondern nur noch um ihren Boyfriend. Also wenn sozusagen sie in die Irre geführt wird. Und sie kommt da auf, um ein Substack-Text zu sprechen, ihrer Lieblings-Substackerin. Die hat einen Text Boyfriendland geschrieben über dieses Phänomen. Das ist allerdings hinter Paywall. Ich hab's mir jetzt nicht gesagt, aber es hat 4000 Herzchen bekommen. Also ein Text, der auch Wallungen ausgelöst hat. Und dieses Phänomen, das hier kritisiert wird, ist, dass Online-Identitäten von Frauen sich sehr häufig um deren Partner drehen. Statt einfach die Frauen selbst in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken. Und Frauen werden wohl noch immer für ihre Fähigkeit, einen Mann zu finden und zu halten, mit einem höheren sozialen Status und Lob belohnt. Und genau das wird jetzt quasi uncool. Also auf die Frage der Großmutter hin, wann ist denn hier heiratet und so. Und dann sagt man, hä, wie, was heiratet, dann sagen wir mal zu. Wir haben neue Coolheitsdefinitionen. So, wir haben es also hier mit einer deutlichen Veränderung zu tun, wie sie schreibt, aus dieser letzten Zeit. Und es gibt immer häufiger Frauen, die sich so für subtilere Zeichen entscheiden, wie zum Beispiel in dem Foto ist mal so eine Hand mit auf einem Lenkrad, die aber nicht ihre ist. Klirrende Gläser beim Abendessen werden gezeigt. Aber es hat nur so angedeutet, der Hinterkopf einer Person, ah ein Mann. Also man macht es nicht mehr ganz so deutlich, aber auch so halb versteckt. Frauen verdecken das Gesicht ihres Partners, wenn sie etwas posten, als wollten sie die Tatsache, dass er existiert, auslöschen, ohne ihn tatsächlich nicht zu posten.
Also man gibt sich nicht als Single aus.
Genau, man will so andeuten, ja ich bin nicht alleine, aber ich weiß auch, dass es cool wäre, oder dass der Hegemon jetzt so langsam sagt, vielleicht doch mal alleine probieren oder wie auch immer. Was hat das zu bedeuten? Schämen sich die Menschen jetzt für ihre Boyfriends? Oder steckt etwas komplizierteres dahinter? Ich sag gleich, der Text wird nicht sehr komplizierter, ja es ist jetzt keine große Analyse und so. Aber es ist doch ein kultureller Shift, der uns hier dargeboten wird, der unter dem Hashtag hetero-fatalismus schon relativ weit verbreitet ist. Frauen verständigen sich in den sozialen Medien darüber, wie man datet, ob man datet, warum man datet und wie gut es eigentlich ist, alles nicht zu machen. Und wenn überhaupt, dann nur, weil das das Leben bereichert, aber auf keinen Fall aus Gründen alter Statusvorstellung. Also wir haben ja diesen Shift der Gefühlswelt sozusagen, der strukturell jetzt nirgendwo ablesbar sein muss. Aber dieser Wandel in der Gefühlswelt, der ja so bedeutend ist, wie wir vorhin ein Buch lassen, den kann man jetzt hier sehen. Selbst die New York Times hat einen großen Text gemacht, The Trouble with Wanting Men, also den Ärger, den sich Frauen immer wieder einhandeln, weil sie der alten Idee, sie müssten einen Mann wollen, sich dann einhandeln. Das ist also durchaus ein großes Thema.
Bedeutet, dass im Prinzip Angela Merkel da schon eine Vorreiterin war, die dann wirklich nur zu ganz selten Gelegenheiten mal Herrn Sauer mitgenommen hat. Aber sonst hieß es selbst, es ist die Frau. Oder noch extremer, bei Dolly Parton, da ist ja jetzt auch der Mann vor einer Weile gestorben und manche waren ganz verblüfft, ach, wie Dolly Parton es verheiratet. Ja, seit 50 Jahren. Aber der Mann mag nicht so gerne Countrymusik und scheut auch die Öffentlichkeit. Und deswegen gibt es auch nie ein Bild mit ihm zusammen.
Genau. Also das finde ich auch wahnsinnig interessant, wie so Frauen, die jetzt so jenseits von Social Media, Medienöffentlichkeit haben. Weil Social Media greift nämlich noch dieses Phänomen. Und hier geht es um zwölf Jahre Beziehung. Frauen können sich nicht mal nach zwölf Jahren Beziehung darauf verlassen, dass sie nicht doch noch mal eine Aufräumaktion starten müssen, dass nämlich eine Beziehung doch nicht klappt, aber plötzlich ist das Social Media Profil ja voll mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die sie dann im Nachhinein immer wieder präsent haben. Und erklären müssen und so.
So funktioniert ja der ganze Bild und bunter Journalismus. Die schauen ja den ganzen Tag mit ihren Redaktionen wohl. Bei welchem Social Media Sternchen ist gerade im Profil was gelöscht worden und warum? Mit wem ist Pedro Lombardi offenbar nicht mehr zusammen, wenn das Foto nicht mehr da ist.
Also hier gibt es eine Nikki38, die sagt, ich war zwölf Jahre lang in einer Beziehung und habe nie etwas über ihn gepostet oder online über ihn gesprochen. Wir haben uns kürzlich getrennt und ich glaube nicht, dass ich jemals einen Mann posten werde, denn auch wenn ich romantisch bin, habe ich immer noch das Gefühl, dass Männer einen selbst nach zwölf Jahren in Verlegenheit bringen können.
Aber das klingt jetzt so, als sei das, also ich meine es ist ja eine Frage der Social-Media-Nutzung selbstredend, aber ich wäre jetzt auch nicht jemand, der dafür plädiert, dass man sich die Namen der Liebsten auf die Haut tätowiert. Das kann böse enden, aber kann.
Genau, ich will auch gar nicht tiefer einsteigen.
Während ich jetzt sage, ja aber bei Social Media verstehe ich das jetzt nicht so ganz. Also ich verstehe die Kritik allgemein, dass man beispielsweise einer Influencerin folgt, dann bekommt sie einen Freund und man bekommt irgendwann nur noch den Freund und nicht mehr die Influencerin zu sehen. Und man ist aber eigentlich mal gefolgt, weil man Modetipps haben wollte. Und dann denkt man, was soll das jetzt? Aber was ich jetzt nicht so ganz nachvollziehen kann, ist zu sagen, ich poste das gar nicht, denn man weiß ja nicht, was in zwölf Jahren ist. Ja gut, das kann man generell nicht machen. Man kann es ja aber löschen wieder.
Ja, man will nicht in Verlegenheit gebracht werden, was man halt würde, wenn man im Nachhinein erklären muss, wer das denn da war, warum der nicht mehr da ist und wie auch immer. Und dann blokiert man lieber gleich nur an seinem Selbstbild, da, wo man es unter Kontrolle hat, rum. Also verstehe ich schon ganz gut. Sie kommt hier zu sprechen auf den Delusional Diaries Podcast. Dem stellt man sich auch die eine oder andere Frage, wie zum Beispiel, warum fühlt es sich republikanisch an, einen Freund zu haben? Die beiden, die den Podcast machen, haben aber selber beide Freunde und verstehen sich als progressiv.
Interessanterweise, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gehört hast, unterstellt ja jetzt auch Taylor Lawrence und viele weitere. Also sie bezieht sich da auf einige, die ich alle nicht kannte, dass jetzt gerade Taylor Swift so einen Shift macht, einmal zum Threat Wife, obwohl sie ja die Red-Winnerin ist, also sie verdient mehr als ihr Mann.
Naja, Threat Wife, also Threat Wife ist schon eine Praxis, die ich bei Taylor Swift gar nicht sehe.
Nein, in der Inszenierung jetzt, wie Taylor Swift sich neuerdings inszeniert auf ihrem Album und auch in den sozialen Medien und dass man sagt, jetzt, da sie ihren Freund hat und ihn auch heiraten wird, würde man dort diese mehr republikanischen Vibes vernehmen. Das wird von Taylor Lawrence als Opportunismus an die herrschende Ordnung interpretiert. Ich bin da nicht tief genug drin und werde mir jetzt auch keinen Urteil über Taylor Swift und ihren Freund und Mann hier anmaßen. Ich finde nur interessant, weil du das gerade sagst, dass das da auch so rezipiert wurde, jetzt da die Hochzeit nahe ist und alldem hat sie eher so eine Interpretation erfahren im Internet, die sagt, ja sie ist vielleicht doch eher so republikanisch, obwohl sie mal Kamala Harris endorsed hat.
Also Chatwife ist eine spezifische Praxis, nämlich in der Küche zu stehen, sich Aufgaben zu widmen und so weiter. Bei Taylor Swift sehe ich die aristokratische Frau, die unabhängig selbst entscheidet, mit welchen Männern sie verkehrt. Und es kann auch immer derselbe sein. Das gehört zur Freiheit.
Aber die Threat Drive Influencerin ist ja wiederum die Unternehmerin. Das heißt, die spielt ja nur die Hausfrau und propagiert ein Hausfrauenideal, dem sie ja gar nicht entspricht, weil sie enorm viel Geld mit ihrem Threat Drive Dasein verdient. Und jetzt wurde gesagt, dass wohl bei Taylor Swift das immer mehr in diese Richtung gehe.
Ja, das kann auch immer so irgendwie über Interpretation und so.
Das werden wir überprüfen. Mir fiel es jetzt nur gerade auf, weil du sagtest, da gibt es diese Nähe.
Ja, also es könnte durchaus sein, dass es jetzt einfach uncool ist, einen Boyfriend zu haben, weil man dann in Erklärungsnöte kommt, im Sinne von, bist du dir selbst nicht genug? Warum belastest du dich so? Sind Boyfriends nicht einfach nur Klatsch und Ratsch-Angelegenheit? Also auf Themen-Ebene, wo man das akzeptiert, im Sinne von, also hat man nicht sehr viel mehr Spaß damit, mit seinen Freundinnen darüber zu reden, wie die Dates nicht klappen. Das alle einfach nur davon erzählen, dass sie jetzt nach Hause müssen oder von zu Hause erzählen und wie auch immer. Also es gibt hier diesen Shift.
Aber kann man nicht auch die Beziehung einfach so gestalten, dass das nicht als dieses Entweder-oder ist?
Ja, das schwingt ja hier mit, dass auf strukturellen Ebenen die Leute, die Frauen, die das so beschreiben und diskutieren, immer in Beziehung sind. Diese Podcaster, die Autoren selbst hier und so. Aber der letzte Satz. Wo beginnt er? Hier. Dies geschieht auch parallel zu einer Welle von Frauen, die ihr Single-Leben zurückerobern und romantisieren. War Single sein früher noch eine warnende Geschichte, du wirst als alte Jungfahrer mit vielen Katzenenden, so wird es heute zu einem begehrten und erstrebenswerten Status, ein weiterer Nagel im Sarg eines Jahrhunderter alten heterosexuellen Märchens, von dem Frauen von Anfang an nie wirklich profitiert haben. Also es steckt auch so eine politische und missionarische Komponente da drin, dass das hier thematisiert wird. Aber ich finde es trotzdem interessant, denn ich will nur immer wieder betonen, die zweite Generation mit besseren Schulabschlüssen, die erste Generation mit höheren Einstiegsgehältern, diese Studienlage wird das ganz deutlich zeigen, es ist nicht der Gender Pay Gap, es ist die Child Penalty. Und solange hier keine Kinder geboren werden, leben die Frauen schon in einer sehr anderen Welt als die Männer, die sich immer noch, YouTube hauptsächlich, darum Gedanken machen, wie sie jetzt zu einer Freundin kommen. Wie klappt es denn auch mit der Freundin?
Zum Schluss, Musik. Countertenöre hören wir manchmal in der Oper, wenn wir in einer Barock-Oper sind zum Beispiel, wenn wir uns eine Händel-Oper anhören. Ich will einen Countertenor vorstellen, der ganz vorzüglich ist, Alois Mühlbacher. Er war schon Sängerknabe, hat dann eine unglaubliche junge Karriere gemacht, ist jetzt noch keine 30 Jahre alt, ist auf allen wichtigen Bühnen der Welt zu Hause. Er hat ein eigenes Ensemble gegründet, Palidor, das wird hier bei seiner Aufnahme geleitet von Franz Farnberger. Alois Mühlbacher hat Bach-Kantaten eingesungen. Countertenöre sind ja Männer, die sehr hoch singen können, die in Alt- und sogar Sopran-Höhen vordringen können, die aber dann eine Sprechstimme haben, die eher baritonal bis Bass ist. Sie haben eine Stimme, die nicht so klingt in der Regel, wie die Stimme einer Frau klingen würde, sondern es ist dieses, ja, knabenhafte drin. Und das können wir bei Alois Mühlbacher wirklich auf ganz wunderbare Weise hören. Es ist eine Stimme, die eine enorme Textverständlichkeit trotz der Höhe und auch der Virtuosität dieser Arian hat. Es ist fast an manchen Stellen, als würde er mit dieser Stimme sprechen und gar nicht singen. So klar, so deutlich ist es. Aber dabei ist es doch alles so melodiös gesungen. Es ist eine Stimme, die sehr flexibel ist, die Koloraturen kann, die vor allem auch sehr lange Bögen halten kann, ohne ein großes Vibrato zu haben. Die ja mit Verzierungen arbeiten kann, die nötig sind. Wenn man beispielsweise Barock Arian singt, da hat man ja immer diese Struktur A, B, A. Also der erste Teil, der zweite Teil und der erste, der A-Teil, wird wiederholt und der wiederholte Teil wird dann verziert. Er hat sich hier entschieden, ganz auf Bach-Kantaten zu gehen. Also Bach hat ja 325 Kirchen-Kantaten geschrieben, so schätzt man, innerhalb von nur 5 Jahren. 200 sind erhalten. Er hat dabei auch Material recycelt. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als wären das alles Kompositionen, die nur aus sich heraus entstanden sind. Aber trotzdem ist dieses Pensum unglaublich, das er geleistet hat. Und diese Kantaten, also ein paar dieser Kantaten, hören wir hier auf der neuen CD. Da ist einmal die Kantate, Ich habe genug, Bach Werkverzeichnis 82, bei der wir auch merken, das ist eine ganz andere Haltung zur Welt, eine ganz andere Subjektivität. Also wir springen ja hier etwa 300 Jahre zurück. Und da heißt es, ich habe genug. Ich habe den Heiland, das Hoffnen der Frommen, auf meine begierigen Arme genommen. Ich habe genug. Ich habe ihn erblickt, mein Glaube an Jesum ans Herz gedrückt. Nun wünsche ich, noch heute mit Freuden von hinten zu scheiden. Also dieser Wunsch nach dem Tod, der elegisch vorgetragen wird. Denn ich habe genug. Dieser Alois Mühlbacher hat einen wunderbaren Schmelz. Das ist ganz fantastisch zu hören. Aber es geht auch durchaus noch intensiver auf den Tod zu. So gibt es da beispielsweise in dieser Kantate Ich habe genug auch das Stück Ich freue mich auf meinen Tod. Bach schlägt da ganz festliche jubilierende Töne an und der Text lautet Ich freue mich auf meinen Tod. Ach, hätte er sich schon eingefunden, da entkomme ich aller Not, die mich noch auf der Welt gebunden. Ich sage ja eine ganz andere Subjektivität ist das, die wir hier erleben, aber eine wirklich berührende, vor allem mit dieser Stimme, wenn auch die Stimme in den Dialog treten kann, mit einer Oboe. Es ist ganz wunderbare Musik. Ich bin froh, dass wir so viele gute Countertenöre haben. Alois Mühlbacher ist ein ganz verzücklicher, weil die Stimme immer etwas Rundes hat, etwas sehr Verständliches. Es ist nie spitz oder stechend, wenn er in die Höhe geht. Ich bin begeistert von dieser Gestaltungslust, die man da hören kann, diese Gestaltungskraft. Und es ist eine CD oder ein Album, man kann es natürlich überall hören, das ich allen sehr ans Herz lege.
Und spielt er auch? Kann man ihn auch auf der Opernbühne sehen?
Ja.
Sehr gut. Ich höre vielleicht einige zu, die denken, ah, diese Männer, die so hochsingen und so. Ich war ja auch skeptisch. Aber nach der coolen Premiere 2024, wir haben es damals auch gesehen, Giulio Cesare in Egitto von Handel, wird gerade wiedergespielt und ich habe nochmal Tickets geholt.
Ah, schön.
Und diesmal zu dritt dachte ich mir, ich kenne es ja schon. Und ich weiß, wie es aus Nahen aussieht. Kostüme sind natürlich überwältigend cool. Es ist ja auch in so einer antiken, hier stehen Säulen rum und so. Nur das Bühnenbild wird ja rechts und links hin und her geschoben, wie Comic-Dinger. Große Comic-Quadrate. Also habe ich mir für Reihe 17 einen Platz gebucht, weil der Sitz, also da ist ja die Akustik entsprechend ausgeglichen. Wird mal sehr gespannt. Nächste Woche. Wir gehen ja heute auch. Vier Stunden.
Aber wir wollen, bevor wir hier schließen, noch die Termine für den Salon nennen. Für den Live-Salon. Viermal sind wir wieder in der CAS zu erleben. Nennen uns doch bitte mal die vier Termine. Also wieder einmal im Quartal. Der erste Termin ist der März.
Ganz wichtig. Diese gibt es nicht per E-Mail, sondern es ist jetzt ein reguläres Ticketing-System. Jeder Salon, die ich jetzt nenne, die vier, hat ein eigener Ticket-Link. Und es gibt jeweils 200 Tickets in der CAS. Freitag, der 20. März 2026. Freitag, der 19. Juni. Freitag, der 18. September. Und Freitag, der 18. Dezember. Wir haben also immer Freitagstermine. Freitagstermine sind das Beste überhaupt. Die Woche ist noch nicht ganz rum. Man kann zu uns kommen und chillen und danach jedes Wochenende in Frankfurt verbringen. Wir gucken uns den Opernplan an, wenn er dann, je nachdem und so. Und vielleicht machen wir wieder so ein Halligalli-Doppelspiel.
Wir werden für März auch noch einen Termin nennen, dass wir vorher etwas besuchen. Da haben wir ja schon was ausgeguckt. Das sagen wir dann auch noch an. Jetzt noch zum Schluss, was wir als nächstes lesen. Wir werden uns ja mit dem neuen Buch von Branko Milanovic beschäftigen. Das erscheint in zehn Tagen.
Diesmal steht es schon fest.
Es erscheint erst mal nur auf Englisch, aber trotzdem denken wir, ist das jetzt wichtig, es sofort zu besprechen. Es wird bestimmt auch noch übersetzt werden, aber wir wollen uns gleich drauf stürzen.
Ich freue mich schon drauf, weil wir da eine Lektüre haben, bei der auf gar keinen Fall droht, dass dir das Ökonomische zu kurz kommt.
Bis dann.